Moin, ich habe nichts besseres zu tun heute vormittag wobei vormittag ist ja nicht mehr
außer meinen zweiten chart zu leveln
habe ich mir gedacht ich mache einfach mal strieb an auch wenn es die meisten wahrscheinlich
absolut gar nicht juckt
Ich bin noch ein bisschen erkältet weiß nicht
was da los ist
was auch immer
Moin
mal kurz chat auf
Moin, heute gibt es sinnlos kreisel grind
aber nicht mit dem chart hier
Ich hoffe dass plörn vom chat funktioniert ganz brauchbar
homeoffice stream
wie gesagt sinnlos mmo kreisel grind
Ich habe
ein chart gelevelt
Jetzt level ich meinen scalde weiter den habe ich ja auch season one gespielt hauptsächlich
sodass ich zweigleisig aufgestellt bin dass ich spielen kann was gerade gerade passt und ich dachte mir hast du was
aber einfach stream an
ich sage euch gleich das wird langweilig dark pv ist
alles ich glaube zum zuschauen
eines der langweiligsten sachen die es überhaupt gibt ja
Dementsprechend gibt es auch entspannte
10 stunden fantasy
ambient music im hintergrund ich hoffe die lautstärke passt ganz gut
und
ich level jetzt erst mal mein
zweiten charme
aber nicht den hier nicht den hier
Chat sollte man hoffentlich nicht lesen können weil es ist gegen die serverregeln
Genau
also soll ich sagen
Vielleicht falls schon jemand da ist das spiel nicht kennt wovon ich ausgehe ich meine das ist 20 jahre alt
Das kam 2001 oder so raus
Das ist Dark Edge of Camelot
Das beste PvP
MMO, was je gemacht wurde
Weiß, werden sich dann
Die ESO Leute und die Guild Wars Leute
Und so streiten sich wieder, aber
Ja
Für mich das beste PvP MMO, was je gemacht wurde
Ich hoffe die Game-Lautstärke und so
Passt auch alles
Und da ist vor
Am Dienstag
Ne, am Samstag
Am Samstag
Am Samstag ist die zweite Season
Auf dem Eden Free Chart gestartet
Denn ihre Webseite
Ist ein bisschen pepeger, aber okay
Könnte auch am Dark Reader liegen
Naja, ist ein bisschen besser
Und ich spiele einmal im Jahr
Immer so 2, 3, 4 Monate
Je nachdem
Wie lang die Season so gut läuft
Gut geht, spiele ich immer
2, 3, 4 Monate
3, 4 Monate
Spiele ich immer im Jahr noch so
Meistens auf dem Free Chart
Die Live-Server
Die Live-Server kann man ja im Endeffekt vergessen
Da habe ich auch gar keinen Bock drauf
Da sind auch die ganzen Klassen nicht wieder zu erkennen
Du hast bei Gamigo gearbeitet
Okay, Gamigo hat ja nicht unbedingt den besten Ruf gehabt
Das ist ein
Pre-World of Warcraft Game
Ja
Und nicht wundern, dass ich ein bisschen schnupfen habe
Ist nicht schlimm, aber
Ja, deswegen mir ist heute auch nicht so fair
Wie gesagt, der Katze geht es ja auch nicht gut
Deswegen mir ist heute nicht so sehr danach
Irgendwie große Haierkette, aber ja, das ist ja auch so
Ich level im zweiten Chart
Wir müssen jetzt noch mal eine Sache checken
Leute
Und zwar, ob die Helligkeit
Okay ist
Weil das Spiel kann in der Nacht
Relativ dunkel werden
Also ich glaube, ich muss erstmal
Ein bisschen für mich die Helligkeit hochdrehen
Aber das seht ihr ja nicht, gell
Wenn ich das hier ändere, das sehe nur ich
Müssen wir mal schauen
Richtig krasser Kreisel, Klein
Müssen wir mal schauen, ich hoffe
Ich hoffe, Vodafone macht mit
Ich werde spielen bis heute Abend
Ich werde spielen, soweit ich komme
Und dann spätestens am Wochenende auch den Scharf 50 machen
Aber scheint zu funktionieren
Und heute Abend machen wir vielleicht tatsächlich noch eine Runde normalen Stream
Und gucken uns Doge an
Ja, genau
Also, falls einer Bock hat, mal Oldschool MMO zu spielen
Der muss erstmal mit der Grafik klarkommen
Das ist noch eine der schöneren Ecken hier im Spielraum
Ich logge mal auf den Char, um den ich eigentlich spielen will jetzt
Wir spielen, ich spiele den gleichen Char weiter, den ich auch Season 1 gespielt habe
Nur das halt resettet wurde
Für Season 2
Wie gesagt, die Grafik
Muss man erstmal klar mitkommen
Selbst wenn man Bock hat, sich ältere Games anzugucken
Also
Die Grafiks
Hm
Sieht man halt schon, die Grafiks sind jetzt halt schon
Ein bisschen 2001
Aber das Spiel ist halt auch von 2001
Aber zum Glück sieht man seine Trailer
Und zwar ist es nicht so groß
Oh, fuck
Jetzt wird das Game crashen gleich
Ne, wird nicht
Wird nicht
Und was wichtig ist
Hier, Reshade
Reshade anmachen
Weil guckt mal
Vielleicht fällt euch das auf
Das Game ist halt auch ein bisschen unscharf
So
Guckt mal
Guckt euch mal die Namen an
Und guckt euch mal hier die ganzen Sachen an
Und ich mach mal aus wieder
Die Grafik Enhancements
Sieht halt schon ein bisschen plass aus
Und ein bisschen
Mach mal die Lampe an
Und nicht so farbenfroh
Und ein bisschen verschwommen
Was aber auch daran liegt
Dass
Das Game halt noch für CRT-Monitore entwickelt wurde
Und auf CRT-Monitoren sah das deutlich farbenfroher aus
Als jetzt auf aktuellen Monitoren
So
Und deswegen
Mach ich Reshade an
Und mit Reshade
Sieht das deutlich mehr aus
Wie man das auch noch von CRTs in
GC quitt
Keine Gilde mehr
Die Leute haben keinen Bock mehr
Bist du deiner Zeitschleier?
Ja schon
So
Wo sind wir hier überhaupt?
Ist die Musik eigentlich okay?
Die Musik ist ein bisschen lauter
Bisschen lautes Fantasy Gedudel im Hintergrund
Mein Problem ist
Hier
Auf 80 runter
Relaxing
Relaxing Medieval Fantasy Music Ambience
Ach ich glaub passt eigentlich ganz gut
Die Dark Background Musik ist auch gar nicht so schlecht entspannend
So
Ich bin Level 1 wieder
Letzte Season war ich mit dem Cha
Oh geil jetzt steck ich den Boden drin
Letzte Season war ich mit dem
Besser Name auch
Mit dem war ich
Das ist nicht sonderlich gut
Ich hab auch die letzte Season nicht so lange gespielt
Was daran lag
Weil irgendwie meine ganzen Guild-Mails keinen Bock mehr hatten
Nach kurzer Zeit
Ich war gestern
Ich war glaube ich 6L8 oder sowas
Und da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr
Weiß nicht sieht man das hier vielleicht
Irgendwo
Ne sieht man glaube ich erst später
Es wurde ja alles
Resettet
Sieht nur noch den Titel
Wurde alles Resettet
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz in Charplaner reingucken
Wie man das
Wie ich das am besten mache für
Ab Level 10
Lass mal kurz gucken
Ich brauch immer Speed
Und ich brauch immer
Halbwegs einen ordentlichen Style
Okay Battle Songs
Max Level muss sein
Ach Water Breathing gibt es schon auf Level 10
Wusste ich gar nicht
Nice
Dann muss ich mir um Tränke keine Sorgen machen
Das ist sehr nice
Mir war gar nicht bewusst
Das es das schon auf Level 10
Gab
Ich dachte eigentlich das das
Später erst kam
Aber okay
Ich will mich mal
Ich will mich nicht beschweren
Ah das ist bloß wie schnell man unter Wasser ist
Ja gut
So
Und dann brauchen wir irgendwie einen halbwegs gescheiten Style
Irgendwie sowas
Ah das ist gut
Ah peilen wir mal an mit Level 11
Irgendwie sowas
Oh ne machen wir nicht
Wir machen nicht Hammer wir machen Schwert
Da gibt es den Taunt auf Level 6
Ah
So machen wir das am Anfang erstmal
Ja Leute das ist Dark Age of Camelot
Ein MMO Pre World of Warcraft
Ära
Und für mich das beste PvP Spiel das es gibt
Nachdem ich den Char schon in Season 1
Gespielt habe
Das ist privater Server
Da sieht man ja auch das da ordentlich was los ist
Aktuell sind 344 Spieler online
In Midgard
Und in Hip und Alp
Ist auch ungefähr ähnlich
Und es ist früh also ich würde sagen
Ich weiß gar nicht ob die Spielerzahlen veröffentlichen
Die hatten doch hier sowas
Die hatten doch Spieler
Zahlen
Statistiken irgendwo
Oder
Server Population
Ne die haben keine
Performance Performance
Ah die haben keine Server
Also ich glaube abends sind so 3000
3500 Leute vielleicht on
Das ist tatsächlich relativ viel
Ja aber das liegt auch daran
Der einzige Freeshot den es zurzeit gibt
Und die offiziellen Server will keiner mehr spielen
Die offiziellen Server haben
Hallo
Ähm
Die offiziellen Server haben glaub ich irgendwie 200
Spieler Gesamt oder so abends
Aber das liegt auch daran
Weil gerade Season 2
Gestartet ist am Dienstag
Äh nicht am Dienstag am Samstag
Am Samstag ist Season 2 gestartet
Und
Die haben saumäßig viel gemacht
Also eins muss man ohne Scheiß
Mal sagen
Die Eden Leute
Die kümmern sich viel viel besser um das Game
Als äh wie heißen sie
Broadsword glaub ich
Die offiziellen Server Betreiber jetzt
Warum ist das Game so gut
Weil Best Game Ever
Fragt mal den Midgard BG Leader
Dann wird er das ins Ohr schreien
Das es Best Game Ever ist
Um das Game so gut ist
Also das werdet ihr heute wahrscheinlich nur ansatzweise sehen
Weil wir spielen heute zum größten Teil
Leveln ich bin Level 1
Im Tutorial Gebiet
Also das beste an dem Game ist
Tatsächlich das PvP
Solo Gruppe Duo
Trio vollkommen egal
PvP
Ist eigentlich
Also das ist das Game
Wo sogar Casuals
Gerne PvP gespielt haben
Das hat glaub ich kein anderes Game
Irgendwie geschafft
So wir machen jetzt kurz das Tutorial durch bis Level 10
Und dann machen wir
Mega langweilige Kill Quests
Eventuell
Eventuell gehe ich auch in Battleground
Und sammle 1-2
Rp's
Das ich schneller Sprinten
Oder nicht schneller Sprinten ist falsch
Länger Ausdauer zum Sprinten sammeln kann
Ja
Tutorial Quests
Easy as fuck
Man rennt hier hin killt ein paar Schweine
So wie das im Prinzip
Alle MMO's fangen doch an mit
Kille 5 Schweine
5 Ratten oder sowas
Alle oder
Ich hab übrigens auch die alten Models
Dementsprechend
Sieht das auch nochmal so richtig schlecht aus
Wir können mal gleich gucken
Das wir Leute invite
Ich invite den Ludmar
Weil
Gucken ob er Bock hat
Will er nicht
Weil das ist gar nicht schlecht wenn man Leute invite hat
Dann kriegt man schneller Quests
Aber gut wenn er keinen Bock hat dann nicht
Es ist überall sinnlos
Es ist sinnlos Mob gebashe
Oh shit
Ich kann keine Game kill
Okay
Oh ich muss mein
Ich muss mein Chat
Ein bisschen verkleinern
Guckt er
Alter seriously
Alter was mit den Wachen
Los man
Ich werde von ner fucking Level 1
Wildsau gebasht man
Wachen please
Ey die haben keinen Bock
Die wollen nicht
Die haben einfach
Okay jetzt wildsau haut ab
Geil beste
So ich muss den Chat mal kurz ein bisschen kleiner machen
Mal kurz schauen das das so passt
Ob so ist gut
Ja
Alles geblucht
Streamen wir mal dahin
Moin Dr. Chaos
So also gelbe Mops sind
Zu hart für mich
Wie es aussieht
Erstmal hier kryptische
Set Camera
Camera
Erstmal kryptische Shell Befehle
Weil Oldschool MMO
Übrigens für Leute die es früher gespielt haben
Lampe an ist kein Noob Signal mehr
Die haben das auf Eden geändert
Das die Lampe man nur selbst sieht und die anderen nicht
Im Main Game
War das früher so wenn man die Lampe im Dunkeln angemacht hat
Dann haben einen quasi die Gegner
Gefühlt über die halbe Map gesehen
Deswegen hat man nie Lampe angemacht
Aber jetzt kann man Lampe anmachen
Und auch Gamma ein bisschen hoch gedreht
Sollte eigentlich alles
So weit passen
Und auf die Frage hin
Warum das best Game ever ist
Oh boi ich muss rein leachen
Ich muss rein leachen
Bam
Rein leachen
Hau drauf Kollege
Du kannst nicht casten während dich der Mob hittet
Wir machen den Fehler und wollen
Nice
Cake Wait
Und auf die Frage hin warum das das beste MMO ist
Ganz einfach
Wartet mal kurz
Äh wir müssen mal kurz
Den Blur
Filter
Ich mach einfach mal ein Chat ein Stückchen
größer
Du hast die Fasten als beste
Ein Stückchen größer hier unten
Ja genau hau drauf
Und lass mich mit bashen
Der Fabian
Den habe ich schon versucht zu überreden
Vielleicht am Wochenende ja
mal gucken ich sollte die dudes in weiten er alles deutlich das ist deutlich einfacher mit
mehreren leuten aber da will nicht oder es ist deutlich einfacher wenn man das mit mehreren
leuten machte so fertig ja mal gucken ob der fabian will also es ist so ich muss ab und zu
mal ein bisschen den chat gucken sind wir hier also ist es so das game hat wie soll ich das
erklären wenn man das war das nicht kennt du hast eigentlich grundsätzlich zwei verschiedene
zwei verschiedene reiche du hast quasi es gibt es gibt es gibt drei verschiedene reiche als
die story ist wohl schnell drei verschiedene reiche im krieg miteinander bla bla bla moment
und
wir müssen noch wir müssen noch mal kurz eine wildsau hauen und man kann sich am anfang aussuchen
in welchem reich man spielen will ich habe in albion mit grab das wird jetzt mein den habe
ich hauptsächlich habe ich gespielt die die erste season und ich habe mir so ein alt christus und
jetzt hier noch ein mitgab und es gibt quasi eine grenzfestung in jedem bereich alles dahinter ist
pvp gebiet und alles davor ist
spider skillen und alles davor ist pvp gebiet wobei das tatsächlich etwas etwas schwammig ist
die die definition weil es gibt auch so ein paar hybrid gebiete es gibt zum beispiel ein pvp
dungeon der ist zugänglich für alle reiche potenziell und da macht man pvp und pv gegen
monster und es gibt also es ist nicht so klar klar zu sagen und im endeffekt ich kann euch ja
mal kurz die die grenze aus vom grenzgebiet die map zeigen jedes der reich hat quasi ein
grenzgebiet mit festungen und türmen die können erobert werden aktuell sieht man die alps kriegen
auf den sack wie immer wie auf jedem server gefühlt zumindest am anfang sie haben quasi
nur die hälfte ihrer festung und was passiert wenn man
die festung verliert es folgenden das slash relic also ganz ganz grobe übersicht ja jedes
reich hat zwei relikte ein stärkeres liegt und ein magier liegt das bringt glaube zehn
prozent schaden nahkampf zehn prozent schaden magic damage und das kann man wenn man die wenn
Wenn man die Festung erobert von dem gegnerischen Reich, dann kann man zur Reliktfestung das Relikt klauen.
Und dann kriegt man halt selbst die 10%.
Die 10% Damage Plus oder Magie Plus.
Das heißt, eigentlich fighten sich da konstant alle drüber.
Und das Spiel hat auch, ich glaube, der Verreckler, ja.
Das Spiel hat auch keine Trennung zwischen PvP und PvE-Stats.
Ich muss ein bisschen Ausrüstung anziehen, ich habe nur noch nichts.
Das heißt, keine Trennung zwischen PvE und PvP-Stats.
Also sprich, oh fuck, wir kriegen auf den Sack vom gelben Mob, man.
Und dementsprechend bringt es auch allgemein dann was für niceres Pv...
Fuck, Alter, wir kriegen auf den Sack von einem popeligen Level 2-Mob, man, hoffentlich.
Okay, okay, ich glaube, wir haben, potenziell schaffen wir das.
Okay, nein.
Und dementsprechend bist du bei allem besser, wenn du in einem Bereich besser bist.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal trainieren gleich.
Also so ganz grob die Übersicht zum Game und wie es halt so ist bei so richtig Oldschool-Spielen.
Du hast sehr viele etwas unklare Mechanics.
Wir gehen jetzt da hin und holen uns einmal Speed, dass wir schneller rennen können.
Oh, nice.
Ein bisschen unklare Mechanics im Endeffekt, weil fängt schon an mit den Stats bei der Charaktererstellung.
Was müssen wir jetzt machen?
Ah, Wölfe killen, okay, nice.
Ich muss mal kurz trainieren.
Train, Battle Songs.
Train, okay, nice.
Battle Songs, Speed.
Damage.
Ja, haben wir noch nicht.
Moment, ja, wir sollten uns übrigens Ausrüstung kaufen, fällt mir gerade so auf.
Aber jetzt killen wir erstmal.
Ich meine, die können ja nicht viel, die Mobs.
Ja, also es ist gerade für Einsteiger nicht so...
Also ich finde, das Game lohnt sich heute immer noch.
Also für mich ist es das beste PvP-MMO, was hier gemacht wurde.
Zumindest allein schon die Stats blickt halt jemand, der neu ist, nicht.
Weil, seriously, Leute.
Warte, okay.
Chat, mal so eine Frage an euch.
Es gibt ja, es gibt natürlich auch keine Hilfe irgendwie in dem Game.
Okay, was denkt ihr, was Stärke als Stat macht?
Das ist noch relativ easy.
Stärke ist also quasi das, was man denkt.
Stärke ist Nahkampf-Damage, okay?
Das kann man sich noch irgendwie denken.
Ja, genau, hitze den Mob von dem Typ.
Nice Idee.
Fuck.
So, gleich haben wir die Wölfe fertig.
Okay, fertig.
GG.
Und also, Stärke ist Nahkampf-Damage.
Das, da kommt man noch ungefähr hin.
Ja, Konstitution ist, äh, ja, Leben.
Und jetzt, jetzt geht's aber schon los.
So, oh, da ist einer dead.
So, Geschicklichkeit ist für Ranged.
Damage, das ist okay.
Kann man sich vorstellen für Bogendamage und so.
Rangedamage, okay, kann man sich vorstellen.
Ja, aber, so einfach ist das Ganze nicht.
Dex ist auch Castspeed, nicht etwa Quickness.
Das ist halt so ein Ding, das checkt niemand, wenn man das Spiel nicht kennt.
Man würde vermuten, Quickness ist Castspeed, aber nein, Quickness ist nur Millespeed.
Und Dex ist Castspeed.
Allerdings auch gleichzeitig Rangedamage.
Und, äh, Primary Stats, ja.
Es ist nicht so, nicht so klar alles.
Was ist denn das?
Das hab ich noch nie gesehen, was ist das?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
So, jetzt muss man hier die Invader-Skill...
Er fragt mich gerade welchen AR ich war in Season 1.
Ich glaub ich hatte 6 oder 7.
Aber hauptsächlich Rumgezerge.
Mit, mit den Leuten mit denen ich gespielt hab.
Ich brauch, ich brauch mal ne Waffe.
Ich, okay, ich brauch erstmal ne Rüstung.
Okay, neue Waffe.
Armlinge.
Juwel, okay, perfekt, immerhin. Jetzt mach ich ein bisschen Damage. So, genau, wo wir gerade bei den Stats gewesen sind. Also, Dex ist Cast Speed, wo man sich auch denkt, okay, man weiß es nicht, man mag in Dark Souls auch so sein, okay, vielleicht denkt sich das der ein oder andere heute, tatsächlich, kann sein.
Aber damals war es extrem weird, Champ, zumal Dex auch nicht nur Range Damage ist, Cast Speed, Dex ist auch Staff Damage, falls man mit Stab unterwegs ist. Es gibt eine Klasse, die kämpft hauptsächlich mit Stab und die ist 100% Dex.
Und ein Kumpel von mir damals, der Carsten, den kennt ihr vielleicht noch, wo ich mit dem Fabian unterwegs war, wir haben ja öfters mit dem Carsten gespielt, das ist so mit Carsten los.
Und der Carsten hat quasi eine Klasse gespielt, die hauptsächlich mit Stab verwendet hat und der hat damals die Entwickler angeschrieben, welche Start Stats er nehmen soll.
Und die haben ihm gesagt, nehm Stärke für Nahkampf Stab Damage, damit war er komplett verskillt. Er hatte 100% Dex skillen müssen.
Also, das ist eine Zeit, die Entwickler wussten selber nicht, was man skillen soll, ja.
Also, insofern.
Ja, es war doch, Can't wait Zeit, ne.
Achso, ich hab jetzt gar nicht geguckt, ob wir done sind.
Wir sind done.
Kompetent, inkompetent.
Ja, ich seh übrigens gerade, ich muss mal XP einblenden, Level XP.
Dass man auch was sieht hier, so.
Ja, und weiter geht's.
Also, das hab ich mich drüber ausgelassen.
So, Quickness, Quickness ist entgegen auch der offiziellen Beschreibung.
In dem Game, also im Game damals, ist Quickness nur Melee, also Meleespeed, Nahkampfspeed.
So, Intelligenz kann man sich wieder denken an Stats.
Intelligenz ist, mir fehlt ein Mob für XP, man.
Ja, es wird Kreiselcrank gemacht bis heute Abend.
Ah, muss die Cloudstärke, passt ganz gut.
Ja, also Intelligenz kann man sich denken, das ist für Cast Damage.
Passt ja soweit.
Empathie ist auch so ein Ding, niemand weiß, wofür das Stat wirklich da ist.
Also damals zu Release, wusste niemand, wofür das wirklich da ist, das Stat.
Und der Witz ist, Empathie macht bei so gut wie keinem Char irgendwas.
Außer du spielst Hibernia, nein, das ist nicht für Magiestärke.
Es sei denn, du spielst Hibernia, die sind ja so naturaffin.
Dort ist es für Heiler und Caster.
Wobei ich glaube sogar...
Dort ist Caster int.
Ja, ja, doch, doch, Caster sind dort auch int.
Also Empathie braucht niemand in diesem Spiel.
Niemand muss Empathie skillen, außer du spielst einen Heiler in Hipp.
Dann hast du Piety, oder auf Deutsch hieß das Frömmigkeit.
Frömmigkeit brauchst du in Albion als Heiler.
Und in Midgard ist es für alle Caster notwendig.
Weil in Midgard, so Odin und Thor und so, die müssen ganz besonders gläubig sein.
Damit sie Damage machen können beim Casten.
Wo müssen wir jetzt hin?
Ah, den Commander killen.
Typisch Bio-Break.
So kurz warten, bis er vom Klo wieder da ist.
Und Charisma...
Charisma lohnt sich, glaube ich, bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher aus dem Kopf,
aber ich glaube, Charisma ist nur relevant für ganze drei Klassen im gesamten Spiel.
Nämlich Skalde, Bade oder Minnesänger.
Für Mana Pool...
Und ich glaube auch Damage-Varianz bei den Spells.
Also insofern, ohne Scheiß, das Game checkt halt niemand.
Du musst erst mal einen kennen, der es kennt, oder Wiki lesen, dass du es verstehst.
Also es ist super kryptisch, auf jeden Fall.
Ich muss aber ehrlich sagen, ich habe das so verinnerlicht alles.
Für mich ist es kein Problem mehr.
Es ist genauso wie Resistenzen.
Resistenzen sind quasi gecapt bei 26 auf Level 50.
Und da fragt man sich jetzt natürlich, okay, warum ausgerechnet 26?
Weil es gibt verschiedene Buff-Modifier oder Stat-Modifier.
Und in dem Fall ist es Level durch 2 plus 1.
Und wenn man das nicht weiß, denkt man sich halt, hä, warum genau 26?
Hä, 50 durch 2 plus 1.
Das ist halt so ein Ding, wenn du es nicht weißt, hast du halt gelitten einfach nur, hä.
So, jetzt müssen wir hier dieses Viech killen.
Dann haben wir das Tutorial auch fast schon fertig.
Bam.
Jetzt schreckt.
Zum Glück machen meine Shouts ordentlich Schaden.
Ey, gehst du weg?
Alter, taunte mir den weg.
Taunte mir den weg, Alter.
Hallo, hallo, taunte mir den Mob weg.
Geck weg.
Und das Game ist halt voll mit solchen Dingern.
So nach dem Motto, weißt es, dann ist gut.
Weißt es nicht, hast du verloren.
Aber es gibt ein ganz gutes Wiki dazu.
Es gab früher ein richtig gutes deutschsprachiges Wiki.
Das wird aber schon seit Jahren nicht mehr aktualisiert.
Und ja, blickt man halt nicht.
Zum Beispiel genauso, wenn du dich buffen lässt von Heilern.
Dann ist das Cap von Buffs auch super weird, wo auch keiner weiß, warum das so ist.
Du musst dann unterscheiden zwischen Spec-Buffs und Base-Buffs.
Die einen geben quasi 125%.
Die anderen, glaube ich, boah, weiß ich aus dem Kopf gar nicht mehr, irgendwie 75%.
Aber es ist super weird, ja.
Bringt auch gar nichts, wenn ich euch das jetzt erzähle.
Es ist halt echt undurchsichtig.
Also entweder man muss sich das nicht mehr verändern.
Oder man muss sich das nicht mehr verändern.
Oder man weiß, oder man hat halt gelitten.
So, habe ich irgendwie noch Schuhe, habe ich noch gekriegt.
Und einen Umhang, nice.
Ich muss jetzt eigentlich trainen, mal eine Runde.
So, was wir machen werden ist, Level 10.
Gehen wir in Battleground.
Versuchen PvP ein paar...
Habe ich überhaupt den richtigen...
Ups, ich kacke nur bei falscher Knopf.
Ähm...
Bei Level 10 versuche ich...
Es kommt drauf an.
Wir müssen mal gucken.
Wenn der weiter, wenn der weiter questen will, dann questen wir ein bisschen weiter.
Weil zu zweit ist es einfach deutlich, deutlich angenehmer als alleine.
Und dann machen wir kurz PvP und versuchen 1, 2 Kills zu machen.
Damit ich mir...
Mehr Ausdauer kaufen kann.
Also, in dem Game ist tatsächlich PvP nicht nur kosmetisch und nicht nur just for fun.
In dem Game ist...
Moment, ich zeige es euch mal ganz kurz, ohne dass ihr zu lange warten müsst.
Kannst du RRs kaufen.
Das sind Fähigkeiten, die kannst du dir kaufen.
Nur von Punkten, die du kriegst, wenn du Gegner killst.
Du musst Gegner nicht solo killen.
Das reicht auch, wenn du in der Gruppe drin bist, die Gegner killt.
Generell muss man sagen, das Game ist...
Ups, da müssen wir hin.
Das Game ist sehr, ja auch gruppenorientiert.
Die Gruppengröße ist 8.
Nicht wie das World of Warcraft etabliert hat, 5.
Die Gruppengröße hier ist 8.
Was sehr schöne, viele Varianten ermöglicht.
Was du spielen kannst.
Und gerade mit den Buffs für die unterschiedlichen Klassen hier, muss man sagen, du kannst hier erstaunlich viel spielen.
Das Spiel hat auch sehr viele verschiedene Klassen.
Also ich glaube, ich glaube jedes Reich hat so...
Albion hat die meisten, wenn ich es nicht...
Ich sage mal so im Durchschnitt, jedes Reich dürfte so um die 13 verschiedenen Klassen haben.
Was dann quasi ungefähr so irgendwie fast an die 40 Klassen macht.
Alles zusammen.
Und du kannst fast, ich sage fast, weil das ist nicht wirklich so...
Du kannst fast alles spielen im PvP.
Also wenn du mit mehreren Leuten rumläufst auf jeden Fall.
Wenn du so auf Elite PvP machst mit 8er Gruppe gegen 8er Gruppe, dann nicht wirklich.
Ups, den wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Dann nicht wirklich, dann kannst du nicht alles spielen.
Aber du kannst zum größten Teil...
Du kannst zum größten Teil tatsächlich alles spielen.
Ich kann euch nachher mal die Klassen...
Ich kann euch nachher die Klassen zeigen.
Also es gibt jede Menge.
Es ist eigentlich für jeden was dabei.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Du hast zu Beginn Graphics.
Kannst du das bitte nochmal zeigen?
Kann ich dir zeigen, aber das alleine wird dir nichts bringen, weil du brauchst Software dafür, dass das geht.
Ich kann dir aber zeigen, welche du brauchst.
Ey.
Wir rennen jetzt vor dem Mob einfach mal weg.
Wir rennen vor dem Mob weg und ich hoffe...
Ach komm.
Scheiß drauf, wir machen jetzt platt.
Oder.
Ich dachte nämlich, der hat kein Endo mehr und kommt nicht weg, der Dude.
Ja.
Also, wenn wir zurückfliegen, zeige ich dir das nochmal kurz.
Ja, weiß.
Also, du drückst POS 1 auf der Tastatur und kannst dann hier die Presets durchstellen.
Also aus, an, so die habe ich eingestellt.
Was du dazu brauchst ist Reshade.
Sag, Reshade.
Wie hieß das?
Reshade?
Ähm.
Ja, Reshade.
Musst du die runterladen?
Auf irgendwo...
Äh.
Wie hieß das?
Reshade?
Moment, ich bin gerade verwirrt.
Gleich.
Wir porten mal kurz weg.
Bin gleich wieder am Start.
Ich muss mal kurz Ausrüstung kaufen.
Ich frag dir mal, ob er weitermachen will.
Äh.
Haben wir hier irgendwas Gescheites, was ich mir kaufen kann?
Kunde, ähm.
Wollen wir kurz eine Waffe?
Ähm.
Great.
So.
Okay.
Train.
Ich brauch eigentlich Level 6 für den halbwegs gescheiten Anytimer zum taunten Train.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Also.
Was wollte ich jetzt, wollte ich dir erzählen?
Genau.
Also.
Du brauchst Reshade.
Stitan.
Kannst du hier runterladen für Dark.
Dann klickst du den Installer durch.
Und dann kannst du das mit diesem Shortcut in-Game aufmachen und anpassen, wie du willst.
Du musst aber gucken, dass du das erst anschaltest, nachdem du eingeloggt bist, weil wenn das läuft,
während du einloggst, also während der Char einloggt, dann crasht das Game mal ganz gerne.
Ich glaub, wir gehen mal in das SI-Gebiet.
So.
Dumm.
Verpasst.
So.
Draw out.
Ups.
Jetzt habe ich mich natürlich vorher mit Ausrüstung ausgerüstet, wobei, der hat ja auch, ich
hab kein Warnwort, kein Quade, Alter.
So.
Jetzt haben wir Quests angenommen.
Im Endeffekt können wir jetzt durch das Gebiet hier laufen, random Mobs killen und dafür
dick XP kriegen, wobei ich im Hinterkopf habe, dass, okay PvP, Leute.
PvP.
Post 1 ist, ähm, der Standard, der Standard-Hotkey, um das Menü aufzumachen.
Nö, nö, Quatsch, Dieter, dafür mache ich doch den Streben.
Ja.
Hier.
Mit Post 1 machst du das Menü auf, wo du dann deine Presets auswählen kannst.
PvP.
Jetzt geht, jetzt geht's los hier.
PvP, Leute.
PvP.
Erstmal Buffs abholen.
Moment.
Habe ich nicht.
Habe ich sogar schon.
Habe ich schon.
Ich habe sogar schon, Longwind.
Ah, lul.
Ich habe sogar schon länger sprinten.
Kriegt man mit Level 10, ist mir neu.
Interesting.
Machen wir hier die Quests.
Also hier kann es übrigens sein, dass wir leicht gekillt werden, klar.
Jetzt mache ich wenigstens ein bisschen Damage, Alter.
Eats.
Uuuuh, die Dark-Mob-Sounds, Mann.
Übrigens, es gibt eine, es gibt eine Story, habe ich von den Entwicklern gelesen, über
die, über die Sounds der Mobs, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihr das überhaupt hört.
Ich habe es leise gemacht, weil die Dark-Sounds sind echt nervig auf Dauer.
Das Ding ist, die haben das Game entwickelt, das Game wurde, es wurde, glaube ich, in nur
einem Jahr oder nur eineinhalb Jahren, die Base West, brauchen wir das überhaupt?
Brauchen wir das überhaupt?
Ach, guck mal.
Leute am Start.
Hey.
Hahaha.
Der Typ schreibt gerade, er arbeitet Home-Office nebenbei und levelt.
Lol.
So muss es sein, Leute.
So muss es sein, Alter.
Genau, also, was wollte ich sagen?
Ja, genau, also die Sounds, die Sounds von den Mobs, die hatten damals das Problem, die
hatten keine Leute, die ordentlich Sounds erstellen können und dementsprechend haben sie sich
so eine, tja.
Ihr müsst euch überlegen, Leute, es war 2001, ja.
2001 gab es ja noch kein Internet und Stock-Footage in dem Sinn.
Die haben sich quasi das 2001-Äquivalent von Stock-Footage gekauft.
Die haben sich eine CD gekauft mit Sounds.
Und da waren alle möglichen Sounds drauf.
Natursounds, was weiß ich, wie einer in der Badewanne ausgerutscht ist und alles Mögliche.
Und darauf haben sie die Sounds genommen.
Sie haben die Sounds genommen für die Monster in dem Game.
Deswegen hören sich die Monstersounds in dem Spiel dann auch alle so weirdchampig an,
Alter.
Also übrigens, hier können wir jederzeit gekillt werden, also wenn wir, wenn wir auf
einmal platzen und ihr nicht wisst warum, dann haben uns gerade irgendwelche Gegner
gekillt.
An String erinnern, sehr gut.
Excellent.
Incoming Keep sagt irgendjemand, ich sehe jetzt noch nichts hier von Gegnern.
So.
Müssen wir den...
Oh.
Was müssen wir eigentlich killen, Leute?
Cephia, okay, das ist von Asht's Cracks.
Ähm.
Goblin Warriors muss man killen, okay, Goblin Warriors.
Und Capricious Wisps, alles klar.
Wo will er hin?
Wo, wo will er hin?
Alter, du willst...
Der will jetzt nicht umdrehen wegen diesem einen Goblin, oder?
The fuck?
Wo will er hin?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Die, die gibt's noch viel mehr Goblins.
Ah, guck mal.
Okay, die Mobs sind respawned.
Also, in Battlegrounds, das ist quasi noch bevor man 50 ist, wie man PvP machen kann.
Ich hab meine Hotkeys noch nicht belegt.
Ich hab nämlich gerade eigentlich den Knopf gedrückt, den zu betäuben, aber der war
noch nicht hotkey mapped.
Muss man, ich muss doch meine Hotkeys ordentlich belegen.
Hatte ich das hier drauf?
Sekunde.
Ja.
Ich, ich weiß nicht worauf ich das gelegt hab.
Oh, Healsong und...
Ich hätte eigentlich gesagt, die Dinger können wir...
Ja.
Ich muss unbedingt meine, meine Hotkeys, Hotkeys ordentlich legen.
Oh, einer noch.
Ich muss unbedingt meine Hotkeys ordentlich legen.
Also, ich glaube Speed muss ich noch belegen.
Ich glaube Speed muss hier hin.
Fuck.
Ich...
Okay, Speed muss da hin.
Und das muss so...
Ne, Moment.
Ah, the fuck.
Alter.
Ich bin, ich bin, ich bin gerade echt planlos.
Das muss, das muss da hin, oder?
Okay, das ist, das ist Speed.
Dann muss ich so rumlegen.
Okay.
Ich bin, ich weiß nicht mehr wo ich meine Hotkeys hab, man.
Hab ich, hab ich meine Hotkeys vielleicht...
Ups.
Hab ich, hab ich vielleicht meine Hotkeys so?
What the fuck?
Okay, ich hab seriously...
Ich denke so sind die Hotkeys.
Ja.
Okay, Hotkeys.
Ich hab meine Hotkeys wieder gefunden.
Nice.
Was ist denn aus dem Daok Nachfolger geworden?
Moment.
Meinst du etwa Camelot Unchained?
Daraus ist leider nichts geworden.
Also, ich würde nicht sagen, dass die uns gescamt haben.
Aber bis jetzt ist da nix, nix weiter rausgekommen.
Schade, schade eigentlich, ja.
Moment, seitlich läuft man schneller im Wasser.
Guck mal.
Daok Logik.
Seitlich läuft man im Wasser schneller.
Das, das kenn ich gar nicht.
Das wusste ich noch gar nicht.
Dass man im Wasser schneller läuft seitlich.
Das ist ja zu geil, man.
Siehste man, ich lerne nach 20 Jahren in dem Game immer noch was dabei.
Guck mal.
Das kannte ich ja echter nicht.
Null.
Guck mal, wir sind viel schneller seitlich laufen im Wasser.
Was sind deine Au...
Was sind...
Das ist ein Private Server.
Ja.
Die Server sind übrigens auch noch online.
Das auch.
Guck mal, das ist zu geil.
Wir sind einfach schneller im Wasser, wenn wir seitlich rennen, man.
Oh.
1 0 5 0 6.
Soll mir alles recht sein.
Ich muss mich da echt dran gewöhnen.
Hey, guck mal!
Guck mal.
Ein Gegner.
Ein Kelte.
Der möchte gebasht werden von uns.
Oh.
Pass auf, da ist noch mehr Gegner.
Wir laufen einfach jetzt hier seitlich.
Beste.
Beste Taktik, man.
Das ist so kaputt, man.
Man lernt echt noch was
Man lernt echt noch was in dem Game
20 Jahre danach
Ja das ist, okay
Jetzt kann ich euch tatsächlich auch ein bisschen was erzählen
In jedem Battleground gibt es
Eine Festung, die man
Einnehmen kann und
Das ist quasi so Vorbereitung für
Dann größeres
Großes PvP
Und bekommt man ein Level
Wenn man die Festung einnimmt
Neue Schuhe haben wir am Start
Level 20
20 Amor, ein Ring
Weste
Ah, Rest kann man verkaufen
Witzig
Das finde ich echt lustig mit dem seitlich
Laufen
Achja, bei der Gelegenheit
Was man noch
Was man noch erwähnen könnte ist
Farben von Gegnern
Das ist auch was, was nicht erklärt wird
In dem Spiel
Aber was essentiell
Ist, dass man nicht laufen verrecken möchte
Also
Graue Gegner
Ich glaube, das ist übrigens in World of Warcraft auch so
Nur mal so, wie Leute das kennen
Graue Gegner sind weit unter deinem Level
Und bringen keine XP
Blaue Gegner
Äh, grüne Gegner
Sind weit unter deinem Level
Bringen noch ein bisschen XP
Blaue Gegner sind ein bisschen unter deinem Level
Bringen
Ganz okay XP
Gelbe Gegner
Sind auf deinem Level
Bringen
Normale XP
Orangene Gegner sind ein bisschen über deinem Level
Wie viel brauchen wir davon eigentlich noch?
Zwei
Und
Bringen eigentlich Cap-XP Solo
Und rote Gegner
Also das, was wir gerade die ganze Zeit gekillt haben
Rote Gegner
Sind eine ganze Ecke über deinem Level
Bringen Cap-XP
Für zwei Personen
Wobei ich glaube auch sogar schon
Ich glaube sogar
Hohe Orange reichen auch für zwei Personen
Hier ist die Glinde am Start
Walküre
Ja, gibt's auch neu auf dem Server
Gab's letzte Season nicht
Eigentlich eine mega nice Klasse
So eine Mischung zwischen
Melee, Support, Damage und Heiler
Ich würde die eigentlich entweiten
Aber wir sind durch mit dem
Mit den Mobs
So, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken
Dass uns keine Gegner abfarmen
Weil wie gesagt, PvP-Gebiet
Immer gucken
Mal gucken, dass man ein bisschen Endu hat
Weil ohne Endu
Keine Nahkampfangriffe möglich sind
Und jemand...
Da ist doch...
Ich bin ja gerade nicht mehr in Albion
Ich hab das Profil der verschiedenen Models schon drauf
Ich kann euch meistens innerhalb von zwei Sekunden sagen
Wenn ich nur ganz kurz eine Silhouette sehe
Haben wir Talkens?
Wir haben Talkens
Aber unser Talken-Dude ist nicht da
Der Talken-Dude ist nicht da
Was das... Was das für ein Gegner ist
Darug gibt's... FreeShard
Darug FreeShard Season 2 ist am Samstag gestartet
Ah ja, und um mal das mit den Gegnern abzuschließen
Dann gibt es noch Lila
Oder Purple
Die sind weit über deinem Level
Du weißt nicht wie viel
Können bis Level 99 im Endeffekt sein
Ja
Und bei Gegnern ist es übrigens genauso
Im PvP
Die Gegner sind auch
Ja...
Wobei ich glaube
Ich glaube bei Gegnern die sind...
Ne ich glaube die sind auch grün
Irgendwann haben sie eingeführt
Dass Gegner die zu niedrig sind nur gelb angezeigt werden
So kam
Aber wenn du quasi im PvP
Einen roten Gegner siehst
Dann weißt du wenn es nicht gerade eine Support Klasse ist
Eigentlich
Guck mal den brauchen wir auch den Dude
Den Boss da
Ich freinde den mal
Ja Galagunde hau mit drauf
Gib's ihm
Der macht ganz schön Damage der Typ
Alter
Wenn ich sterbe
Dreh ich durch
Okay
Er hat es mir weggetauntet
Sehr nicer Dude
Oh Sieglinde hat es nicht mehr abgekriegt
Nooo
So erstmal hier Horn an Goblins weg schnetzeln
Ja da sieht man
Guck der war jetzt orange
Der ist quasi ein bisschen über unserem Level
Der ist gelb, der ist auf unserem Level
Ich glaube wir müssen die Inviten oder
Kindergarten Jordheim
Ey mit den
Es könnte sogar sein dass ich den kenne
Doria
Ey ich kannte einen Heiler von denen
Haben wir öfters mal gespielt
Letzte Season
Sind wir fertig
Ich bin verwirrt
Ich habe die Quest überhaupt nicht drin
Okay wir müssen nur noch einen Boss killen
Dann haben wir es geschafft
Easy
Ich kann dir vielleicht ein bisschen was zu meinen Skills erzählen
Das mache ich aber
Wenn wir aus dem PvP Gebiet raus sind
Dann habe ich auch alle Basic Skills
Fast alle
Fast alle Basic Skills
Als Skaldemon was zu erzählen kann
Mir fehlt glaube ich noch Endo Reduce
Endo Reduce ist enorm praktisch
Und sobald ich Gold habe
Muss ich unbedingt
Ist unser Zelt
Zelt Guy am Start
Es gibt nämlich
In jedem
Battleground
Klickt man für gekillte Monster und Gegner
So
Tokens
Und die Tokens kann man abgeben
Und dann klickt man auch ein bisschen
XP für
Ach komm mal ein Nekro
Der out uns jetzt
Der basht uns jetzt
Nekros sind OP
Nekros sind krass OP
Ach wir wollten den Mob killen
Okay
Jetzt gab es ein bisschen
Punkte
Haben sich gesehen das der Mob gespawnt war
Der Nekro hat da drauf gehauen
Wir müssen mal kurz gucken ob wir Respawn abwarten
Oder
Direkt weiter gehen
Deserters auch eine gute Idee
Ja
Deserters ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee
So Leute
Jetzt müsst ihr mir mal sagen
Ist der Stream hell genug
Wenn nicht mache ich euch das Gamma noch ein bisschen hoch
Da ist er
Geht
Ich kann es euch noch ein bisschen heller machen
Ich mach euch noch ein bisschen heller
Bisschen
Weil Nacht in Dark ist immer mega dunkel
Und ätzend
So
Ich hab keine Ahnung wo Deserters sind
Weil meine Karte hat keine Deserters
To the left of the keep near water
Okay
Left keep ist hier
Schauen wir mal wo die sind
Ich mach mal ganz kurz
Den
Ticken in Ticken heller
Haben wir hier
Einfach mal 3 Punkte heller
Gucken wir mal ob hier
Deserters sind
Es gibt in jedem Battleground gibt es so eine zusätzliche
Killquest wenn man noch nicht max
Max Level ist
Was mein Level ist too low
What the fuck
Pass auf Gegner ist am Start
Muss wohl Gegner bashen
Oh Mann ich hab meine Hotkeys noch nicht belegt
Ich kack Noob Alter
Okay okay okay
Passt
Irgendwas davon
Habe ich auf dem Hotkey
Galla Gunde ist wieder am Start
Was hat er vor
Oh du willst ja nicht hin
Wir sollten uns mal verpissen hier
Hier sind
Deserters oder
Hier sind Deserters okay nice
Jetzt müssen wir von hinten gucken weil
Also das Problem ist tatsächlich
Die Festung gehört den Gegnern
Und was man da vorne
Rumlaufen hat sehen wir dann auch Gegner
Das ist halt
Wir sind hier gerade wirklich ziemlich
Wirklich sehr dumme
Sehr dumme Posi ja
Hier hinter uns ist Wasser wir kommen nicht weg
Warum ist der Deserter spawnen
So langsam
Wir können auch mit unserem neu gelehrten Trick ins Wasser
Laufen da kommen sie nicht hin
Oh da kommen Albs
Guck mal hier da hinten ist ein Nekro
Da hinten ist eine Alpgruppe am Start
Guck mal im Wasser
Seht ihr die?
Da hinten
Die trauen sich aber nicht
Wie immer
Kackenhoops am Start
Hinter uns gucken keine Gegner
Am Start okay
Aber die Alps sind wieder abgehauen
Oder die kommen jetzt von der Seite
Haben wir es eigentlich jetzt
Okay zwei Stück noch
Oh mein Dude ist fast tot man
Ich mach ihm Heilsong an
Okay wir haben es
Dann
Gucken das uns keine Gegner in den Rücken fallen
Ach guck mal da
Der steht
Wir können nicht ins Wasser Engagen
Wenn wir ins Wasser Engagen sind wir gefickt
Die sollen rauskommen
Die müssen rauskommen aus dem Wasser
Typ ist schon down
Da können wir nichts machen
Verpissen wir uns mal
Also ins Wasser rein Engagen wäre eine blöde Idee
So wir gehen jetzt erstmal bei uns
Die
Quests abgeben
Also ich merke ich kann mich
Unglaublich schlecht auf Labern Chat
Und PvP konzentrieren
Oh guck mal wir haben einen Heiler
Ich fasse es nicht
Excellent
Woher
Der ist richtig gut hier der Kerl
Der macht jetzt Group Invites
Da muss ich mich da nicht drum kümmern
Das ist gut
Macht mein Brain gerade nicht mit
Ja also ich hoffe jetzt ist hell genug
Weil es ist Nacht und es ist scheiß Wetter
Da ist da auch doch schon sehr dunkel
Jetzt muss ich erstmal kurz trainieren
Trainieren
Für
Neue Spells und Skills
Ja
Falls irgendjemand Dark spielt
Und sich wundert warum ich Schwert geskillt bin
Und nicht Hammer
Dann liegt das daran
Weil ich Schwert mehr mag
Aber und das muss man ja auch ganz klar sagen
Hammer
Ist in der Regel die bessere Variante
Hab ich da irgendwas
Das können wir noch austauschen
Ja das
Ich bräuchte unbedingt ein neues Schwert
Ring haben wir noch
Ok ich brauch auf jeden Fall ein neues Schwert
Hammer bringt mir nix
Ich kann nicht so viel gleichzeitig machen
Das schafft mein Boomer hier nicht mehr
Oh oh
Oh da sind ganz viele
Da sind ganz viele Hips dahinter
Auf auf go go
Die werden jetzt gebasht
Links ist ein Kelter Alter macht der noch Blatt
Oh oh oh oh oh das ist ein bisschen viel
Sehr gut
Sehr gut den Typen haben wir jetzt down
Jaja
Lauft ihr alle nur
Fuck mein Endu
Nice
Next
Lauft ihr alle bloß random bei uns rein
Und lasst euch kiten
Wir müssen ein Stückchen weg
Oh
Ok wir müssen weg
Stückchen
So der Bade muss sterben
Sonst wird das nix
Oh shit shit die heilen
Ich hab zu wenig Spells
Der hat das Pad drauf das ist ok
So sobald der castet wird er angeschautet
Ansonsten nicht
Ja gut gut gut
Speed
Bade Bade
Mach den Bade kalt
Der Bade muss sterben
Jawoll
Der andere Heiler steht die haben keinen Heal mehr aktuell
Fuck der Heiler ist frei
Shit
Ich hab keine Endu das ist mein Problem
So und jetzt ok
Den nächsten Bade kann ich abstellen wenn ich Glück hab
Fuck und resisted
Jetzt hab ich nix mehr den zu unterbrechen
Aber der ist blöd der läuft ne Kurve nice
GG
Oh jetzt hat er auch noch resisted ich fass es nicht
Alter
Sterbe ich hab keine Endu mehr man
Ok 14%
14% gib ihm
Gib ihm 0 down jawoll
Der wird abgestellt
Ok der ist fast down
Der ist fast down
Du musst nix peilen macht nix
Macht nix
Du musst nur peilen das wir gewonnen haben
Du musst nur peilen das wir gerade 8 Gegner gekillt haben
Oder so zu viert
Das reicht
Ahem
Ja sehr gut
Also ich kann
Versuchen euch zu erklären was da gerade
Gewesen ist
Wobei das
Mein Brain gerade mit
Aufpassen überfordert
Ich muss trainen
Battlesongs
Moment Moment ich brauch Battlesongs
Neuen Speed brauchen wir
Neuen Speed
Neuen Damage Song
Endu Enchantment
Das brauchen wir jetzt
Das beste können wir besser
Rennen hätten wir eben gebraucht
Mehr Damage Nahkampf
Und mein Snare
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher auf welchen Hotkey ich den hatte
Das letzte mal
Ähm
Mana Song den braucht man selten
Ok passt
Alter ich bin
Ich kann nicht so viel Multitask scoren
So pass mal auf
High IQ seitwärts laufen wieder am Start
Also übrigens das waren echte Gegner
Eben ne diese
Die wir da gerade gekillt haben
Also echte Spieler
Token abgeben
Gibt XP
Der ist aber der ist sehr optimistisch
Das wir mit 4 Leute das Keep erobern können
Das ist
Ich weiß ja nicht
Das erscheint mir etwas mega optimistisch
Guckt mal wir sind 4 Leute
Ok 5 mit dem Pet von ihm dabei
Einmal mit 5 Leuten
Das Keep
Ich bin mir unschlüssig
Oh da sind Alps
Ach ne Moment da sind schon
Da sind schon Mets am Start easy
Oh da kann ich nicht hin Leute
Da kann ich nicht hin da bin ich dead wenn ich dahin gehe
Unser Heiler muss da irgendwas rein bekommen
Sehr gut
Sehr gut perfekt
Poggers Healer
Auf rein Leute
Ihr müsst da rein
Oh ich krieg auf den Sack
Die chargen nicht mit
No
Oh fuck ich bin down
Dead
So kanns gehen
Schnell releasen und wieder hin
Der Heiler hat das richtig gut gemacht
Der hat das richtig gut gemacht
Die standen alle
Die sind alle rein drücken müssen
Dann hätte das geklappt
Speed holen
Enchantments holen
Speed an Endo Reduce an
Lets go
Volle Pulle zum Keep
Man respawnt hier so schnell
Das man vor allem mit Speed
Das man gleich wieder da ist
Ok
Oh die machen noch irgendwelche Quests
So jetzt kommt pass mal auf Trick 17
Wir laufen jetzt nicht den Weg außen drum herum
Wir machen jetzt
Das was ich gerade gelernt hab
Massive High IQ Sidewards Walking
Haha
Das ist so ein geiler Bug
Den kannte ich noch gar nicht
Guck mal wie schnell wir hier durch sind
Anstatt um den See zu laufen
Guck mal ich krieg sogar RPs
Nice
Das ist der beste Glitch ever
Oh ne
Die anderen sind auch am Start
Ich muss meine Leute supporten
Ah wo ist mein Team
Mein Team
Hier unten sind sie
Wir sitzen hier auf der Karte
Da sind sie
Schnell
Nein nicht sterben
Oh shit
Snare
Jawoll
Nein nein nein
Fuck
Ok ich bleibe auf dem
Ich hab halt nix mehr
Komm jetzt
Komm jetzt der kann jetzt noch sterben
Nice
Und
Der kann auch noch sterben
Ok
Das geht ja gerade richtig was ab hier
So wir haben wieder gewonnen
Okay
Ich hoffe unsere Leute kommen schnell
Ah da hinten ist noch n Kälte
Guck mal die hauen ab
Guck mal wie sie weg rennen
Wie sie weg rennen
gramsch sure
So
Das hab mannu
Jetzt
Das haben wir schon
Ja
Also
Siehst du
Ich bin So
IchShow
gab es Paladin mit Plattenrüstung.
Deswegen hat man im deutschsprachigen Raum immer gesagt,
das sind keine Alps, sondern das sind Dosen.
Weil Plattenrüstung und so, ne? Dosen.
Ja, und zu...
Zu Hips war man
deutlich weniger nett.
Da hat man meistens gesagt,
Baumficker oder sowas.
Weil die so
naturverbunden sind.
Okay.
Turn in Token.
Ja, können wir machen.
Wir turnen Tokens in.
Ich hab nur 24 Tokens, das lohnt sich ja eigentlich kaum.
Den Ring können wir
austauschen.
Stilarmlinge. Okay, ich brauche
Hosen und
Schuhe und
ne Weste.
Das andere ist schon 15, ne?
Ja, wir machen schnell
Deserters.
Bist du denn, Dr. Chaos?
Er meint ihn hier.
Der Bersi soll
desbanden, die anderen, dass wir sie entweihten können.
Achtung, Ink, Ink, Ink, Ink.
Oh, fuck, Resistant.
Er hat Resistant. Schnell, schnell, schnell, Damage, Damage, Damage, Damage, Damage,
Damage, Damage, Damage, Damage, Leute, Damage, Damage, Damage, Damage,
Damage, ihr... Oh, ihr seid blind,
ihr seid blind, ihr seid... Nein!
Ihr seid so blind, alle, Mann.
Auf Damage,
Leute, Damage, Damage, Damage,
Kimmim! Der ist blau, Mann,
der hält nix aus.
Eis.
Oh.
Den haben wir dann da.
Alter, bashen.
Ah, ist 15. So, jetzt killen wir die da unten
noch schnell. Auf, auf, Leute, let's go.
Oh, Heiler, Heiler,
sehr gut gemacht, Heiler. Nice.
Du gehst auch in den Dings und du
auch und du auch und...
Oh, jetzt stunnt er mich, Alter, ich fass.
Den da hinten könnt ihr aber killen.
Das ist ein Söldner, oder? Das ist gar kein Minne.
Ich dachte, das ist ein Minne, Alter.
Das macht meine Hand nicht. Alter, seht ihr alle,
wie die alle dieses dumme Straving machen?
Hahaha.
Seht ihr alle dieses dumme Straving machen, Mann?
So, den Neko holen wir uns noch. Den Neko holen wir uns noch.
Den Neko holen wir noch.
Alter, ich fass es nicht.
Ich hab kein Mana mehr.
Shit.
Jawoll.
Jawoll, er hat ihn, er hat ihn, er hat ihn, er hat ihn.
Ich bin gleich da, ich bin gleich da.
Jawoll.
Erstmal, Leute, Leute,
erstmal T-Baggen.
Wie sich das in jedem guten,
geheim gehört.
Erstmal die feine T-Baggen.
Seht ihr, das ist unter anderem
eines der riesen
neuesten Sachen an Dork.
Dadurch, dass es zwei Fraktionen,
äh, drei Fraktionen gibt in dem Spiel,
es ist nie
langweilig.
Versteht ihr, wie ich mein?
Es war eben so, wir haben gefightet von vorne
gegen die Alps. Dann kamen Hips von der Seite
und umgedreht.
Übrigens, wir sterben jetzt, das ist Absicht.
Nicht wundern. Wir rennen jetzt in das Portal Keep.
Äh, der, der Hips.
Da sind super High-Level-Wachen,
die uns jetzt bashen werden.
Dü-dü-dü-dü-dü.
Ich muss den mal fragen, was der, was der machen will.
Ob der ins nächste...
Hast du AOC heute schon gemacht?
Nein.
Hab ich noch nicht gemacht.
Aber wir sind 1L2.
Also wir können gleich noch was, was kaufen.
Alter, wo bin ich denn hier rausgekommen?
Was ver...
Alter, random, random
Gilden-Invite, lol, Alter.
Ich kenn, ich kenn ihn gar nicht.
Ähm,
wo sind die anderen noch?
Alter, kann ich mal richtig am Inn?
Wir machen BG, hä?
Haben wir irgendwas?
Okay, der will wahrscheinlich BG, oder?
Mal kurz gucken, wo er ist.
Der will bestimmt BG.
Wir machen
nächsten BG.
Joa, ich hab gegen P.
Ich hab gegen PvP nix.
Das ist das Beste, was es in dem Spiel gibt.
Aber ihr habt's gesehen, es kann nicht langweilig werden mit drei Fraktionen.
Das ist halt das Geile da dran.
Und wir sind schon Level 15.
Ging wirklich sehr, sehr zackig.
So, Leute, ich muss mal kurz Bio aften.
So wie man das, äh, wie man das in MMOs nennt.
Afk Bio.
Heißt...
Ach, guck mal, ich hab Deserters fertig gehabt.
Na ja, es gibt ein bisschen Bonus-XP.
Ich bin mal kurz Bio-Breakin'.
Und dann...
Sehen wir uns gleich wieder, eine Minute.
Wieder am Start.
Nice Twitch-Zuschauer.
Ähm, ich sollte euch vielleicht noch eine Sache erklären.
Zu Dark.
Und zwar...
Gibt's hier ein Bounty?
Guck mal da.
Bounty Points.
Sollte ich Bounty Points dafür ausgeben?
Ja, ich geb Bounty Points dafür aus.
Ich geb Bounty Points für eine Waffe aus.
Ich brauch unbedingt...
Eine gescheite Waffe.
Waffe...
Ja, dabei.
Weiß.
Es gibt ein Makro, um alle Gegenstände zu verkaufen.
Das hab ich aber noch nicht.
Deswegen verkauf ich jetzt mal manuell.
Can't be sold.
Okay.
Ja, ich muss euch nur was erzählen zu einer...
Ziemlich aus...
Für die heutige Zeit einzigartige...
Mechanic von Dark.
Und zwar ist es das Interrupt-System.
Also, wenn ihr...
Brauch ich 200, aber ich...
Wenn ihr Caster seid oder Heiler, also wenn ihr irgendwas casten möchtet und euch jemand im Nahkampf angreift, dann könnt ihr nicht zaubern.
Und selbst wenn euch Range Damage hittet, könnt ihr auch nicht zaubern.
Das heißt, es gibt nur ganz wenige Spells, die ihr abkriegen könnt, bei denen ihr noch weiter zaubern könnt.
Das heißt, was enorm wichtig ist, gerade als Supporter und Heiler, dass man sich ordentlich positioniert.
Ansonsten hast du eigentlich nahezu verloren.
Und das haben die gegnerischen Supporter bei den Fights eben nicht gemacht.
Ich war permanent dran, konnte die so gut wie die ganze Zeit interrupten.
Und dementsprechend haben die auch keine Spells rausgekriegt.
So sieht's aus.
So, jetzt trainieren wir erstmal.
Du weißt schon, dass du mit Shift-S auf... Nein, das weiß ich nicht.
Ist das neu?
Weiß ich nicht. Ne, wusste ich nicht.
So, Battle Songs muss auf Level.
Ein neuer Metz und etwas schwer.
Ein Side-Style, Back-Style?
Front-Style?
Was ist denn das?
In Front of Target.
Okay, das könnte vielleicht was...
Ich glaub einfach mit meinem Any-Timer drauf, Braindead und gut ist.
So.
Battle Songs. Gut.
Während das hier läuft, äh, hab ich Power Toys drauf.
Power Toys?
Fuck.
Ich brauch, ich brauch mein Shortcut-Mapping, sonst wird das nix.
Ich, ähm, hab, ähm, Snare immer auf Control liegen.
War schon immer. Ernsthaft?
Ich spiel das seit 20 Jahren.
Nur ist nix davon.
Null.
Hahaha.
Hab ich schon zwei Sachen gelernt.
Side-Fat, Scraven und Verkaufen.
Zumindest, ich, ich kann euch jetzt mal ganz grob die, die, die Spells erklären.
Hab ich überhaupt Quests angenommen? Ja, hab ich.
Ganz, ganz grob erklären, was es, was es gibt.
Also, Skalde ist ne Hybrid-Klasse.
Das ist quasi die, die Musik-Klasse aus Midgard.
Und dementsprechend hab ich Speed.
Was so ziemlich eines der begehrtesten Sachen im gesamten Spiel ist.
Also, wenn ihr euch fragt, welche Klassen sind begehrt, dann sind das prinzipiell Heiler und Supporter.
Und Klassen mit Speed.
Weil, im PvP-Gebieten, wenn du dort nicht maximalen Laufspeed hast, bist du quasi dead.
Und du holst auch keine Gegner ein und sowas.
Kannst du eigentlich, kannst du eigentlich voll vergessen.
Im Prinzip können alle Klassen relativ beliebt sein, finden, finden was.
Wobei, naja, nicht unbedingt alle, aber die meisten.
Aber gerade, gerade Supporter und Klassen mit Speed sind, sind immer, sind immer beliebt.
Also, ich versuch euch das mal kurz zu erklären.
Also, das ist ne Hybrid-Klasse.
Sprich, ich hab erstmal den laueren Mob-Killen.
Alter, ich krieg echt Damage.
Krieg ich so ein Damage.
Warte mal kurz, Heilsong an, Heilsong und Endo-Reduce.
Okay, ich warte mal kurz, bis der getauntet hat.
Ja, also, ich hab ein bisschen, bisschen wenig TP gerade.
Also, ich lass, ich lass den mal kurz draufhauen, regge mal schnell.
Also, ähm, nachdem das ne Hybrid-Klasse ist, hab ich Nahkampf-Warngriffe.
Wie das, wie das funktioniert, kann ich euch zeigen.
Zum Beispiel hat man, wenn man jetzt das hier nimmt, Drawout, da steht dran, was das, was das macht.
Also, es ist quasi, es hat ein Defense-Penalty, es hat einen hohen Bonus-To-Hit und Low-Damage.
Das ist also eigentlich für PvP nicht der optimale Style.
Aber, was Drawout hat, ist, ähm, äh, Taunt-Target.
Also, sprich, die Gegner sind wahrscheinlicher, mich anzugreifen.
Was jetzt in der Konzeption ist, ist, dass die Gegner, die Gegner sind, die Gegner sind, die Gegner sind, die Gegner sind.
Was jetzt in der Konstellation gar nicht so sinnvoll ist, mit einem Krieger dabei, die können eigentlich ruhig stehen, hitten.
Was ist denn da oben?
Ah, das ist ein Hit.
Und die Styles, also Nahkampf-Warngriffe nennen sich in Dark Styles, die Styles haben oftmals unterschiedliche Voraussetzungen.
Guckt, der hier zum Beispiel, der geht nur, wenn man in Front of Target ist.
Oh, Speed vergessen.
Der geht nur, wenn man direkt in Front, also wenn man quasi so vor dem Gegner steht, so, ich glaub, irgendwie so bis zu 60 Grad Winkel oder sowas.
Würde das funktionieren?
Und Drawout ist Opening, also wichtig ist bei Opening, Anytime, das heißt, geht immer.
Dann hat man so Sachen wie zum Beispiel Follow-Up.
Also, sprich, man muss zuerst den einen Style machen, dann den anderen.
Es ist relativ simpel, ja, es ist relativ simpel.
Also, man muss sagen, wenn du einen reinen Nahkampf-Char spielst in Dark, also, du verbiegst dir nicht gerade die Hände.
Das ist ein bisschen, wie ein
Nice.
Schön, dass wir, wäre schön auf der Karte angezeigt jetzt.
Top.
Topke!
Aber der ist Level 19, der ist fast weg hier.
Oh ne, shit, ich hab nicht geguckt.
Wo, wo, what the?
Oh.
Oh shit.
Bade, Bade, Bade, Bade.
Bade steht.
Bade steht nicht, fuck.
Okay, wir sind dead.
Wir sind, wir sind dead.
Wir sind dead, wir sind dead.
Wir sind dead.
So sieht das aus, wenn man gepfarmt wird von der Seite.
So sah das eben bei den Gegnern aus.
Und das sind auch etwas zu viele.
Oh ne, wir brauchen 29, 29 Sekunden, bis man gebufft werden kann.
So sah das eben für die anderen aus, als wir die von der Seite weggeballert haben.
Ja, dazu kommt, weil es eine Hybridklasse ist, es gibt neben Nahkampfangriffen, kriegt man
auch noch eine.
Es gibt eine Spell-Linie.
Skalde ist tatsächlich eines der simpleren Klassen, ja.
Man hat nicht, man hat nicht wirklich, wirklich viel, was man managen muss.
Eigentlich musst du eine halbwegs gute Position haben und dann, dann geht das.
Skalde ist gut solo, in der Gruppe.
Also, ach guck mal da, ach, die, die machen das gleiche wie wir, sie sind fertig mit dem
Battleground.
Deswegen haben die sich hier gerade gewiped.
Nice.
Und es gibt auch eine Sache, die man auch nicht unbedingt machen sollte.
Äh, ich weiß nicht.
Äh, im, im PvP und das ist einfach blind sticken.
Man hat eben gesehen, dass es keine gute Idee ist.
Also, sticken ist quasi hinterherlaufen.
Quasi direkt, das, sollen wir das Relikt aufnehmen?
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, da wissen alle, dass wir da sind.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist.
Nee, nee, gut, machen wir auch nicht.
Ja, es ist, ist meistens keine so gute Idee.
Weil, wenn du das Relikt aufnimmst, wirst du immer auf der Karte markiert für alle.
Jo.
Und ihr habt es gerade gesehen, wenn man stickt und hier auf dem Klumpen läuft, dann steht
man halt auch mal schnell.
Das heißt, es ist immer besser, wenn man etwas de-stickt läuft, so wie ich, gerade
weil ich Instant Interrupt habe für die Gegner.
Brauchen wir das Viech?
Denke mal schon.
Bin mir immer noch nicht sicher, welchen Shortcut ich hier wie, aber wisst ihr, was ich gut,
gut finde?
Der, der Danik, bei mir aus der Gruppe.
Der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der,
der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der,
scheint gerne Gruppen-Invites zu machen und Sachen zu managen.
Guckt, der invitiert die Leute und sowas.
Das ist mega praktisch.
Jetzt gerade, wenn ich, wenn ich am Streamsort bin, am Schwätzen bin, dann muss ich das
nicht machen.
Weil mein Hirn, mein Hirn schafft es nicht, das noch nebenbei zu machen.
Guckt, jetzt kann ich euch das mit dem Style mal zeigen, wenn ich jetzt so, ja, das Viech.
Ich stelle mich jetzt vor, ich stelle mich jetzt vor, das Viech.
Dann kann ich den Style machen.
weil das ein Front-Style ist, wenn ich hinter dem Vieh stehe
und versuche den Style reinzuhauen, guckt, dann geht das nicht.
Also da muss man ein bisschen auf die Position gucken.
Ansonsten ist es super easy, weil Dark auch recht, sagen wir mal, recht laggy ist.
Und du kannst, also die richtig guten Leute, das ist ein bisschen verpönt,
aber wie gesagt, ich finde, es gehört, wenn man Melee-Charakter spielt, irgendwie dazu.
Man kann ziemlich gut um Gegner strafen.
Also durch Gegner, durch Strafen, an die Seite strafen
und dementsprechend kannst du aus fast jeder Position
Positional-Nahkampfangriffe treffen, die du eigentlich nicht treffen können solltest.
Der Netcode ist für 56k und ISDN gebaut, ja, das ist korrekt.
Das ist richtig. Moment, habe ich jetzt nicht sogar schon Water-Buff mit 10?
Ich habe Water-Buff, jawohl!
Besser!
Das ist das Beste!
Water-Buff! Jetzt kann man sogar schneller schwimmen.
Excellent!
Und jetzt hier, guckt, stellt euch vor, eine gegnerische Gruppe kommt von der Seite,
die stehen alle hier, weil die so auf dem Haufen sind.
Deswegen versuche ich immer ein bisschen die Stick zu laufen.
Wir warten übrigens auf Monster-Respawn.
Muss ich gar nichts machen, guckt, bam.
10 von 10, eats.
Oh.
Oh, es gibt...
Was gibt's denn hier?
Weiß.
Warum durfte ich das Ding hier vorhin eigentlich nicht anziehen?
Hat das irgendwie spezielle Sachen?
Ach, guck mal hier, Replenish-Target-Power-Pool.
Ach, guck mal, das Item hat einen Charge.
Ja, das ist nice.
Das...
Level-Requirement 20.
Ja, alles klar.
Toll.
Trinkets.
Hier ist das Hip-Häuschen.
Für den...
Token...
Token-Merchant.
Ja.
Aber was ihr auch daran seht, man kann, wenn man eine Gruppe hat,
man kann auch komplett im PvP leveln.
Wir sind jetzt schon Level 15 und wir sind eineinhalb Stunden oder so am Start.
Das ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig schnell, muss man sagen.
Also wenn man eine wirklich gut optimierte Gruppe hat und einfach nur sinnlos PvP macht,
mit Bomben und allem, dann ist man das auch schnell.
Aber nachdem wir ja quasi alle Solos sind, die sich jetzt hier in Groups zusammengeschlossen haben
und nicht irgendwie Premade-Gruppe, ist das gar nicht so schlecht.
Also läuft ganz gut.
So...
Oh, die Albs sind am Start.
Mit diesen Tokens, die man hier in jedem Battleground bekommt, also mit...
Ach, guck mal, was läuft denn da unten?
Ey, das ist ein...
Ach, die Brücke, man.
Mit den Tokens, die man bekommt hier in jedem Battleground,
kann man zu diesem Zelt gehen, wo wir eben gerade dran vorbeigelaufen sind.
Und an diesem Zelt steht so ein Händler, dem kann man die Tokens geben.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wo das Mittent ist, das ist mein Problem.
Und dann beschwört der so einen Belagerungs-Mob,
der zum Keep in die Mitte rennt und die Tür einschlägt.
Dann kann man einfacher rein.
Ich hoffe, man versteht das.
Ich hab mir aufgeschrieben, wenn wir hier mit PvP und...
Wenn ein bisschen Luft ist, dass ich euch was zeigen kann.
Ich hab mir aufgeschrieben, ich wollte euch mal ganz kurz zeigen,
falls irgendjemand mal reingucken möchte.
Übersicht, was es für Klassen gibt, erzähle ich euch einfach dann,
während wir PvM machen.
Und dann noch...
Ja, genau. Ach, stimmt.
Und Übersicht über meine Skills.
Wo ist das Zelt für die Tokens, man?
Wir suchen unser Zelt.
Da ist das Zelt!
Und da ist auch unser...
Da ist auch unser Token-Dude.
Jawoll.
Hier.
Tokens.
Gibt ein bisschen XP.
Und wenn wir genug Tokens reingegeben haben...
Äh, da ist ein...
Da ist ein...
Da ist ein Nekro irgendwo, oder?
Da ist ein Nekro.
Aber ein großer Nekro.
Weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist, den anzugreifen.
High...
Highspeed...
Highspeed-Mob am Start.
Der ist richtig...
Fast and Furious, ja.
Er wird immer langsamer.
Auf Siege-Giant.
Gib alles.
Mann.
Was ist da unten?
Ah, Grab.
Wenn man stirbt, gibt es ein Grab.
Da kann man beten gehen.
Und kriegt wieder ein bisschen XP zurück.
Die Alps rennen weg!
Kick-Waite!
Kick!
Oh, nein!
Nice Level-Up.
Okay, ich muss ein Stückchen weg.
Ich muss ein Stückchen weg.
Ich habe keine Resis.
Ich bin instant...
Ich bin instant dead.
Wenn einer auf mich castet.
Nice, GG.
Shit, shit, shit, shit.
Wir müssen da rein.
Okay.
Der steht.
Sehr gut.
Äh, warum...
Warum hauen wir den Tank?
Das ist richtig dumm.
Sollten nicht den Tank hauen, Mann.
Das ist der Nekro.
Okay, der kriegt...
Der kriegt Damage hier.
Sehr gut.
Ich laufe dem einfach hinterher.
Sobald er stehen bleibt...
...ist er dead.
Ich warte nur, bis ich Speed habe.
Moment, das ist ein Reaver?
Das ist ein fucking Reaver, Alter.
Alter.
Mit Stoffrüstung.
So leben noch Leute von mir hier am Keep?
Ich glaube schon.
Okay, fuck, der ist dead.
Nope.
Ich glaube, die sind...
Ich glaube, die sind alle dead.
Aber die Nekros...
Die Nekros haben es gerissen, Leute.
Die Nekros haben es gerissen.
Auf, Kollege, komm.
Wir gehen zurück zu unseren...
Zu unseren Jungs.
Warum klicke ich eigentlich?
Ich habe doch meine Shortcuts mittlerweile am Start.
Aber gut.
Gut, RPs gemacht.
Gut, ähm...
Gut, äh...
XP?
Kann man nix sagen.
Ist okay.
Ich meine, Nekros sind eh in den unteren BGs extrem schwierig zu killen mit einer Nahkampfgruppe.
Die machen übelst Damage.
Die halten übelst aus.
Die kannst du so gut wie gar nicht interrupten.
Und die sind höheres Level als wir.
Also Nekros zacken.
Die haben...
Eigentlich ist das so richtig Instant-Win-Button für die Albs auf dem Level.
Guck mal, da kommen sie.
Ja.
Und auch so ein Ding in Dark.
Es gibt...
Das Speed 1 bis 5 hat die jeweilige, ja...
Ich nenne es mal Musikklasse in jedem Realm.
Aber wenn du sprintest, wird das oftmals Speed 6 genannt.
Weil du quasi nochmal genauso viel zusätzlichen Runspeed kriegst, wie mit so einem Speed-Buff.
Äh, Kill-A-Log.
Ich habe ja kaum eine.
Ja.
Und gegen Nekros ist das Beste, wenn du Caster hast.
Also Magie-Damage.
Weil die Nekro-Pets halten nicht viel aus.
Guck mal, das Tor ist schon auf.
Nice.
Die Albs haben...
Guck mal.
Und deswegen ist Three-Realm-Combat das Beste.
Die Albs haben das Tor kaputt gemacht.
Und wir gehen ja jetzt rein.
Gleich.
Und...
Äh...
Warum will er nicht rein?
Ja.
Genau.
Die Albs bashen uns gleich, die Albs, ja.
Wenn sie schnell genug sind.
Die kommen gleich rein und bashen uns.
Do we have Rams?
No, ich habe keine Rams.
Oh, ich muss meine...
Ink, Ink, Ink, Ink.
Okay.
Albs kommen an den Start.
Jetzt müssen wir gucken, dass die hier...
Wenn die hier reinkommen...
Wir können die killen, wenn die reinkommen.
Das geht.
Den...
Muss ich mal abstellen, kurz da hinten.
Jetzt müssen wir gucken, wenn die Albs reinkommen...
Warum setze ich mich hin?
Wenn die Albs reinkommen...
Ich habe da schon was durch die Wand klitschen sehen gerade.
Albion Siege Golem, okay.
Ach, das habe ich durch die Wand klitschen sehen.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, okay, Albs, komm, Albs, komm.
Achtung, lass dich nicht baiten.
Lass dich nicht baiten, lass dich nicht baiten.
Die Nekros, die Nekros ficken uns jetzt halt gleich.
Wir können nicht raus.
Sobald wir um die Ecke gehen, sind wir dead.
Und die sind auch noch higher level als wir.
Okay, den können wir killen.
Nice, nice, nice, okay.
Wir müssen langsam rauspushen, langsam rauspushen.
Nicht overextenden, nicht übertreiben.
Die haben nämlich, die haben Wachen, Ed.
Die haben Wachen, Ed.
Sehr schön.
Darog speak, ich kann es gerade nicht ändern.
So, mal kurz die Pets anhauen, dass die aufhören zu casten.
Wache taunten und zurück ins Keep.
Ich habe Endosong laufen.
Okay, nice.
Ja, haben wir gut gemacht.
Haben wir gut gemacht.
Und den können wir wieder beleben.
Hit door, ja.
Door ist auf 22, war nicht so easy.
Wir müssen uns beeilen.
Wir haben leider keine Ramme dabei.
Ich habe nicht gedacht, dass wir jetzt gerade siechen gehen hier.
Weil die Albs sind gleich wieder am Start.
100 pro.
So, brauchen unsere Heiler, brauchen unsere Heiler Mana.
Ich glaube, wir brauchen eher Endo für das.
Ne, ich habe keine Ramme.
Ich habe nicht gedacht, dass wir jetzt hier irgendwas machen wollen in der Richtung.
Alle, alle müssen Damage machen.
Theoretisch müssen sogar die Caster ran.
Also eigentlich müssten jetzt,
sogar, dass es schnell geht, die Heiler ran und mit dem Hammer draufklatschen.
Weil die Albs, die respawnen hier unten.
Und die sind in drei Minuten sind wieder da.
Und wir sind super langsam.
Bis wir das aufgeschlagen haben.
Wir sind super langsam.
Guck mal, ohne Ramme.
Albs will be back, korrekt.
Ne, ich habe keine Ramme.
Ich habe keine Ramme mitgenommen, Mann.
Ich hätte nicht damit gerechnet, dass wir eine Ramme brauchen.
Okay, was brauche ich denn noch für Rüstung?
Ich könnte...
Ja, eigentlich habe ich alles.
Armlinge, okay, nice.
Habe ich auch hier.
Äh, Füße, Hände, Kopf.
Könnte ich noch gebrauchen.
Füße, Hände, Kopf.
Tokens.
Ich habe auch Tokens.
Das dauert zu lang.
Wir sollten alle unsere Tokens abgeben.
Ja, ich weiß, dass 50 nicht reichen.
Sollten Tokens, wir sollten Tokens.
Ähm, Hipster coming, okay.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Hipster am Start.
Leute, Gegner kommen.
Ich zeige euch mal was.
Ich gehe mal kurz hoch.
Da können wir runtergucken.
Wobei ich, wobei ich unten sein muss.
Es bringt nichts, wenn ich als Nahkampfcharakter oben bin.
Aber ich kann es euch mal zeigen von oben.
Also man kann.
Kann man runtergucken.
Man sieht dann auch ein bisschen was.
Aber es eigentlich ziemlich, ziemlich low IQ.
Als Nahkampfcharakter oben auf der.
Auf der Feste rumzulaufen.
Okay, es ist.
Es dauert es auf 14.
Okay, okay, steady.
Wir sind, wir sind nicht schnell, wir sind langsam, aber es passt.
Und immer wichtig.
NPC Wachen taunten, Alter, ich krieg so Damage Mann von dem Viech, damit sie nicht auf die Heiler gehen, weil es gibt eine Sache, die noch mehr die also Mobs und und Wachen tauntet als Damage.
Das ist.
Heilung heilen zieht in dem Spiel echt die meiste Agro gibt's irgendwas, was ich noch austauschen kann, also Hose haben, okay, Beine, Beine, Kopf, Hände bräuchte ich noch oder den Gürtel Gürtel habe ich keinen mehr.
Kommt von hinten was Nope.
Okay, elf Prozent.
Brauchen unbedingt mehr Hips mehr mit, die hier rankommen.
High Octane Gameplay.
Wie ihr seht hier.
Wir schlagen aufs Tor.
Aufmacht die Wache, Blattmann.
Wir können die Kasten jetzt umnuken, nachdem er die getauntet hat, so zehn Prozent, zehn Prozent.
Okay, ich muss auf jeden Fall gucken, dass ich ein bisschen Endu behalte.
Ich sehe keinen Guard, die Respawn sind, muss auf jeden Fall gucken, dass ich ein bisschen Mama und Endu behalte, also ich sollte jetzt kein Mama mehr raushauen.
Sinnlos, wir können so mal kurz.
Können theoretisch sogar mal kurz Mana Song.
Rein switchen.
Nee, Damage, Damage Add und Endu ist das Beste, was wir jetzt machen können in der Situation.
Also ich habe verschiedene.
Ich habe ja verschiedene Spells.
Ich wollte euch das ja eigentlich mal zeigen, weil ich habe verschiedene Songs, weil ich bin Skalde.
Das sind das sind eigentlich Songs.
Sieht man ja auch.
Gibt halt keine Songs, Sounds irgendwie in dem Spiel.
Ich habe Endu, also Ausdauer Reduktion, Speed, schneller rennen, mehr Nahkampfschaden und Leben regenerieren und
Mana regenerieren und in dem Fall, wenn man an so einem Tor ist, bietet sich an, mehr Nahkampfschaden und Ausdauer Reduktion.
Da kann man nämlich konstanter aufs Tor prügeln und macht mehr Schaden, weil ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, ob es Damage Add, nee, Damage Add am Tor gibt es gar nicht.
Nein, Advent of Code haben wir noch nicht gemacht.
Ich muss bis heute Abend Kreiselcrime machen und meinen Mid leveln.
Alp ist schon 50, jetzt Zeit für Mid.
Okay.
Gleiches, gleiche, jetzt ist es, jetzt kommt es halt echt drauf an.
Scheiß drauf, Tor aufmachen, Tor aufmachen.
Okay, wir müssen von unseren Heilern, also immer Wachen von Heilern und Castern weg, das ist wichtig.
Ja, und den Rest können die machen und wir hauen jetzt weiter aufs Tor.
Hauptsache, Hauptsache immer die Wache taunten.
So, 3% Tor.
Die anderen, die Alps haben schon kein Tor.
Die Alps haben schon kein Tor.
Die Alps haben schon kein Bock mal zu defenden.
Ich kriege ziemlich Damage, Leute.
Es wäre nice, wenn ich einen Heal bekommen könnte.
Nice, ich werde geheilt.
Okay, das, immerhin.
Ich werde mich ja nicht beschweren, ich weiß, als Heiler ist es echt stressig.
Gerade, wenn du auf alles achten musst.
Und in BG ist Heiler zu spielen nochmal doppelt stressig, weil du kaum Mana hast, diesen Cast Speed und alles.
So, Tor ist gleich offen.
Ich hoffe, jetzt kommen nicht die Alps noch um die Ecke, zwei Sekunden vorher.
Okay.
0, 0%, Tor geht auf.
Nächster Style.
So.
Und jedes, jede Festung hat einen Mini-Boss im Endeffekt.
Alter, Mana kriegt es voller.
Kälte, Kälte, Kälte, Kälte.
Bashen.
Das war jetzt wieder ein Gegner, ein echter.
So, alle rein ins Keep, alle rein ins Keep.
Wir können den Heiler nachher retzen, der liegt im Keep, der kriegt XP.
Wache taunten, dass sie nicht auf die Heiler und auf die Caster geht.
Jetzt hoch zum Lord.
Das ist so quasi so ein Mini-Boss, der in jedem Keep oben ist.
Kann eigentlich auch nix.
Oh, oh, ich krieg Damage.
Ich krieg...
Ich mach nix mehr.
Ich krieg, ich krieg mega krass Damage.
Heil.
Heal please.
Prege.
Heil mich.
Heiler.
Aber der hat kein Mana mehr.
Okay, oder?
Egal, nice.
Nice.
Wir haben alle Level bekommen.
Sollen wir recht sein.
War knapp.
So ein Rats wär nice.
Heiler, du darfst mich wiederbeleben.
Äh.
Besser, besser mit, ähm, Buffs vom Keep.
Okay.
Haben wir gut gemacht.
Gleich nochmal ein Keep eingenommen.
So, haben wir Deserter's Killallow, friend?
Moment, hab ich überhaupt die Deserter-Quest?
Deserter allerdings, ja hab ich.
Okay, dann renn ich mal schnell zurück zu meiner Crew.
Ich bin 1L3.
Ich hoffe, ich kann Longwind 2 kaufen.
Mana hat's wieder am Start.
Nice.
Guck mal, wir sind auch alle relativ hohes Level.
Wir kommen...
Wir leveln alle ungefähr zeitgleich aus dem BG raus.
Wir könnten gleich in das nächste...
Okay.
Da sind die Jungs hier.
Guckt's euch an.
Sind's am Start.
Wie der Fabian jetzt sagen würde.
Am Start.
Wir können...
Zelt, Zeugs abgeben.
Falls der Dude da ist.
Nee, der ist nicht da. Shit.
Okay.
Ähm.
So.
Ich müsste jetzt mal...
Ich müsste jetzt mal trainieren schnell.
Aber erst mal aufholen.
Ja, ich brauch unbedingt Longwind 2.
Das kann ich euch auch gleich zeigen.
Was man davon hat, wenn man PvP macht in dem Spiel.
Also...
Eine der Sachen, die man Vorteile hat.
Und zwar...
Ich bin jetzt...
Rang 1L3.
Also es gibt quasi so 10, 10...
Eigentlich 11.
Nee, ich glaub sogar 14 mittlerweile.
Hauptränge und jeweils immer 10 Unterränge.
Oder 9 Unterränge.
Guck mal da.
Alps am Start.
Lapps.
Die gibt...
Oh, das sind ganz schön viele.
Oh, und das sind auch noch...
Das sind auch noch Hipps am Start.
Okay, wir sollten...
Wir sollten auf jeden Fall die Hipps fokussen.
Und nicht...
Und nicht die Alps.
Nicht die Alps.
Wir sollen die Hipps fok...
Jawoll!
Damage, Damage, Damage.
Volle, volle, volle, volle.
Ja, ja.
Der muss umkippen, bevor die Heiler wieder über den Berg kommen.
Jawoll.
Okay.
Alps.
Lasst die Alps.
Macht die Hipps...
Macht die Hipps down.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt rüber zu den anderen.
Und da seht ihr...
Drei reiche PvP.
Ist das Beste.
Wir haben die jetzt voll ass jammed.
Im Endeffekt.
Gachibas.
Richtig geass jammed.
So.
Snare.
Der Bade.
Der Bade darf nicht frei werden.
Doch, der Bade wird frei.
Nicht ganz.
Oh, ich sprinte ja gar nicht.
Ich kack noob, Alter.
Wie der letzte Kack-Bun, ey.
Ja, guck mal wie er versucht zu straven.
Wie er versucht zu straven.
Ihr kommt hier nicht weg, Leute.
Ihr kommt hier.
Du bleibst stehen.
Ja, guck mal, wie er versucht zu straven.
Wie er versucht zu straven.
Ihr kommt hier nicht weg, Leute.
Ihr kommt hier.
Du bleibst stehen.
Du kommst hier nicht weg, Mann.
So.
Jetzt wird er mal outstraved.
Kann er mal sterben, please?
Jawoll.
Albs sind wieder am Start, hier hinten.
Albs.
Okay.
Albs da drüben.
Alles tot.
Nice.
So mag ich das.
GG Eats.
RVR.
Genau.
Aber hier hast du es wieder gesehen.
Ohne Mist.
Oh.
Unser Land.
So.
RvR mit 3 Fraktionen.
Oder PvP mit 3 Fraktionen.
Das ist einfach das Beste.
Weil während die anderen sich gekloppt haben, wir waren weniger, habt's gesehen, wir waren
weniger, sind drauf, und haben die taktisch geschickt weggebashed.
Nämlich zuerst die, die gewonnen hätten, und dann haben wir aufgeräumt.
Was hast du mit maxFPS gemacht?
Ich habe nur das Logo geklaut.
Ich bin wubblos.
Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt hier alles.
An was ist er denn gestorben?
Oh, oh, oh, ich kack nur.
Ich habe es gar nicht gesehen.
Ich habe es auch nicht gesehen.
Da waren zwei Ranger, Mann.
Im Baum.
Im Baum haben sie sich versteckt.
Keckwait, Mann.
So, was brauchen wir denn hier jetzt noch?
Oh, Mist, Leute.
Mein Inf ist bald voll.
Okay, das können wir löschen.
Das bringt nichts, wenn ich das verkaufe.
Trinkets.
100 Trinkets.
Okay, wir viben jetzt. Respawn.
Auch immer valide Taktik.
So, und jetzt
verkaufen wir mal unseren kompletten
hier.
Makro Move
Sell
Move
Move Item
Sell
All Bags
Ist das das Richtige?
Hier ist ja nichts mehr drin.
Ne.
Jawoll.
Alles gesellt.
Gab es ein bisschen Gold.
Da können wir uns gescheite Items gleich von kaufen.
So, wir haben noch 100 Trinkets zum Abgeben.
Das gibt auf jeden Fall ein halbes Level an XP.
Ja.
Nice.
Let's go.
Ich könnte mal wieder trainieren, fällt mir gerade auf.
Im Prinzip ist es easy zu specken.
Ich specke einfach Battle Songs auf Level Rest in Schwert.
Fertig.
Brauche ich eine neue Waffe?
Nein, noch nicht.
Hier oben, Leute.
Pilzpower.
Das ist der Brain Hip.
Das ist ein Deutscher, soweit ich weiß.
Was heißt, soweit ich weiß?
Ich weiß, dass es ein Deutscher ist.
Er redet auch manchmal Deutsch.
Aber er hört sich auch sonst
sehr, sehr deutsch an.
Das ist der Brain Hip.
Der ratet den ganzen Tag irgendwelche Keeps.
Was geht denn da rechts ab?
Ist hier noch ein Boss,
den wir killen?
Müssen oder was?
Was brauchen wir denn noch?
Bogey?
Was?
Was müssen wir killen?
Bogey Spawns.
Ach, die kleinen Viecher da vorne.
Diese Mini.
Was ist das?
Was ist das, Alter?
Das sind die Darkness Falls Mobs, nur in klein.
Sieben Stück, sechs Stück noch.
Ich glaube, wir sind zu high level.
Das sind zu wenige Mobs.
Wasser Buff.
High IQ seitwärts laufen.
Hier im Wasser ist noch einer.
Okay.
Ich muss unbedingt zum Zelt die Tokens abgeben.
Das gibt richtig dicke Xp.
Nochmal.
Aber du musst doch sagen.
Oder.
Chat, versteht man, dass ich da ohne Probleme
auch mal sechs Stunden Kreiselcrime machen kann in dem Game?
Du kannst halt die ganze Zeit irgendwas machen.
Und du kannst dir im Prinzip selbst ausdenken.
Möchtest du jetzt Action reich PvP?
Möchtest du eher ein bisschen entspannt im Heimgebiet PvM machen?
Ist halt mega nice.
In MMOs gibt es immer genug zu tun.
Ehrlich gesagt sehe ich nicht so.
Wir haben das letzte MMO, was wir vom Scratch angefangen haben zusammen.
Also Fabian und ich.
War Final Fantasy 14.
Da war gerade frisch das Addon raus.
Das war Heavensward, das erste Addon.
Haben wir gemacht.
Haben das Addon durchgespielt.
Es gab nichts zu tun.
Außer Angeln oder irgendwie so ein Blödsinn.
Asia Crinder.
Asia Crinder ist nicht so das.
Okay.
Wir müssen Hips bashen.
Keep.
Immer schön Kamera schwenken, umdrehen.
Gucken, dass man nicht assjammed wird von der Seite.
Und ganz wichtig.
Fuck.
Ich habe ein RP zu wenig.
Ich wollte Longwind 2 specken.
Dass ich besser rennen kann.
Also Longwind 2 beim Leveln, finde ich, lohnt sich extrem.
Dann verliert man nämlich viel weniger Ausdauer beim Sprinten.
In Kombination mit meinem Song für Endu-Reduzierung ist das richtig nice.
Massive nice.
Da kann man nahezu unendlich sprinten, was essentiell für Nahkampf-Character ist.
Weil, naja, Rennen kostet Endu und Nahkampf draufschlagen kostet Endu.
Oh, rechts.
Alps, gib ihm in your face.
Okay, die haben jetzt Skeletten gehabt.
Da machst du nix.
In den modernen MMOs geht es nur noch um Endorphin Instant Creativity.
Das stimmt.
Sehe ich auch so.
Deswegen mag ich das hier auch.
Hier musst du im Endeffekt selbst dafür sorgen, dass du was auf die Reihe kriegst.
Also du musst dir hier auch schon den Plan selbst machen.
Du kannst Stumpf-Kill-Quest ablaufen.
Du kannst PvP machen.
Du kannst auch irgendwelche...
Muss man ja schon sagen, ziemlich braindead High-Level-PvM-Content machen.
Du kannst...
Du hast eigentlich den ganzen Tag was zu tun.
Und wenn du gar nichts mehr zu tun hast, machst du dir noch einen zweiten Charakter.
Oh, Hips hinter uns.
Bade?
Ist das der Bade?
Ich hoffe, das ist der Bade.
Das ist der Bade.
Der wird gefickt jetzt.
Der wird richtig...
Bade gemetzt.
Jawoll.
Jawoll, jawoll, jawoll.
Kack-Noobs, Kack-Noobs.
Get rekt.
Es wäre nice, wenn ich geheilt werde übrigens.
Alter, warum trainen die mich?
Was ist mit euch los, Mann?
Seid ihr dumm?
Lasst mich in Ruhe.
Bade wieder am Start.
Bade am Start.
Bade wird interrupted.
So geht das, Leute.
So geht das.
Der Bade darf nie zum Casten kommen.
Nie.
Oh, Druide gemetzt.
Bade interrupted.
Oh, shit.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ich bin out of range.
Out of range.
Ich bin dumm gelaufen.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ich bin out of range gelaufen.
Ja, das war dumm.
Ach, sind noch welche von der Seite?
Es sind noch mehr Gegner gekommen.
Deswegen.
Okay.
Das sind zwei Gruppen jetzt.
Und noch Alps von hinten.
Ja, gut.
Da machst du nix.
Aber die ersten, die hatten wir eigentlich.
Was willst du machen, ne?
Noch schöne Bogi-Ads und alles.
Ja.
Aber so musst du das machen.
Der Bade darf nicht zum Casten kommen.
Wenn der Bade zum Casten kommt, ist man tot.
Also nicht, weil der Bade dich killt,
sondern weil er dafür sorgt,
dass du dich nicht mehr wehren kannst.
Darnink macht das wirklich gut.
Also sieht man, der hat schon mal Krieger gespielt.
Ja, jetzt ist, jetzt ist dead.
Jetzt, jetzt ist.
Das sind jetzt zu viele.
Guck mal.
Das sind zwei Gruppen plus irgendwelche Schleicher-Ads.
Da machst du nix.
Und noch Alps von hinten.
Best-Up-Game.
Also im Prinzip sind wir fast max-level für das BG.
Wir killen jetzt zwei Mobs und dann ist es vorbei.
Wir können theoretisch, wenn alle 20 werden,
sogar in das nächste BG zusammen gehen.
Schauen wir mal.
Okay, ich brauche Hände und...
Ja.
Unbedingt Hände und einen Helm.
Hab ich grad nicht.
Die Hips am Anfang hatten wir.
Das haben wir richtig gut gemacht.
Muss man sagen.
Für das, dass das so unnötig ist,
so unkoordiniert ist normalerweise in einem BG.
Ich meine, wir sind hier alle nicht im Voice-Chat.
Wir spielen hier quasi auf Sicht.
Man sieht durchaus, dass wir Leute in der Gruppe haben,
die schon mal ihren Charakter gespielt haben.
Auch der BD macht das hier.
Wie heißt der?
Dalamip.
Ist das...
Moment, ist da vorne was?
Nee.
Sind wir jetzt...
Dalamip.
Ist das der Name?
Vielleicht umgedreht geschrieben, wie er sonst heißt?
Bimalat?
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Der hat auch die richtigen Targets mit seinen Pets und sowas.
Und auch den Heiler, den wir da vorhatten.
Echt nicht übel.
Hat man nicht so oft.
Hat man echt nicht so oft.
Im BG.
Aber man darf nicht vergessen, das Spiel ist halt 20 Jahre alt.
Dementsprechend, du hast den einen oder anderen, der auch seinen Char halbwegs spielen kann.
Da oben.
Oben ist Ink.
Der Bade.
Nein, nein, nein, Bade.
Du machst nix.
Da steht er.
Kein Noob.
Nein, nein, du castest nicht.
Du castest nicht.
Da ist ein Schleicher, by the way.
Der Bade ist bald wieder frei.
Der Bade ist frei.
Ich muss auf den Bade.
Ohne Bade sind sie gefickt.
Der muss auf dem Druide bleiben, der andere.
Der muss auf dem Heiler bleiben.
Unbedingt.
Bade, Bade, komm.
Einmal Damage.
Jawohl, dead.
So, Caster.
Voll durch die Bombe gerannt, lul.
Alter, das fällt ja immer mehr.
Fucking shit, man.
Das fällt ja immer mehr, Alter.
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Aber ich glaube, wir können das schaffen.
Okay, okay, nice.
Okay, ich lasse mich nicht backstylen.
Kein Gachi-Bass für euch, Leute.
Da kommen immer noch mehr.
Ich fass es nicht.
Wie viele Ads, man?
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Wie viele Gegner kamen da noch zusätzlich, Mensch?
Guck mal.
Wir haben irgendwie 10 gekillt.
Das sind wieder 10.
Die unendliche Respawn, Mann.
Ist die Kurve nicht extrem hoch bei Dark, da überhaupt reinzukommen?
Also, wenn man ganz alleine startet, ohne jegliche Unterstützung,
ohne Leute, die man fragen kann, braucht man eine Weile, bis man reinkommt.
Ich glaube, das kann man nicht bestreiten.
Aber, sagen wir mal so, es ist jetzt erstmal nicht relevant,
weil du musst nicht PvP leveln.
Ja.
Wo ist denn hier?
Moment, ich muss mal kurz porten.
Also, alleine frustet höchstwahrscheinlich nur, wenn man PvP macht.
Ich würde dir empfehlen, und da kommt man echt ganz gut rein, einfach PvP, äh, PvM leveln.
Also, ganz normale Killtasks und Monster, Monsterkram.
Und, und dann nennst du auch deinen Shark.
kennen und wenn du dann mal so level 30 bist oder so oder 20 oder so was da
kannst du ein bisschen im bg gehen bisschen ein bisschen pvp schnuppern oder
level zu bis 50 durchmachten parades mit 20 ich bin level 20 so schwer auf
leveln es soll braun und nicht die ton braucht auch keiner
dann lasst uns mal kurz die spells abchecken dass der reiz gut neuer wasser
barf haben wir schon haben wir schon wird überschrieben im endeffekt wann
gibt es einen neuen speed auf 23 perina das brauche ich nicht sind da noch
aktiv spieler drin ja ja ich das wir haben heute nur pvp gespielt mit mit
und gegen echte spieler
ja wir haben heute nur pvp gespielt mit mit und gegen echte spieler
habe ich den planer noch irgendwo offen und kann was checken level 20 20 und
rest schwert man gibt es in den nächsten speed das wollte ich eigentlich gucken
23 ok immer 3 13 23 43 43 ok während der während danik afghis
der schon wieder da ich wollte euch sagen kann ich euch noch ein bisschen was
zeigen
zeigen aber also das ich bin echt froh dass ich den gleich auf level 1 jetzt
getroffen habe der übernimmt auch das k fulfilling und sowas was sehr der nice
ist übrigens von der gruppe weiß keiner dass sie gerade im stream sind was das
da ein mit nächstes battle crowns privat einfach mal was der kann ihnen
einfach einladen hier auf pdi kasten drauf slash up hat keinen bock was für ein
spiel jetzt habe ich gar nicht das ist nur ein spiel ist das ist nur ein spiel
Es ist Dark Edge of Camelot auf dem Eden-Free-Chart.
Ja, man muss sagen, manche Leute haben es noch nicht so richtig gecheckt, dass die Regeln auf Eden ein bisschen anders sind.
Normalerweise ist es extrem verpönt, Mobs anzugreifen, also Monster, die andere Leute schon attackiert haben.
Allerdings, auf Eden nicht.
Auf Eden haben sie es nämlich gescheit gemacht, wo ich mich gefragt habe, warum haben die das nicht auf Live schon vor Jahrzehnten gefühlt gemacht.
Und auf Eden kriegst du Quests trotzdem und Sachen trotzdem, auch wenn du die Mobs anhaust, wo jemand anderes schon draufgeschlagen hat.
Es ist auch komplett dumm, wenn nicht.
Da wurde so krass rumgegrieft früher, so mit, ich klau dir Mobs, ich greif deine Mobs an, dann gibt es keine XP und sowas.
Muss mal kurz den Heilsong anmachen.
Ich lass die mal kurz hier ein bisschen bashen.
Ich rack mal schnell, den hitten wir hier.
Okay, na ist fertig.
Jetzt.
Jetzt ist er back.
Dann.
Wir sind fertig, ne?
Wir sind, Return to Captain.
Ja, jetzt müssen wir Beatles killen, einen Boss killen, Deserters killen und natürlich PvP Gegner killen.
Und ja, es gibt aktive Mitspieler, weil das ist ein Free-Shot, das ist nicht der offizielle Server, auf dem wir spielen.
Und da hat eine neue Season gestartet, erst am Samstag, letzten Samstag.
Also quasi vor...
Vier Tagen.
Was ist denn das?
Ein bisschen Mitz, oder?
Ja.
Ich will eigentlich unbedingt nur noch zum, zum weiter Level 1, L4.
Dann hab ich nämlich genug Punkte, um mir Longwind 2 zu kaufen, dann kann ich nahezu unendlich sprinten.
Auch ohne Endu-Pots.
Was sehr nice ist.
Guck mal, der Krieger macht das hier solo jetzt.
Easy, kein Problem.
Der, der stellt es dir alleine weg.
Und ich krieg schon fast auf den Sack von einem einzelnen Orangen.
Krieger ist mit der beste, ähm, reine Nahkampfcharakter, oder, hä, wie, wie nennt man das eigentlich?
Nahkampfklasse im Spiel.
Man kann sich drüber streiten, die sind eigentlich alle ziemlich gut, die, die Main-Tanks der jeweiligen Reich.
Die sind eigentlich alle ganz gut.
Die Mitte gehen, gehen Deserters, oder?
Irgendwo hier sind die.
Irgendwo hier sind die anderen Mitz hin.
Hier müssen wir gucken, weil hier sind Alps.
Da gehen wir nicht hin.
Oh, hier vorne ist die Alps.
LPG.
Da vorne ist die Alp-PG.
Ah, ne, Moment, da sind ja auch die Mitz.
Null.
Ich hab nix gesagt.
Okay.
Wir rennen mal mit den Mitz rum.
Ja, und wie gesagt, zum Thema aktive Spieler.
Letzter.
Äh, zum Thema aktive Mitspieler.
Vor vier Tagen ist die neue Season gestartet.
Mit saumäßig vielen Verbesserungen und richtig geilen Sachen für alle, für alle Langzeit, Langzeit-Dauerspieler.
Und es sind abends aktuell, würde ich sagen.
So, 3.500 Leute ungefähr on.
So würde ich sagen.
Ich glaube, die haben gar keine richtigen Spielzahlen.
Aber sagen wir mal, ungefähr 3.500 Leute.
Und das wird die nächsten Monate über.
Also am Anfang, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt gerade wird es wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen mehr.
So die ersten paar Wochen.
Das wird die nächsten Monate wieder ein bisschen droppen.
So auf 2.500.
Und so zwischen 2.000 und 2.500.
Sagen wir mal zwischen 1.500 und 2.000.
Und so.
Wird es dann eine ganze Weile bleiben.
Und das ist, ähm, also bis dann die Season, so, mehr oder weniger durch ist.
Und das ist super zum Spielen.
Och, guck mal, Alps.
Ach, da sind sie wieder.
Lull.
Das sind die von eben.
Erkennt ihr sie wieder?
Ich hab, ich erkenne diesen komischen Bretonen-Binne wieder.
Ey, was ist mit euch los?
Du bleibst hier.
Das sind die von eben, die wir eben schon mal weggeklatscht haben.
Immer schön seitlich laufen.
Du bleibst hier.
Wo sterben unsere Leute?
Hallo, woran sterben gerade Leute?
What the fuck?
Wo sterben die denn?
Sind die da hinten noch?
Oh, da hinten im Wasser ist noch was.
Lull.
Ich vergesse immer, dass ich die Songs schon angemacht habe.
Hier hinten im Wasser war noch was.
Oh, da hinten ist ein Nekro.
Oh, Attacke.
Okay, ich brauche unbedingt Longwind 2.
1L3, Mann.
Ich brauch mehr Arpies.
Mehr Arpies.
Äh, hallo?
Da sind sie wieder.
Wow.
Alter.
Rekt.
Der hat mich peart.
Voll in your face.
Tja, das geht bei Schleichern ganz gut.
Ich release schnell und komme zurück.
Der hat mir voll ins Gesicht peart.
Also es gibt, so zur Erklärung, Schleicher sind alles Sacken eigentlich.
Außer in 1vs1-Files und sowas.
Aber das Ding ist.
Also in Gruppen-Files kannst du Schleicher vergessen.
Aber jedes Klasse hat so 1-2 Schleicher-Klassen.
Und die haben in allen Reichen eine Fähigkeit.
Und zwar, wenn die direkt vor einem stehen und getarnt sind,
dann können die so einen super krassen Angriff machen.
Und den habe ich gerade komplett ins Gesicht bekommen.
Normalerweise passiert das nicht,
weil du normalerweise nicht frontal auf den Schleicher zuläufst, der getarnt ist.
Aber das hat mich ziemlich, ziemlich zerrissen gerade.
Ich brauche eine neue Waffe.
Äh, Bounty Merchant.
Und zwar Greatswords.
15 Bounty Points.
Sehr gut.
So.
Also, Danik muss weg.
Das Game war noch nie offline.
Aber es gibt Eden wieder.
Eden Season 2 seit Samstag.
Und deswegen gibt es wieder ein paar tausend Spieler, die spielen.
Gleich wird es ein bisschen entspannter.
Gleich machen wir ein bisschen Solo-PvE-Kill-Quests.
Oder mal gucken, mal gucken.
Ich werde auf jeden Fall nicht Solo-FVR spielen oder PvP spielen,
ohne dass hier gescheite Crews am Start sind.
Alter, wo ist, wo ist der BD?
Wir haben ihn irgendwie verloren, oder?
Ich habe doch extra Wasser-Buff gemacht.
Du kannst tauchen, du kannst tauchen.
Ja, komm ins Wasser.
Wir haben unseren BD verloren.
Unser BD ist sonst wo da hinten.
Den sollten wir aber mal einsammeln gehen.
Das ist, oh, das ist super risky, wo der langläuft.
Der läuft direkt an der Brücke, wo die Alps lang kommen, lang.
Okay, vielleicht kriegen wir ein paar Deserter.
Also, ich werde euch jetzt mal kurz erzählen.
Für alle, die vielleicht früher schon mal Dark,
für die Leute, die schon mal ein bisschen früher Dark gespielt haben,
ein paar Sachen, die die bei Eden geändert haben.
Es gibt jetzt eine Sache, die sich alle gewünscht haben.
Es gibt ab und zu Home-Invasion-Events,
dass du quasi bis ins innere Land des jeweiligen anderen Realms rein kannst.
Das gibt es nicht dauerhaft, das gibt es nur Events.
Aber das ist mega nice.
Das ist nicht Ingame-Musik, das ist eine Playlist.
Wo sind Gegner?
Ich sehe keine Gegner.
Ach, hier neben dir.
Ja, oh, wir kriegen gleich auf den Sack.
Oh, jetzt kommt Sneaking-Taktics.
Ja, also es gibt ab und zu Home-Invasion-Events.
Das Leveln ist, finde ich, viel angenehmer als früher.
Weil du mit Killtasten und PvP ordentlich leveln kannst.
Hier, Stealth-Modus aktiviert, Leute.
Niemand, niemand kommt drauf, dass wir hier stehen.
Hier unten sind übrigens die Alps.
Das sieht man auf der Map.
Die haben quasi ein...
Ich glaube, die haben ein Relikt, dass man sie sieht.
Oder ist das eine Alp-BG, dass man sie sieht?
Ich bin mir unschlüssig gerade.
Die sehen uns auf der Map auf jeden Fall nicht.
Haben die Radar?
Woher wissen die, dass wir da sind, Alter?
Das ist eine Playlist von YouTube.
Was ist denn?
Was machen die Alps da unten?
Wir brauchen eigentlich nur die Gegner hier.
Dann haben wir die Quests für das BG auch fertig.
Ein Level haben wir schon durch.
Wir hauen mal ab.
Warum wir hier rumrennen ist, wir sind nur vier und das andere sind zehn plus.
Da können wir nichts machen.
Wir sind gar nicht auf dem Level.
Die campen den Spot da oben.
Da oben sind zwei gelaufen gerade.
Die machen die Quests, die Alps da oben.
Die machen die Quests.
Wie viele Mids haben wir?
Wir haben 19.
Wir haben 19 hier im BG und wir sind nur vier.
Wo ist denn der Rest von uns?
Hätte ich um zwei oder höher?
2002 rum war das.
Ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher.
Oh Shit.
Oh, S-Champ, S-Champ.
Oh Fuck, der hat uns gesehen.
Wir sind gefickt.
Okay, wir sind dead.
Wir sind, okay, wir sind dead.
Officially dead.
Alter, so viele Mobs auch dabei.
Nice.
Officially dead sind wir.
Offiziell.
Es ist offiziell.
Naja.
Haben die Athlon?
Ja, ich glaube, ich hatte einen Athlon 1900.
Gab's sowas?
Okay, Gruppe ist Gruppe ist Gruppe ist fertig.
Alles klar.
Dann.
Das bände ich mal.
Und jetzt kann ich ein bisschen was über das Game erzählen,
was ich euch die ganze Zeit schon erzählen wollte.
Und zwar nur für den Fall der Fälle.
Dass irgendjemand doch.
Soll ich sagen, den.
Die Lust verspürt.
Sich das mal anzugucken, das Game.
Also ich.
Ich will euch jetzt nichts erzählen, dass das super einfach ist vom Einstieg.
Ist es nicht.
Jetzt gucken, ob ich mir nicht gescheite Rüstung noch kauf.
Bounty Points 305.
Okay, lass mal, lass mal, lass mal ein bisschen pfeif sein.
Lass mal ein bisschen pfeif sein.
Okay, Schwerte haben wir ganz gute.
Rüstung ist auch durchaus noch okay.
Ich würde sagen, wir brauchen gar keine Bounty Points auszugeben.
Wir gehen einfach zum Quartermaster und holen uns dort was.
Wenn ich wüsste, wo der aktuelle Quartermaster ist.
Ich glaube in der Grenzfestung.
Gucken wir mal.
Und ich selle den Rest mal.
Wie war das?
Shift S zum Sellen.
Shift S.
Ach so, man kann das nicht verkaufen.
Kann man nur zerstören.
Shift S, was man damit macht.
Wie sehen eigentlich meine Stats aktuell aus?
Lass mal kurz checken.
Ich brauche Stärke.
Volle Pulle, Quickness.
Bisschen Constitution und Charisma.
Charisma fehlt mir das jetzt aber erst mal nicht so wild.
Hits, Quickness, Decks, Quickness, Magic Skills, Constitution, Parry.
Parry juckt mich nicht.
So.
Was hat man hier? Wollen wir kurz gucken.
Constitution, Strengths, Quickness, das ist top.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Belt, Quickness.
Okay, der suckt.
Der suckt ja noch mehr.
Okay.
Lolwee, Schrott.
Schrott.
Aber hier Constitution, Quickness, Hits.
Das ist ganz gut.
Quickness, Constitution, Spirited Decks.
Okay, auf jeden Fall den.
Das verkaufen.
Killaloe brauche ich halt nicht.
Weiß nicht, ob man die noch irgendwo einlösen kann.
Tinderbox.
Gut.
Also ich, ich hatte damals einen AMD Athlon XP.
Gab es einen Athlon?
Athlon XP 1900 plus.
Ja, den hatte ich damals.
Ich glaube, dass ich glaube, das war mein Daok PC, mein erster Daok PC.
Mit einem, passt mal auf, mit einem
Zalman Lüfter.
So, so ein Ding war das noch.
Irgendwie hatten die damals super Lüfter und danach nie wieder.
Die waren richtig wild.
Ja, den Zalman hatte jeder, aber schon irgendwie.
Okay, lass uns mal kurz trainen.
Battlesongs.
Oh, gibt's nichts geschafft.
Battlesongs und Schwert.
Der sollte eigentlich die Sachen hier selbst replacen.
Aber man weiß ja nie.
Ich muss jetzt mal ein paar Sachen kurz zur Vorbereitung machen.
Sonst, sonst wird es nachher nervig.
Jetzt so Mana Song.
Muss mal kurz in die Housing Zone porten.
Auch so ein Ding.
Das lasst mal kurz vor die Tür schauen, ob dort irgendwie noch mit am Start sind.
Also, das ist nämlich auch so ein Ding.
In Daok kann man sich Häuser kaufen.
Gibt es eine extra Zone für.
Kann man sich Häuser kaufen und in den Häusern kann man dann Drops,
random generierte Items, gecraftete Items, Tränke und sowas anbieten, dass andere Spieler das kaufen können.
Und da will ich jetzt mal gucken nach Endu Tränken.
Oh, ist das teuer.
The fuck, warum ist das so teuer?
So viel Geld habe ich nicht.
Ich brauche aber einen Endu Trank.
Ich habe nur 53 Gold, ich bin Level 21.
Was haben wir denn hier?
30 Charges Endu 3.
100 Charges Endu 3.
Okay, 90 Gold muss ich irgendwie zusammenkratzen.
Ja, dann kann ich, dann kann ich mir Endu Tränke kaufen.
Endu Tränke sind enorm, also sind quasi essentiell, dass man ordentlich melee, Nahkampfcharakter spielen kann.
Ich habe halt kein Endu Trank.
Kein Geld.
Ich habe vorhin erst angefangen zu leveln.
Okay, dann holen wir uns mal neue Ausrüstung ab.
Ich glaube, die standen hier irgendwo rum.
Also Core to Duo hat damals noch keiner dran gedacht.
Damals hatten die CPU Hersteller noch die Devise.
Mach mehr Takt und dann wird alles besser.
Intel kam ja damals auf die glorreiche Idee.
Vielleicht erinnert sich da noch einer dran.
Intel kam ja damals auf die Idee.
ATX, ATX kennt ihr alle, oder?
Vom Namen her.
Sind die Quartermaster verbuggt?
Oder ich glaube, die Quartermaster sind einfach zu High Level für mich.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Quartermaster sind für mein Level.
Gut, wir machen ein paar Killtasks, damit wir ein bisschen Gold kriegen und XP.
Dazu gehen wir auf Eden in das Wiki.
In das Eden Wiki und schauen uns die Midgard Quests an und schauen, in welche Zone wir müssen.
11, 10 bis 34 Westerland und Gotha.
Curse Tomb machen wir nicht.
Dungeons habe ich jetzt keinen Bock.
Mount brauche ich nicht.
Ich habe Speed.
Haben wir gerade.
Vendor machen wir auch nicht.
Okay, wir können West-Zweiland und Gotha.
Wir können mal gucken.
Agil gibt es nichts mehr.
Da sind wir.
Die machen wir. Die machen wir.
Die sind nice, die Quests.
Und da sind wir mit 21 genau richtig für.
Die machen wir.
Ja.
Perfekt.
Porter.
Wo ist hier ein Teleporter-Dude, Mann?
Hier.
Da.
Agil, wo ist es?
Ja.
Da wollen wir hin.
Wollen Quests.
Da waren ein paar Kill-Quests und wir brauchen auf jeden Fall Gold.
Ja, und wenn ich die Quests angenommen habe,
dann erzähle ich mal, was es so für Klassen gibt und sowas.
Falls irgendjemand doch Bock hat, sich das anzugucken.
Xepp.
Was?
Wie, warum gibt es da nur eine Quest?
Wie?
Nur eine Quest?
Das ist das falsche Gebiet, oder?
Bin ich, bin ich komplett, komplett pepega?
Warum gibt es da nur eine?
20 bis 24.
Gibt es nur eine Quest?
Es ist ja komplett bescheuert.
Wie läuft euer Job?
Ganz gut.
Wir machen schnell die Quest.
Das ist ja easy.
Ich habe, ich habe gehofft, vielleicht hat hier noch einer was.
Gut, die Quest machen wir schon.
Es wird jetzt nicht allzu wahnsinnig viel XP geben.
Ach ja, ich wollte fast zu Hardware sagen, ob es wer kennt.
Richtig.
Vielleicht kennst du jemand.
Intel war ja damals komplett lost.
Intel, also ATX kennt ihr ja alle noch.
Intel wollte damals den, ich laufe übrigens falsch, den BTX-Standard einführen,
weil Intel sich gedacht hat, es wird zu warm in Rechnern und Intel ist damals nichts
mehr eingefallen, außer, ja, dann brauchen wir neuen Gehäuse-Standard und neuen
Mainboard-Standard, wo man einfacher die Abwärme abführen kann.
Ja, und dreimal dürft ihr raten, wie gut sich das durchgesetzt hat.
Keck-Wait.
Kennt jemand heute noch BTX-Gehäuse?
Also, ich glaube, die wenigsten.
Ihr kennt vielleicht noch BTX, dieses Telekom-Internet da.
So, lass mal kurz checken, wo gibt's denn hier sonst noch Quests?
Ja, 25 geht's da weiter.
Moonen Sound.
Das können wir machen.
Okay, das ist gut, weil sobald wir 25 sind, gehen wir dahin.
Das sind gute, das sind nice Zonen.
Guck mal, Manfred am Start.
Ice Age ist auch so eine Filmserie.
Ich hab das erste, ich hab den ersten Ice Age-Film voll gefeiert.
Zweiten hab ich mir angeguckt, hab mir gedacht, okay, jetzt sind euch die Ideen ausgegangen.
Danach hab ich nie wieder eingeguckt.
Aber der erste, Ice Age, den fand ich echt nice, den kann ich auch immer mal wieder gucken.
Habe jetzt zum zweiten, ersten neuen Job als Admin 100% Home Office.
Okay, das ist gut.
Wenn man drauf steht.
Also, ich würde das auch machen.
Okay, dann lass uns mal Björn, Shrek und Talvor killen.
Und Uga auch? Nein, Uga nicht.
Moment, wir sind hier auch falsch.
Tore? Ne, Moment, den sollen wir gar nicht killen.
Wir müssen, wir müssen zum nächsten Camp.
Hier, hier sind angeblich
Viecher, die man killen soll.
Angeblich, angeblich ist hier ein Boss.
Booba, Bobri.
Aber hier ist kein Boss.
Seht ihr einen? Ich sehe keinen.
Hier sollte eigentlich Björn, Shrek oder Talvor sein.
Gucken wir mal, ob da oben einer ist.
Erst mal Shrek bashen.
Da ist er doch, da ist er doch.
Oh ne, lass, lass das Viech.
Alter, Finger weg.
Mein Boss.
Never donated, never subscribed, neighbors wifi, stolen laptop.
Ich entwalte den BD.
Es ist einfach viel angenehmer, das mit mehreren Leuten zu machen.
Ach, der ist erst 20, okay.
Das ist auch eine Sache.
Die finde ich an Dark wirklich nice.
Du bist permanent dazu angehalten,
halt einfach mit anderen Leuten zusammenzuspielen.
Da ist Shrek.
Moin, Shrek wird jetzt weggeschreckt.
Oh, Shrek kriegt richtig Damage reingefahren.
Stimmt, ich habe gehört, Cyberpunk gab es 2.1 Update.
Okay, der Kerl ist halb AFK.
So, ich brauche jetzt eigentlich nur noch einen Boss.
Rick, Rick, kommst du mit oder nicht?
Wir brauchen noch einen.
Wir brauchen noch Björn als Boss.
Okay, Rick hat keinen Bock.
Rick kommt nicht mit.
Okay, der ist fertig mit der Quest.
So, ich muss Björn killen.
Wo ist Björn, Alter?
Angeblich ist Björn hier.
Laut meiner Map.
Wo ist Björn?
Buba.
Björn muss noch respawnen.
Kann das sein?
Aber zum Glück sind die Respawn-Timer kurz.
Respawn-Timer dauern so drei bis vier, fünf Minuten.
Und davon sind jetzt wahrscheinlich schon fünf Minuten.
Der kann nicht mal lange dauern.
Wo ist Björn?
Ich kill jetzt mal das Viech, solange ich auf Björn warte.
Björn wird gebasht, sobald er auftaucht.
Es kann auch nicht scheinen, weil ich brauche ein bisschen Gold.
Shrek Bracer.
Kann er was?
Parry, Hits, Slash, Dexterity.
Nun ja.
Hits, Parry.
Parry all melee weapons.
Es ist besser.
Shrek's Bracer sucked.
Da, Björn.
Alter, dich habe ich gewartet.
Björn Champ am Start.
Hab gerade meinen ersten Job nach der Ausbildung angeboten bekommen.
Die sucht eine komplette IT-Abteilung in mir.
Nice.
Kannst du, kannst du scheren?
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Nee, lass. Selbst wenn du es kannst, lass es lieber sein.
Nicht, dass das irgendwie negativ auf dich zurückfällt.
Okay, nice.
Porten wir mal zum Bind Stone.
Gut, Quests done hier.
Porten wir zum Bind Stone.
Ich bin übrigens richtig dumm.
Von den Aufgaben.
Ja, zeig mal.
Würde mich, würde mich interessieren.
Porten zurück zum Bind Stone, zurück
zu dem NPC.
Und dann sind wir halt leider noch nicht 25.
Dann müssen wir entweder doch noch mal in BG gucken.
Oder wir machen Mirkwurz.
Mulan ist okay.
Nee, die machen wir.
Die ja, ja, ja, die machen wir.
Das ist eine schöne.
Das ist eine schöne Schleife, glaube ich, die man hier laufen kann.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist eine schöne Schleife, die man laufen kann.
Frontier Quest. Gibt es die auf dem Level überhaupt schon?
Sind die TOR-Quests gibt es jetzt ja auch.
Ach, der Arab 20.
Ich dachte, die gibt es erst ab, keine Ahnung.
40 oder so.
Ach, die sind. Ja, dann machen wir Frontier-Quests.
Spielst du noch manchmal mit dem Friseur?
Selten, selten.
Gerade mit so, jeder mit seinem Zeug.
Wie schicke ich dir am besten Screenshot?
Keine Ahnung, einfach hier im Immegur oder irgendwo hochladen.
Image CC Flicker, wo auch immer und dann Link posten zum Screenshot.
Okay, Zack, was wollte ich jetzt machen?
Quest abgeben.
Ach, Frontier-Quests gibt es ab, das ist auch neu.
Also letzte Season, wo ich gelevelt habe, gab es noch gar keine Frontier-Quests.
Da gab es nur die.
Da gab es nur dann Deserter-Quests und tägliche Kill-Tasks und sowas.
Gucken wir von den Leuten, die ich aus letzter Season kenne.
Irgendjemand anders.
Okay, einer ist schon mal 50.
Kann ich mich dran erinnern?
Lul.
Ich hab.
Ich spiel ernsthaft.
Es spielt nur.
Geht das sortieren?
Okay, von den von den Leuten, mit denen ich
gespielt habe letzte Season irgendwie.
Also die ich mal gefriended habe.
Irgendwie keiner, keiner am Start mehr.
Finish.
Okay, zeigt mal her.
Okay, wir gucken uns das mal schnell an.
Was sollst du machen? Halbe IT-Abteilung.
Ihre Aufgaben Betreuung von IT-Infrastruktur,
Hardware, Software im Bereich der Verwaltung und der Ausstellung.
Oh, Verwaltung.
Das klingt so ein bisschen nach öffentlicher Dienst oder sowas.
Wir porten mal kurz ins RvR-Gebiet.
Wo könnten die Quartermaster sein?
Ah, guck mal, wir kriegen neue Schuhe.
Das ist ja nice.
Shrek-Spracer brauche ich nicht.
Wir sellen das einfach jetzt schnell noch.
Chartmans, Stablemaster, SSS, weg, Tinderbox.
Ja, so nice die sind.
Okay, das brauchen wir auch nicht mehr.
Destroy.
Wobei, Disclunky kann ich abgeben.
Killaloe brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Tinderbox, das heben wir auf.
Das ist so ein Campfire.
Da reckt man, reckt man schneller.
Okay, porten wir mal ins RvR-Gebiet und machen RvR-Tasks.
Kommt ja noch mehr, kommt ja noch mehr PvP an den Start.
Wobei, im großen RvR-Gebiet, PvP-Gebiet bin ich halt Futter.
Sobald irgendjemand kommt, bin ich direkt Futter.
Auf der anderen Seite.
Ich bin auch grau, ich gebe keine Punkte.
Okay, also zeigt mal her.
Betreuung IT-Infrastruktur, Hardware und Software.
Bereich der Verwaltung und Administration von Servern.
Professionelle Unterstützung der Anwender in Hardware.
Alter, Anwendersupport.
Was ist mit denen los, man?
Was ist mit denen los?
Weiterentwicklung der gesamten IT-Infrastruktur, der gesamten.
Konzeptionelle Weiterentwicklung der gesamten IT-Infrastruktur.
Konfiguration zentraler IT-Systeme.
Also AD, LDAP, Datensicherung, Dokumentenmanagement.
Alter, was ist mit denen los?
Unterstützung bei IT-Projekten.
Pflege der Internetpräsenz.
Hardware-Software bestellen, Software-Verträge.
Mitwirkung beim Datenschutz.
Zusammenarbeit mit dem Rechtsanwalt.
Wer hat denn das wieder geschrieben, man?
Wer hat das wieder geschrieben, Alter?
Zu geil.
Midcard Frontier Explorers.
Nice.
Okay, ich lehne mal kurz die alten Quests ab.
Die alten.
Die alten Quests.
Das Star-Orc-Quest-Menü fühlt sich halt echt an wie 1995.
Alter, der Witz ist halt, es ist nicht 1995.
Es ist 2001.
Killer-Lo, brauchen wir auch nicht mehr.
Äh, The Trunky behalten wir.
The Subtle Living Frontier behalten wir auch.
Okay, Midgard Frontier Explorers, let's go.
Alles klar, auf geht's.
Äh, da.
Ach, das ist auch noch hinterm Wall.
Easy, easy.
Da kommt doch nicht mal einer hin.
Ich bräuchte unbedingt 1L4, dass ich, dass ich Longwind 2 holen kann.
Naja, wir machen jetzt erst mal hier ein paar Mobs.
Dann gehen wir noch mal kurz ins BG
und holen uns noch ein paar RPs.
Müssen wir das killen? Was müssen wir killen?
Yakr, Yakr, Snowman, Run,
Shizzler müssen wir killen.
Frosty, Scuttlebug.
Und Snowim, okay, also von denen müssen wir 10 Stück killen.
Nice, easy.
Ja, gesamte IT-Infrastruktur ist halt mega übertrieben.
Oh, das ist solo so langweilig.
Ich brauche irgendjemanden, der mitmacht.
Äh, any Frontier Questers, Alter.
Das wird zu langweilig, Mann.
Das ist so, okay, die 10 Stück kill ich jetzt, 10 Stück kill ich jetzt.
Aber mehr halte ich denn aus?
Brauche auch wieder neue Rüstung.
Ich hab's ja gesagt.
Rüstung auf typisch low IQ Warnung, Kreisel, Grinder streamen.
Ich bräuchte mal einen besseren Anytimer-Style.
Wann gibt es denn einen?
Eden, Dark, Charplaner.
Wann gibt's einen gescheiten Anytimer für Schwert?
12, 34 erst, ehh.
Vielleicht soll ich doch Hammer-Spec.
Bis zum Leveln.
Mit 34
kriege ich erst
ersten gescheiten Anytime-Style, Mann.
Das ist ja schon richtig
mies, ne?
Ja, killen wir halt 10 Käfer, gut ist.
Also, Fabian,
ich geh mal davon aus,
dass diese Stellenanzeige wahrscheinlich
schlimmer ist, als es
also sich schlimmer liest, als
es ist, denn
dadurch, dass es wahrscheinlich
die Behörde oder irgendwie sowas ist, vermute
ich jetzt einfach mal,
haben die wahrscheinlich
genaue Vorgaben, was da unten
was da drinnen stehen muss
und dementsprechend ist das
nicht unbedingt tatsächlich dann
so deine Aufgaben.
Auf Käfer,
sterben, please.
Ist ja schrecklich.
Okay, Leute, ich mach 10 Kills,
danach geh ich wieder ins RVR-Gemiet.
Also, danach geh ich wieder in BG
und mach zumindest
nochmal bis 1.11.4
und dann brauch ich Gold,
dass ich mir Endu-Tränke kaufen kann.
Und wenn ich Endu-Tränke hab, ich brauch ja nicht
mehr viel Gold, wenn ich Endu-Tränke
hab, dann ist easy, dann kann
ich das hier chainen quasi.
Naja, fast.
Und ne gescheite Rüstung vor allem.
Also, falls einer Bock hat
auf Frontier-Quests, Level 20,
dann... Das ist auch was Neues,
ihr seht das hier unten nicht, aber die
haben immer ständig wechselnde Zonen
auf Eden,
wo es für Solos,
Duos
oder, ja, alles,
was nicht, alles, also,
es gibt extra Zonen für Solospieler,
für Duospieler
und für Smallman-Spieler, also, ich glaub, alles unter 5.
Was ich echt cool finde.
Ey,
da ist was.
Oh, die Elite ist am Start hier.
Sind so
special,
ganz special Guild ist das.
Die haben sich bei mir
mal aufgeregt,
dass ich im PvP auf ihre Gegner
gehauen hab.
Ey, hätte ich früher auch.
Ich, mittlerweile bin ich deutlich entspannter,
was das angeht.
Oh, ist da unten ein Gegner gewesen?
Snow Imp soll wir auch killen,
glaub ich.
Ich lauf jetzt einfach mit denen mit und mach die Quests.
Warum nicht?
Doch ganz nice.
So, haben wir irgendwas gedroppt? Nope.
Ich lauf jetzt einfach mit denen mit,
weil wenn die hier anfangen, machen die die gleiche
Quest. Oh, easy.
Und zu dritt
ist man auf jeden Fall schneller.
Gibt sogar nen Camp,
Fire. So, was brauchen wir denn sonst noch?
Snow Imps gab's doch noch?
Snow Imp. Da unten
hab ich doch Snow Imps gesehen, oder?
Jawoll, Snow Imps. Wie viel ist...
Oh, 20!
Aber, wenn die Leute dabei sind,
dann geht das. Komm, scheiß drauf.
Ist halt mal...
Ist halt mal langweiliger Kreisel,
Cryant. Ich hoffe,
ich hoffe, das gibt ordentlich,
ordentlich XP dann gleich.
Weil das halt ich nicht lang aus.
Den Solo-XP.
Cryant.
So. Ach, mehr gibt's nicht,
oder was? Das waren alle.
Dachte, hier stehen noch mehr rum.
Lul.
Richtig Boomer-Mode am Start.
Yep. Yep, Clock.
Hier ist angeblich
was? Ich seh hier nix.
Was soll hier sein?
Käfer vielleicht.
Aber die Käfer hab ich ja schon.
Gehen wir mal zum nächsten.
Na, viel mehr als 4 Pixel sind sie auch nicht.
Vielleicht 8 Pixel.
Wie viel spielst du noch?
Du meinst das Game?
Ich hab jetzt die Woche saumäßig viel
Kreiselcrank gemacht, weil die neue Season
hier gestartet ist.
Müssen wir die Dinger bashen hier?
Ey, die sind zu hoch für mich.
Nee, oder?
Die müssen wir nicht bashen.
Vorne müssen wir irgendwas bashen.
Snow.
Snowmans müssen wir bashen.
Endu-Reggin.
Brauch unbedingt Endu-Potz.
Sonst ist das...
sehr nervig und
langweilig.
Gelbe kann ich Chain killen, das ist kein Ding.
Ich überlege gerade, was die beste
Song-Kombi ist. Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie
Makro-Software am Start hätte,
würde ich einfach alle Songs
durch irgendeinen Makro-Trigger lassen.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist
Endo-Reduce
und ein bisschen Heal,
auch wenn der Heal in Fight schwach ist,
ganz gut,
weil dann kannst du fast
Chain kloppen, Gelbe.
Also die Woche habe ich enorm
viel gespielt, weil, wie gesagt, Season Start
und Season Start
ist halt immer
Pock, Reinkreiten, Kreisel
mäßig. Level Up heißt.
Okay, trainieren.
Battle Songs, neues
Zeug. Ah, neuer Endo-Reduce.
Das ist sehr schick.
Umso weniger Endo
ich verbrauche, umso besser.
Und ein neuer Snare.
Ja, auch gut.
Du hast früher mit den Makros gemacht. Ich habe gerade nichts am Start.
Sonst würde ich es auch mit Makros machen.
Übrigens, Makros sind auf dem Server
erlaubt, solange es keine Loops
sind.
Der Onkel Bob ist am Start.
Solange es keine Loops sind. Also wenn du immer
alle deine Auren selbst triggerst,
alle 5 Sekunden oder so, dann ist es okay.
Wenn du einen Loop
eingebaut hast, der quasi, ohne
dass du alle 5 Sekunden selbst eine Taste drückst,
triggerst, ist es verboten.
Ob das wirklich
irgendjemand kostet,
kontrolliert.
I don't know.
Guck mal hier.
Lohnt sich richtig mit
mit dem neuen Endo-Chant.
Seht ihr?
Das verliert man fast kaum noch Endo hier im Fight.
So ist das gut.
So hat man relativ schnell 20 dann weggekloppt.
Moin.
So, und danach machen wir, wir kloppen jetzt die 20 um.
Ich glaube, die andere Quest mache ich nicht.
Das ist mir zu langweilig.
Dann gehen wir kurz noch PvP machen, bis ich 1 L4 bin.
Für Longwind 2.
Dass ich unendlich sprinten kann.
Oder vielleicht, müssen wir mal gucken,
vielleicht kann ich sogar jetzt schon unendlich sprinten.
Ich müsste eigentlich.
Ich habe aber weder Endo-Juwel,
noch einen Endo-Trank bis jetzt.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Weil unendlich sprinten können, ist enorm wichtig für Nahkampf-Character.
Denn, also ihr habt es ja vorhin gesehen,
ich war vorhin quasi fast permanent out of Endo,
wenn ich irgendwelchen Gegnern nachgerannt bin,
weil halt zu viel Endo verpasst wurde.
Und ich habe so viel Endo-Verbrauch mit Nahkampfangriffen plus Sprint.
Also ist wichtig, dass man Endo hat.
Und ich müsste mal einen Dungeon machen,
dass ich so ein Endo-Rack-Teil kriege.
Aber die mache ich nicht gerne.
Die mache ich immer erst gerne nur die High-Level-Sachen,
weil dann macht man die Eimer und gut ist.
Ich sehe hier auch so wenig.
Kann das sein, dass ich...
Aliens?
Habe ich irgendwie LF Advice?
Chat?
Muss ich mal alles anmachen wieder.
Jetzt hatte ich alles ausgeschaltet.
Officer?
Ja, meinetwegen auch.
Aliens?
Looking for Croup?
Ja.
Schalte ich mal alles ein, dass ich sehe,
falls irgendjemand Dungeons oder so machen will,
die in meinem Level, in meiner Level-Range sind.
Okay, was suchen die hier unten?
Wenn jetzt übrigens ein Gegner kommt,
bin ich instant One-Shot.
Ja.
Patrick, siehst du, ich muss ja auch noch leveln.
Ich bin ja erst Level 22.
Also mein Ziel ist eigentlich 40 heute.
Ja.
Was auch durchaus geht, wenn ich auch ein paar Leute,
also wenn wir noch ein bisschen RvR machen,
bisschen PvP.
Und wenn ich dann noch ein paar,
vielleicht die ein oder anderen Sachen nebenbei mitnehmen kann,
dann geht 40 schon ganz gut.
Also wenn man natürlich eine richtig gute fixe Croup hat,
ist man innerhalb von ein paar Stunden 40.
Aber mir ist das so eigentlich ganz recht.
Ich habe ja auch mit ganzen Leuten,
haben ja diese Season wenig Bock.
Ja.
Also ich muss jetzt mal kurz ein bisschen Leben raggen.
So, wie viele brauchen wir von diesem Müll denn hier noch?
Sechs Stück.
Wobei, ich ragge mal kurz noch Mana.
Komm.
Mana schnell gereckt.
Normalerweise würde ich mir einen Mana-Trank kaufen
und einen Endo-Trank kaufen.
Und dann sehe die Welt schon mal ganz anders aus.
Aber ich bin in Level 22 und die Season hat gestartet.
Ich habe kein Geld.
Satch.
Zumindest habe ich eine gute Waffe.
Off.
Kipp um.
Jo.
Während ich hier PvM mache,
erzähle ich euch mal ein bisschen was.
Und zwar,
was ich euch eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit erzählen wollte.
Aber nicht dazu gekommen bin,
weil zu viel PvP-MBG-Action.
Also falls irgendjemand Bock hat, sich das Game mal anzugucken.
Gerade Leute, die auf Oldschool-MMOs stehen.
Für mich ist es immer noch das beste PvP-MMO.
Für PvM sucht ihr vielleicht was anderes.
Wenn es auch gerade was Croup-Content angeht,
bisschen was zu bieten hat.
Aber es ist kein World of Warcraft PvM oder so.
Zumindest wollte ich einfach mal so ein bisschen was über die Klassen erzählen, die es gibt.
Denn was ich so gemerkt habe,
was die letzten Jahre über in MMOs
doch ziemlich, ziemlich zurückgegangen ist,
ist Support-Klassen.
Es gibt kaum noch MMOs mit richtigen Support-Klassen.
Leute, welches neue MMO fällt euch ein,
die richtig echte Support-Klassen haben?
Also richtig echte Support-Klassen sind für mich Klassen,
ohne die du eigentlich nicht spielen kannst,
aber die alleine nichts auf die Reihe kriegen.
Da fällt mir echt nicht viel ein.
Ich meine, wenn man sich Final Fantasy anguckt,
dann haben die schon Support-Klassen und Heiler,
aber die können alle Solo-Overs machen.
So in Dark ist es halt so,
du hast ProRealm,
hast du mehrere Support-Klassen,
du hast meistens so eine Main-Heal-Klasse und Main-Buff-Klasse.
Manchmal ist das auch in einem.
Und in der Regel kriegen die halt Solo nicht allzu viel hin.
Aber du brauchst sie in jeder Gruppe,
eigentlich mindestens zwei.
Und du kommst halt ohne nicht aus.
Und was ich gemerkt habe ist,
dass es ganz viele Leute gibt,
denen das wahnsinnig viel Spaß macht,
Support-Klassen zu spielen in Dark.
Wo man ja erstmal denkt,
ey, ich meine,
warum sollte ich was spielen,
was selbst nichts killen kann?
Aber es scheint enorm viele,
also ich spiele übrigens auch gerne Support,
also das scheint enorm viele Leute Spaß zu machen.
Auch wenn es sich jetzt erstmal nicht so anhört.
Aber nur weil du selbst nichts killen kannst,
heißt das nicht, dass die Klassen leicht zu spielen wären.
Und ja, nichts können.
Also ich würde mal sagen,
in jeder guten Gruppe sind die Supporter mit entscheidend für,
dass sie was auf die Reihe kriegt oder nicht.
Sind alle für entscheidend,
aber Supporter ganz besonders.
Und Supporter sind auch die einzigen,
die auf irgendwelchen Raids nicht schlafen können,
weil sonst alle sterben.
Als DPS stellst du dich in Dark an den Gegner dran,
drückst einen Knopf,
alle drei Sekunden und fertig.
Ja.
Und es gibt in jedem Realm Main Support-Klassen,
Main Buff-Klassen.
Dann hast du in jedem Realm natürlich Main Tanks,
so wie in jedem MMO.
Wobei man halt sagen muss,
in Dark ist es so,
Main Tanks sind ziemlich gute Damage-Dealer,
PvP-technisch,
PvM-technisch nicht so sehr.
Und dann hast du natürlich die üblichen Sachen,
wie Off-Tanks,
die ordentlich was aushalten,
aber richtig, richtig gut Melee-Damage machen.
Moment.
Bin ich eigentlich fertig mit der Quest, Leute?
Ich glaube, ich bin fertig, oder?
Ich muss die gar nicht mehr killen.
Ich bin durch.
Null.
Okay, der ist verbuggt.
Den kann ich nicht hitten.
Hallo, Game.
Ich glaube, ich bin fertig.
Easy.
Ja, die hätte ich gar nicht mehr killen müssen.
Null.
Heck, wait.
Ne.
Gut, wo wir gerade dabei sind,
ich kille jetzt nochmal hier vorne die,
weil ich bin gerade am Erzählen.
Vielleicht habe ich dann auch genug Sachen.
Aha, neue Armlinge.
Excellent.
Wie sehe ich da eigentlich aktuell aus?
Alter, wie der schlechteste Low-Level-Kack-Noob sehe ich aus, Mann.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Hits, Parry,
Constitution, Parry, Decks, Melee-Weapons.
Jawohl, geben wir ihm.
Ja, du hast Off-Tanks
für Nahkampf-Damage.
Du hast
ein paar Schleicher.
Du hast so ein paar Hybrid-Klassen.
Damage-Caster.
Main Crowd-Control-Character.
Also es ist in Dark, ohne Scheiß,
es ist für jeden irgendwas dabei.
Ich glaube, ich kenne niemand,
der in Dark nicht die richtige Klasse gefunden hat,
auf die er richtig Bock hat.
Und man muss sagen, die Klassen sind
doch schon recht variabel,
was so die
ja, das
das Niveau angeht,
auf dem man die spielen kann.
Aber man muss sagen,
es ist relativ rewarding
in dem Fall, dass
sagen wir mal, in der Regel,
nicht immer, aber in der Regel
sind die
Klassen, die schwieriger zu
spielen sind, kann man auch mehr
rausholen, ja.
Ein Beispiel. Hyla ist einer der schwierigsten
zu spielenden Klassen im ganzen Game.
Es gibt eine Klasse, die ist,
Hyla und heißt Hyla,
da ist dir nichts eingefallen.
Also Hyla ist eines der
mit Abstand schwierigsten Klassen.
Du kannst sie sogar
Triple-Spec machen, also dass du
alle drei Skills hier
und dann kannst du alles.
Du kannst heilen,
du kannst buffen, du kannst Crowd-Controllen,
du kannst alles
irgendwie, außer Damage machen, ja.
Und das ist unglaublich schwer gut
zu spielen.
Aber wenn du einen guten Hyla in der Gruppe hast,
macht es enorm viel aus.
Genauso in Albion,
wenn du gute
Sorg dabei hast oder gute Bade in
Hipp. Und
es gibt so ein paar No-Prain
Klassen, sowas wie Skalda zum Beispiel,
was ich spiele, das ist nicht sonderlich schwierig.
Aber
ich bin auch Boomer, ey Leute,
nur Boomer spielen dieses Spiel, wer soll
sonst spielen? Mein
Brain macht nicht mehr mit, wobei in Alp spiele ich Sorg.
Sorg ist auch echt nicht ohne
Zeit zu spielen.
Wenn ich Bock auf Caster habe,
spiele ich Alp, wenn ich Bock auf
Solo-Nahkampf-Kram habe,
spiele ich mit.
Ja. Also,
Dauercard, lasst mich mal zählen.
Wollen wir mal gucken?
Okay, lasst mal überlegen, lasst mal überlegen.
Gucken, ob ich
die Klassen zusammenkriege von den
unterschiedlichen Realms.
So, in Albion,
in Albion hast du
...
Ich muss abgucken.
Okay, ich guck mal, was ich alles, ich muss
abgucken, aber ich muss mal gucken, wie weit ich
die Klassen zusammenkriege. Ich meine,
ich habe das Spiel seit 20 Jahren gespielt, ich kenne
alle Klassen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich aus dem Kopf mir allein falle.
Also, in Alb hast du
Paladin,
Cleric,
Ordi,
Kabba, Armsman,
äh,
Infi-Scout,
Söldner, Minnesänger,
Necro,
Wizard.
Waren das alle?
Ich hab bestimmt was vergessen.
Und ich guck,
ich guck mal nach.
Warte mal.
Ich guck mal nach.
Ja, Classes, hier, da steht's doch.
Gibt's da nicht, gibt's da nicht
ein besseres, besseres Wiki, so?
Ja, doch.
Ja, viel besser hier.
Wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt
AFK-Leveling, ja.
Alles auf den Mob.
Und wir gucken uns mal kurz die Klassen an.
Also, in Alb hast du Armsman.
Armsman ist Main-Tank.
In Albion.
Hat eine Besonderheit,
also nur für den Fall, der fällt, dass jemand Bock hat, ne?
Ich erklär euch mal ein bisschen so
die Klassen, die es in dem Game gibt.
Muss mal ein bisschen weg hier aus dem Spawn raus.
Weil, die
Schizzler schizzelt mich um gerade.
Als erstes, wenn ihr da auch
anfangen, ihr müsst euch für eines von drei Reiche
entscheiden. Ihr könnt euch für Albion entscheiden,
Stuttgart oder Hipp.
Auf Eden ist es in der Tat recht easy.
Auf Eden könnt ihr alle drei Reiche
spielen. Auf Eden gibt's
die Beschränkung nicht, wie
auf Live, beziehungsweise damals
auf Live. Allerdings haben sie's
auf Eden auch clever gemacht, dass du nicht
permanent Winning Team Joiner machst,
kriegst du Loyalitätsbonus,
wenn du eine lange Zeit hier spielst.
Und sollst, und spielst du dann in einem anderen Reich,
sinkt der Loyalitätsbonus.
Das ist eigentlich ganz clever gemacht.
Aber nur solange, nur solange
du PvP
Kills machst. Also hab ich ganz gut gemacht.
Also ihr müsst, am Anfang entscheidet ihr euch
für eins von drei Reichen.
Es gibt Albion, das ist
mittelalterliches England.
Weil die Story von Darok ist,
König Arthus ist gestorben
und frag mich nicht nach der Story.
Ja, König Arthus ist gestorben und
dadurch
ist die Welt im Chaos.
Kein Schimmer. Übrigens die Story dahinter,
hinter der Story, warum
die das genommen haben ist, weil es
Copyright Free ist.
Die wollten, die wollten ein Game machen.
Die wollten ein MMO machen. PvP MMO.
Aber alles was sie
sich überlegt haben,
war halt, hatte halt
Copyright Probleme. Und da haben sie gesagt,
sie greifen auf die König Arthus Sage zurück.
Weil die ist halt quasi,
wie heißt das,
Royalty Free oder sowas.
Deswegen haben sie Public Domain.
Nicht Royalty Free, ja das wäre was anderes.
Public Domain.
Eigentlich
eine ganz clevere Entscheidung von den
Entwicklern damals gewesen.
Das so zu machen. Aufschüssler.
Oh.
Zack.
Bevor ich es vergesse.
Genau, also als erstes müsst ihr euch entscheiden für eins von Reichen.
Albion ist so mittelalterliches England.
Midgard ist Skandinavien. Hibernia ist quasi so
keltisch-irisch.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Und
Reiche haben komplett
unterschiedliche Rassen
und komplett
unterschiedliche Klassen.
Es gibt nicht, wobei, eine Klasse
gibt es in allen Reichen, aber die spielt keiner.
Wobei, die gibt es auf Eden gar nicht. Vergiss es.
Es gibt nicht eine Klasse, die doppelt ist.
Alle drei Reiche haben ungefähr
gleich viel, aber unterschiedliche Rassen.
Du hast in jedem
Reich hast du quasi so die
so mehr oder weniger die gleichen
äh wie soll man sagen,
so die gleichen Typen
von unterschiedlichen Rassen. Bei Albion kannst du
Bretonne spielen, Avalonia, Saracene,
Highlander, Incono oder Halbogar.
Wenn man sich die Klassen, die Rassen
anguckt, kann man sich schon ungefähr denken, wer
für was gut ist. Halbogar
sind richtig gut für Nahkampfcharakter.
Highlander sind auch richtig gut für Nahkampfcharakter.
Äh, Saracene sind richtig gute,
richtig gute Caster, weil die viel
Geschicklichkeit haben. Sind auch gute Caster.
Allrounder und ähm
Incono für die
edgy Leute, ja. Und
so ähnlich ist das in den
anderen Reichen auch.
Es gibt immer Rassen, die sich besonders
anbieten, um bestimmte Klassen zu spielen. Ja zum Beispiel
Midgard. Midgard gibt es
Nordmänner, die sind so allround, die können alles ganz gut.
Du hast Zwerge, die
haben sehr viel Konstitution. Eigentlich sind
Zwerge für nichts die beste Klasse.
Aber dadurch, dass sie klein
sind, spielen gerne viele Heilerzwerge.
Weil du äh nicht so leicht gesehen wirst.
Eigentlich ziemlich, ziemlich
pfeifert. Ich hab früher auch
Zwergenheiler gespielt.
Dann hast du Trolle. Trolle sind mit
Abstand im ganzen Game die beste Nahkampfklasse.
100 Stärke.
Keine andere Klasse, nicht mal Halboga,
haben ansatzweise so viel Stärke, Stärke wie
Trolle. Dann hast du Kobolde.
Die sind super Caster, weil hohe Geschicklichkeit.
Valkin, keine Ahnung wer sowas spielt.
Frostalph sind ganz gut, ganz gut
für Heiler zum Beispiel.
Und in Hipp hast du ähnliche
Sachen. Kälte, Allroundrasse,
Elf, guter, guter Caster.
Vierbolg, hohe Stärke, gut
Charakter. Lorikin, hohe Decks,
guter Caster. Oder
eben Schleicher.
Und Silvan, ja
auch random Leute, die das spielen.
Braucht man eigentlich nicht.
Also man hat ungefähr schon,
sind zwar alles unterschiedliche Rassen,
aber man sieht schon, es ist schon
also man kann auch suboptimale
Klassen spielen. Man kann Trollcaster
spielen, aber kein der
Serious Dark spielt, spielt
Trollcaster. Du kannst Troll
Bonedancer oder Troll Schamanisch
spielen, aber dadurch, dass Troll
sauviel Stärke haben und Bonedancer und
Schaman keine Stärke brauchen und die
brauchen Decks und Troller haben den
niedrigsten Deckswert mit 35 von allen
Klassen, ist das total unsinnig.
Manche machen es trotzdem, ich weiß
nicht warum, aber
gibt auch Leute, die peitschen
sich selbst aus.
Finden das geil.
Also insofern muss man das nicht
hinterfragen. Soll jeder spielen, worauf er Bock hat.
Ich finde, man sollte schon ein bisschen
halbwegs passenden Choice
passende Sache dazu nehmen.
So, und wenn man sich für den Realm
entschieden hat, was man spielen will, dann
als nächstes sollte man sich eine
Klasse raussuchen, auf die man Bock hat.
Und das ist das, das ist wirklich eines der
finde ich der richtig, richtig nicen Sachen
von Dark. Es gibt wirklich
für jeden irgendwas
zu spielen.
Natürlich hast du so
grundsätzliche Typen wie
Main Tank oder
Main Healer und sowas in allen Reichen,
aber das sind unterschiedliche Klassen, die sich
auch komplett unterschiedlich spielen.
Mir fällt kein Game ein,
was so ist wie Dark, was
von der
Klassenverteilung. Und es
ist, man kann nicht
sagen, dass Dark balanced ist,
ganz im Gegenteil, aber
auf größerer Skala
ist es ganz gut balanced.
Und
auch auf kleinerer Skala,
also wenn du mit Achtergruppen spielst,
kannst
theoretisch jeder gegen jeden gewinnen.
Kommt ein bisschen auf das Setup an,
kommt natürlich auch sehr auf die Spiele an,
aber du kannst mit jeder Achtergruppe
gegen jede andere Achtergruppe gewinnen.
Wenn das Setup nicht dich total
benachteiligt.
Also mit einer reinen
Nahkampfgruppe zum Beispiel
hast du es gegen kaltende
Castergruppen oftmals dann doch
recht schwer. Zumindest auf niedrigem
RR. Auf höherem geht das ganz gut,
mehr Burst Damage und auch mehr RRs zur Verfügung,
aber ist nicht so, ist nicht so ohne.
Glaubt mir,
da weiß ich tatsächlich, wovon ich rede.
Ich habe das lange gespielt und wir haben
auch genug
auf Elite
Spacken gemacht früher, also insofern.
Was das angeht, kenn ich mich aus.
So, zumindest, wenn man sich mal
die Klassen anguckt, und wie gesagt,
die Klassen sind pro Reich alle komplett unterschiedlich.
Eine noch, ja.
Kommen wir uns das mal an.
Also, wenn ihr zum Beispiel Albion spielen wollt,
wenn ihr auf mittelalterliches England
steht,
und ihr
euch das anguckt, werdet ihr feststellen, es gibt sowas wie
Armsman. Armsman ist
Main Tank in Albion, hat
eine spezielle Fähigkeit.
Übrigens, ganz viele Klassen haben
spezielle Fähigkeiten, die einzigartig im Spiel
sind. Also,
da ist das Recycling auch gar nicht so
krass in Dark, dass man sagt, okay, man nimmt
immer das Gleiche und ordnet es dann einfach nur pro Reich
anders an. Es ist wirklich sehr, sehr
unique pro Reich, was man spielt.
So, zumindest Armsman,
ist der Main Tank, also
zwei der Main Tanks in Albion,
hat eine Sache,
die sonst keiner hat, kann Polearms tragen.
Also,
was heißt denn Polearm
auf Deutsch? So helle Bade, oder
sowas, oder? Was heißt
Polearm auf Deutsch?
Stangenwaffe!
Sagt das irgendjemand?
Sagt ernsthaft jemand Stangenwaffe?
Polearms.
Polearms sind eine richtig gute Waffe,
weil die langsam sind
und übelst Damage machen.
Also, Armsman tankt
extrem gut, dank Plattenrüstung
und macht auch nahkampfmäßig
enormen Damage.
Als nächstes hast du Kabba.
Kabba ist für Damagecaster,
die einen Pet haben wollen.
Da hast du permanent einen Pet dabei,
was du rumkommandieren kannst und neu
beschwören kannst.
Und machst auch ziemlich gut Damage.
Bist so ein bisschen Mischung aus
Supportcaster,
Interrupt mit dem Pet
und Damagecaster.
Kabba ist sehr beliebt in Alpgruppen.
Wird eigentlich immer mitgenommen.
Du kannst Kabba auch wunderbar spielen,
wenn du nicht so auf Elite
Achtergruppen Fight machen willst.
Kannst du Kabba auch wunderbar im Zerg spielen,
also mit ganz vielen Leuten auf
einem Haufen,
weil Kabba ist die Klasse,
die ein Albion AE dort hat.
Also,
Gift,
damit leachst du
RPs wie sonst kein zweiter.
Und Kabba ist auch ziemlich gut im
Solo-Monster-Killen, dank dem Pet.
So, nächste Klasse,
Cleric, Primary Healing Class,
trifft ganz gut.
Cleric ist der Main Heiler oder
Main Buffer in Albion.
Macht mir unglaublich Spaß zu spielen,
ich habe jahrelang Cleric gespielt.
Kann,
aber ein bisschen Offensive.
Also Clerics hat eine
Specklinie fürs Buffen,
also, dass man anderen Leuten mehr
Geschicklichkeit, Stärke, sonst was geben kann,
Resistenzen, hat die besten Heals
in Albion, Instant Heals
und kann
Gegner stunnen und ein bisschen
Damage machen. Also ist jetzt nicht so,
dass Cleric super krass Damage macht,
es gibt die wenigsten Clerics specken diese
Damage Linie,
aber ein bisschen Baseline Damage
kann man machen.
Wie findest du die Ausschreibung der
Stelle?
Mal gucken.
Gucken wir gleich.
Ich laber grad mal mein Kram hier fertig,
dass ich nicht wieder vergesse,
da gucken wir uns das gleich an.
Ist die Quest jetzt eigentlich fertig?
Yagre müssen wir killen,
Relic, Relic, Imp.
Imps müssen wir noch killen.
Hier oben ist noch was, was wir bashen müssen.
Friends.
Ist der andere eigentlich wieder da?
Hä?
Danik wieder am Start?
Ja.
Okay.
Ja. Was haben wir hier?
Heiler.
Müssen wir Heiler
killen?
Ist das WoW? Nein.
Sieht doch nicht wahnsinnsweise aus wie WoW.
Das ist Dark Age of Camelot.
Bestes PvP MMO ever.
Aua.
Alter Heiler, mach nicht so viel Damage.
Was ist mit dir los? Heiler, lass mich in Ruhe.
Finger weg.
Was ist das hier?
Der hat mich fast gebasht.
Ne, den müssen wir gar nicht killen.
Wir müssen...
Ich dachte, das ist ein Name, den ich killen muss.
Den müssen wir überhaupt nicht killen.
Habe ich jetzt
komplett umsonst gekillt.
GG Max.
Gut gemacht.
So, Cleric habe ich schon.
Dann gibt es Ordi oder Ordensbruder auf Deutsch.
Also Friar auf Englisch.
Ehrlich gesagt,
kann ich nicht sagen.
Kann man sich drüber streiten,
ob es eine gute Klasse ist oder nicht.
Ist Hybrid Heiler Nahkampfklasse.
Eigentlich auf Eden ganz gut.
Eigentlich,
eigentlich auf Eden ganz gut.
Solo ziemlich gut, aber leider kein Speed.
Gibt aber viele, die mögen Ordi.
Ich kann dazu nicht so viel sagen.
Habe ich nie groß gespielt.
Eine der wenigen Klassen, wo ich nie gelevelt habe.
Und ich weiß auch nicht,
wie gut die Changes auf
Eden jetzt wirklich sind für Ordis
in der Gruppe.
Aber spielen viele gerne.
Ordi hat auf jeden Fall gute RRs für Zerg-Fights.
Infi
gehe ich jetzt drüber. Schleicherklassen
interessieren mich nicht.
Tick auch.
Juckt mich auch nicht so sehr.
Mauler gibt es auf Eden nicht.
Mercenary.
Eden ist
ein Dark-Free-Shard.
Wie viel brauche ich eigentlich
von dem hier?
Wo habe ich von den Viechern denn hier?
Boah, 20 auch.
Nice.
Oder auch
nicht nice.
Aber wir sind noch ein bisschen beschäftigt hier.
Kann ja ein bisschen weitererzählen.
Ach ja, und immer wieder umdrehen zum Gegner,
bevor er seinen zweiten Melee-Angriff macht,
dass man die Chance hat zu parieren.
Und nicht strafen im Nahkampf,
weil dann misst man.
Einfacher.
Muss ich mal kurz raggen.
Oh, die sind aggressive, die bashen mich.
Ja, man sieht halt da auch, guckt euch das mal an.
Man sieht halt da auch schon an,
dass es ein bisschen älteres Game ist.
Guckt mal, der Zonen-Übergang.
Seht ihr das?
Hier haben die Leute halt nicht aufgepasst.
Der Zonen-Übergang ist halt ein bisschen broken.
Genau.
Mercenary, richtig guter Off-Tank.
Nahkampf-Damage.
Also für alle, die Nahkämpfer
spielen wollen, die gut Damage machen.
Und ein paar kleinere Tricks.
Ist Mercenary in Albion richtig gut.
Minstrel oder Minnesänger
ist quasi die Speed-Klasse in Albion.
Wenn ihr in jeder Gruppe gefragt
sein wollt, aber auch Solo gut was reißen könnt.
Man könnte argumentieren,
Minnesänger ist die beste Solo-Klasse
im Spiel.
Ich würde sagen, Skalde ist die beste
Solo-Klasse im Spiel.
Aber man...
kann man sich drüber streiten.
Ich hab meinen Shortcut immer noch
nicht gefunden für den Snare.
Auf, komm her.
Ist überall gefragt.
Ist ne super Support-Klasse.
Macht Nahkampf-mäßig nicht viel Damage.
Kann aber super nerven und ist schwierig zu spielen.
Kann sich nen Patch haben.
Nekro ist quasi
die PvE-Klasse schlechthin in Alb.
Wer viel Gold farmen will,
macht sich in Nekro.
Nekro im PvP
kann man spielen.
Find ich persönlich nicht so geil.
Ordi farmt Sharnuma.
Die Change ist so gut auf Eden,
dass das...
dass das gerechtfertigt ist.
Also der Heal-Prog ist halt mega
in Kombination mit nem Cover-Pet und sowas.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob das genervt wurde mittlerweile.
Es gab ja die Möglichkeit,
dass du Cover-Pet-Heal-Progst
und es nicht gestorben ist.
Okay, jetzt muss ich da den Roten killen.
Paladin ist eines der beliebtesten
Klassen in Albion,
bei dem wir Paladin spielen.
Das ist der zweite Main-Tank
zu Leber Armsman.
Auch Plattenrüstung.
Macht nahkampfmäßig bei weitem
nicht so viel Schaden wie Armsman,
aber mit den Anpassungen auf Eden
ganz gut Nahkampf-Damage
und hat paar ganz nette Auren
für mehr Ausdauer
und bisschen mehr Rüstung und sowas.
Paladin ist wirklich nice.
Also für alle, die nen Support-Nahkämpfer
spielen wollen und gerade im
PvM begehrt sein wollen,
ist Paladin wirklich mega.
Paladin ist denke ich auch eine ganz gute
Startklasse,
weil viele spielen halt gerne Paladin.
An sich,
ich persönlich
bin kein großer Paladin-Fan.
Aber auf Eden
muss der deutlich besser sein als damals
auf Live, weil Eden viele Custom-Changes
für den Paladin hat.
So, next.
Pumbled.
Übrigens, das ist auch neu,
weil ich weiß gar nicht,
wo das herkommt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das was ist,
was Eden gebaut hat vom UI
oder, weil eigentlich kann ja Eden
am Kleinen nichts machen.
Also da bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Vielleicht ist das was von Eden,
vielleicht ist das auch was,
was sie live gepatcht haben.
Richtig coole Idee.
Also man sieht, dass die Entwickler
von Eden einfach besser sind als die
Broadsword-Leute.
Das ist ja die erste Addon-Klasse.
Das ist quasi
ein Tank mit Schild,
Kettenrüstung und einer Peitsche,
der
in Massen ziemlich
krass abgehen kann.
Es gab so eine Taktik mal früher,
nannte sich Reaver-Bombing.
Da hat man drei oder vier
Reaver in eine Gruppe gepackt
und hat dann
die passenden
drei Fähigkeiten zusammengedrückt
und konnte mit vier
Reavern quasi 80 Gegner instantwipen.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen,
ist Reaver jetzt für das RvR
nicht die allergeilste Klasse,
aber im Zerg kann man alles spielen.
PVP, äh PVM, also gegen Monster
ist Reaver fine.
Ich bin kein großer
Reaver-RvR-Fan.
Aber ist auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht
oder so.
Mag's nicht unbedingt so.
Scout, wer auf Bogenklassen steht,
kann das spielen.
Niemand möchte Scouts haben.
Sorcerer,
beste Klasse in Albion,
meiner Meinung nach.
Meine zwei Lieblingsklassen in Albion
eindeutig Sorc und Cleric.
Sorc, Cleric, Cover.
Wenn ihr mich fragt,
die beste Klasse in ganz Albion.
Sorc kann mega gut Damage machen.
Sorc kann
Pet, Charm
und Sorc kann
richtig gut CC'en.
Also eigentlich kann Sorc alles.
Sorc ist quasi
ein bisschen wie ein Heiler in Midgard.
Der kann alles außer Damage machen.
Sorc kann alles außer heilen.
Also wenn ihr mich fragt,
also aus meiner
Meinung nach ist Sorc der beste
Caster im ganzen Spiel.
Aber
da gehen ja die Meinungen in Darug auseinander.
Turk,
ja wer auf Pet-Caster steht,
ich persönlich würde Sorc immer
vorziehen. Und Wizard, wer den
Caster mit dem höchsten Damage-Output
spielen will, aber den wenigsten One-Button-
Spells, der kann Wizard spielen.
Wizard ist auch sehr beliebt, gerade bei Boomern
wie mir, die es nicht mehr hinkriegen
mehr als drei Tasten gleichzeitig
zu drücken. Oder mehr als eine Taste
muss man bei Wizard ja sagen. Nicht
hinbekommen mehr als eine Taste gleichzeitig
zu drücken. Die spielen Wizard.
Wizard kann jeder spielen.
Also mir fällt
niemand ein, der nicht in der Lage ist Wizard zu spielen.
Ich hoffe ich sterbe
nicht an dem Mob. Ah, Parried.
Nice. Hallo?
Schlagen, please?
Hallo?
The fuck?
Oh, der Mob haut aber gut rein. Evade, okay, jetzt haben
wir's, jetzt haben wir's. Easy win, easy win.
Eats.
Also Wizard
hat den höchsten Damage-Output von allen
Castern, ohne Debuffs und sowas jetzt.
Ich glaube, er hat
sogar, wenn man sich die Spells
anguckt, den höchsten Damage-Nuke im ganzen
Game. Ich glaube,
Wizard hat, glaube ich, 129er
DD oder sowas. Gibt keine andere
Klasse, die so viel hat. Und Bowls
und alles. Also wer einfach nur
vier, fünf Buttons möchte und
damit Ultra-Damage raushauen, der spielt
Wizard. Dafür kann Wizard sonst nix.
Wizard kann nur Damage machen.
So, das war die Klasse
in Albion. Also
mein Favorit eindeutig Sork. Wobei
ich sagen würde, Sork ist jetzt keine gute Einstiegsklasse
in Dark, weil Sork
kann halt alles irgendwie.
Außer heilen.
Also ich würde sagen, wer Albion anfangen will,
ne gute Einstiegsklasse in Alb ist eindeutig
Cleric. Brauchst du immer.
Du wirst immer ne Gruppe finden, wirst für alles gebraucht.
Du kannst Solo zwar nix gut auf die
Reihe bekommen, aber das musst du gar nicht unbedingt.
Weil du bist überall gefragt
und so lernst du halt Dark-Mechanics,
wenn du in Gruppe spielst.
Ja, also insofern.
Alter, könnt ihr mal was anderes außer rote Gegner
spawnen? Wart mal kurz, bis meine
DDs wieder da sind, dass ich dir mal ordentlich Damage machen
kann. So, also
ich würde jemand, der neu anfängt,
und sagt, ich möchte
jetzt mal Albion spielen,
hier würde ich tatsächlich,
wenn er Supporter mag,
ihr müsst Supporter mögen. Also ihr müsst es mögen,
Gruppen zu unterstützen mit Buffs
und Heals und Gegner
stunnen und bisschen minimal Damage
machen. Also wenn ihr jemand seid,
der Support nichts
abgewinnen kann, ist Cleric nix für euch.
Aber wenn ihr Support was abgewinnen könnt, ohne Mist,
Cleric ist eine der besten Einstiegsklassen im Game.
Und auf jeden Fall für Albion.
Ansonsten, wenn ihr gar nichts
mit Support anfangen könnt.
Man kann auch immer
sowas wie Parler oder Armsman spielen.
Da macht man auch nix mit verkehrt. Kaba
geht auch immer. Oder
Wizard, Ice Wizard
oder
Minit theoretisch auch. Wobei Minit tatsächlich
ein bisschen schwieriger ist.
Einzige Sachen, wo ich vielleicht nicht
so spielen würde zum Einstieg
ist, ja kann man auch spielen.
Zog würde ich nicht unbedingt als Einstieg
empfehlen. Scout auch nicht.
Reaver auch nicht.
Necro auch nicht unbedingt.
Damit kommt man nicht weit.
Mörg vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt.
Mauler gibts auf ihn nicht.
Heretic kann ich nicht einschätzen. Infi
auch nicht. Ordi
ist auch so n Ding.
Weiß ich nicht, ob das ne gute Einstiegsklasse ist.
Schwer ist sie glaub ich nicht.
Ich kanns schlecht einschätzen.
Aber Rest alles fein in Alb.
So, gucken wir uns mal die Midgard Klassen an.
Oh guck mal, Orangenschnell Gegner.
Nice du.
Falls irgendjemand von euch am Start ist,
der auch Darug spielt.
Ich weiß, viele sind wahrscheinlich am Start hier
von meinem normalen Stream.
Aber vielleicht hat ja auch der eine oder andere den Stream hier gefunden.
Der selbst Darug spielt.
Was spielt ihr?
Also ich spiel
Zog auf Alb und Skalde auf Mid.
Eventuell mach ich mir
noch wieder ein Chammy
auf Mid und noch ein Clary auf Alb.
Dass ich jeweils auch gute
Kruppchars hab.
Vielleicht diesmal.
Hab ich auch lange gespielt.
So.
Alter, die Viecher machen gut
Damage, Mann.
Ich muss gucken, dass ich rechtzeitig
abhauen kann, wenn ich zu viel Schaden krieg.
Pariert, jawoll.
Easy.
Easy Win.
So, dann gucken wir uns mal
die Midklassen an. Falls irgendjemand
auf nordische Wikinger
steht und auf Schnee und Eis
und auf
Odin, Thor und sonst was. Der ist in Midgard
richtig. Der kann
zum Beispiel Berserker spielen.
Wahrscheinlich
der Tank, der
oder was heißt Tank? Der, der, der
Off Tank, Melee
Damage Dealer, der den größten
Burst Damage im ganzen Game verursachen kann.
Du kannst dich in
einen Bär verwandeln. Alle
keine Ahnung, wie oft.
Und dann ist
jeder Angriff ein Critical Hit.
Und manche
besonders High IQ Bersis
switchen dann von
Dual Wield auf
zweihändiger Waffe, um
fette Krits reinzuhauen.
Ansonsten ist Bersi
relativ Straight Forward
zum Gegner hin.
Draufschlagen, bis er tot ist.
Kann man nicht allzu viel verkehrt machen.
So, als nächstes
Bone Dancer. Bone Dancer ist
so ein Ding. Bone Dancer finde ich
ist eine super Einstiegsklasse. Die ist nicht schwer
zu spielen. Jeder kann Bone Dancer spielen.
Aber Bone Dancer hat durch
die zusätzlichen Pets
eine gewisse Tiefe. Also ich finde Bone Dancer
ist eine super Einstiegsklasse, weil
du kannst die One Tap,
Live Tap spielen, ohne dir Gedanken machen zu müssen.
Und killst damit
fast alles. Außer Leute, die
eine passende Klasse haben und ganz gut spielen.
Du kannst Solo
PvM machen.
Und
wenn du dich ein bisschen mit der Klasse beschäftigst,
kannst du auch noch deutlich mehr.
Gerade wenn du
gelernt hast, wie du dich positionieren musst.
Was du mal Gegner
wegrouten kannst, wo du deine Pets
draufschickst und so. Also ich glaube
BD dürfte aus dem Grund
eines der besten Einstiegsklassen sein, wenn man
auf Caster steht. Weil
BD ist easy zu lernen
und, sagen wir mal so, medium
schwer zu mastern. Aber
bringt auch
was. Ist auch im großen
RVR gut, wenn du mit mehreren
Leuten spielst. TWF und sowas. Also
BD ist eine super Einstiegsklasse in Midgard, finde ich.
Kannst alles Solo machen.
Kannst Group spielen. Kannst RVR
spielen. Alle Sachen. Also BD ist
immer gut.
Heiler
dürfte mit
die beste Support Klasse im ganzen Spiel
sein. Kann alles, außer Damage machen.
Würde ich als Einstieg
nicht empfehlen. Ist zu schwierig.
Selbst wenn ihr
gerne Supporter spielt.
Weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht. Falls
wir ein paar Darkerfahrene haben. Aber
Heiler als Einstieg ist echt hart.
Du musst
genau wissen, was du machst. Und du musst
was machen.
Wenn's deine Nahkampf-Damage-Dealer
verkacken, verkacken's die Damage-Dealer. Stirbt keiner
davon. Wenn du's als Heiler verkackst,
egal in welchem
Sektor, bist
du eigentlich im Arsch. Wenn du nicht
richtig heilst, ist die Gruppe tot.
Wenn du nicht Buffs verteilst, wie's sein muss,
und Nahkampf-Damage
und so, dann killt die Gruppe langsamer, wie's sein muss.
Und wenn du nicht richtig CC'st,
wird die Gruppe überrannt.
Heiler ist echt schwer gut zu spielen.
Wenn ihr
Heiler spielen wollt, dann auf jeden Fall
Augheiler.
Augheiler ist deutlich einfacher als
Puck- oder Treespec-Heiler.
Augheiler müsst ihr im Endeffekt nur heilen
und ab und zu mal ein
Nahkampf-
Speed-Buff machen.
Ich glaub, wir haben's, oder?
Ich glaube, wir haben die Quest fertig.
Jetzt müssen wir nur noch Yagre
killen. Wobei,
der ist angeblich hier.
Ich hab den hier nicht gesehen.
Oder hab ich was?
Angeblich ist hier Yagre.
Oh, Moment, hier ist er doch.
Lull.
Okay, Quest fertig.
Moin, Fips.
Quest.
Nice. Kann man hier eigentlich porten?
Nein.
Wir laufen zurück.
So, komm ich ungefähr hier bei der Festung
raus? Ich hoffe es.
Also, wie gesagt, Heiler, super Support-Klasse.
Wenn ihr Augheiler spielt, ist er auch eine ganz brauchbare
Einstiegsklasse.
Aber Treespec und Puck-Heiler ist zu schwer als Einsteiger.
Hunter, Bogi, keiner.
Mauler, juck mich.
Runemaster ist quasi so der Main,
ja, der
Main-Range-DPS-Caster
in Midgard.
Ist, finde ich,
nicht so geil.
Hat nicht
so viele Spells.
Kann nicht so viel machen.
Ist im Zerg ganz gut mit
AE-Sperren und sowas.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie
aktuell so das 8er, ups,
das 8er-Meta aussieht, was
Runemaster angeht. Ich würde aber
fast vermuten, auch da eher nicht.
Dafür ist einfach zu spielen.
Aber Midgard ist nicht wirklich
für die krassen Caster bekannt.
So, dann gibt es Savage.
Auf Deutsch heißt das Wilder.
Eigentlich ganz gut übersetzt.
Ist quasi wie
ein Bersi. Nur, dass du nicht
Äxte verwendest, sondern Clown,
die mehrfach treffen können.
Savage hat
theoretisch sogar noch ein höheres
Nahkampf-Burst-Potential als Bersi.
Aber,
ja, ist schwierig
reliable dann diesen super
krassen Damage zu machen.
Nimmt sich nicht viel. Kann man beides spielen. Bersi,
Savage, beides gut.
Nimmt sich echt nicht viel.
Ist ziemlich ähnlich.
Wobei Savage komplizierter ist
durch die ganzen Self-Buffs, die du noch hast.
Ich finde, Savage ist keine gute
Einstiegsklasse. Wenn einer wirklich
Melee-DPS spielen will, dann
soll er lieber Bersi spielen.
Savage ist zu kompliziert für
Einsteiger, erstmal, finde ich.
Mein Gen tut alles.
So, 24, zack, bumm.
Easy.
Fat Axe, man.
Was macht eigentlich
Danik? Ah, da sitzt noch ein Titranki rum.
25.
Nice. Okay.
Ich würde sagen...
Was machen wir denn jetzt? Wir sind 25.
Waren wir gleich weiter. So, erstmal
trainieren.
Habe ich jetzt genug Geld, um mir ein paar... Ja.
Ich habe genug Geld, um mir Tränke
kaufen zu können. 50.
50.
Necklace...
Brauchen wir eh nicht.
Ja, brauchen wir, brauchen wir nicht, aber...
Ah, Two-Handed-Axt.
Wie sieht die Stats aus?
Cons...
Stär...
Hätte ich doch das lieber behalten sollen?
Stärke?
Moment, ich brauche... Max
Stärke, Alter, alles andere. Sagt doch mal richtig, man.
Quickness
ist okay. Habt ihr irgendein Item, was
Stärke gibt, vielleicht?
Constitution...
Quickness...
Oh, nö.
Ja, wenn ich jetzt wüsste,
wo der Quartermaster ist, dann könnte ich mir einfach
eine neue Rüstung kaufen.
Weil ich brauche eine neue Rüstung.
Wo eiert der
Quartermaster rum?
Können wir löschen. So.
Alles klar.
Gucken, ob ich jetzt zu einem der
Quartermaster hier gehen kann.
In Windsor.
Alles klar. Das ist
richtig nice, ja.
Und falls du früher gespielt hast und
dich fragst, was da abgeht.
Es ist am Samstag
ist Season 2
auf Eden gestartet.
Eden ist ein Dark Freeshard.
Das heißt, falls du früher gespielt hast, mal wieder Bock hast,
ist jetzt genau die richtige...
Wann gibt es denn eigentlich den neuen
Speed?
Battlesong...
Speed! Jawoll!
Und ja, Leute, bevor jetzt irgendwelche Darkcanner
zukucken, ich weiß, das Schwert eigentlich...
Das Hammer eigentlich
besser ist, aber ich spiel lieber Schwert.
Wir gehen jetzt mal ganz kurz ins BG
gucken, weil ich möchte
1L4 machen.
1L4.
Da kann ich Longwind 2 kaufen
und mit Longwind 2 sollte ich nahezu
unendlich sprinten können.
Vorher porten wir
nochmal in die Housing und kaufen uns
endlich einen Endu-Trank.
So. Um die Sache hier nochmal
abzuschließen für Midgard.
Schamane!
Also, wenn ihr Bock auf Support habt,
Support, der auch ein bisschen was machen kann
und
leicht bis semi
leicht zu spielen ist,
dann ist Schamane wirklich gut.
Schamane ist die Main-Buff-Klasse in Mid.
Wird immer gebraucht.
Jede Gruppe braucht einen Shami.
Und du kannst als Shami
auch ein bisschen offensiv
was machen. Ich finde, Schamane ist
eigentlich eines... Also, es ist eine Klasse,
die kann man super simpel spielen, aber ich finde, Schamane ist tatsächlich
eines der coolsten Klassen, die es gibt.
Weil das
eine seltene Kombination ist
aus...
Ich will nicht gerade sagen Damage,
weil das ist jetzt nicht mit einem
vollen Caster zu vergleichen,
aber Schamane kann ganz gut
nerven, Schaden machen und
interupten, plus
sehr gut buffen und ein bisschen
heilen. Also, Schamane
ist wirklich eine interessante Klasse. Die kann man
kann man, sagen wir mal so, sehr
eigenspielen, ja. Und
die ist nicht super schwer zu spielen, weil es gibt
nicht so viele Spells und die meisten sind permanent.
Drückst da halt einmal die Buffs drauf.
Aber du kannst ein bisschen was machen. Du hast
einen Bolt mit großer Reichweite für Damage.
Hast einen halbwegs brauchbaren
DD, wobei so hoch
skillt keiner Cave.
Hast AE-Root, AE-Seuche. Also
Schamane ist eine wirklich coole Einstiegsklasse.
Also, in Midgard eine der coolsten
Einstiegsklassen, würde ich sagen.
Neva
vielleicht BD und Orc-Heiler.
Also, kann man
auf jeden Fall empfehlen. Wenn man
Bock hat auf Support, der auch
offensiv ein bisschen was machen kann,
ist Schamane wirklich cool.
Skalde, Skalde ist eine super Klasse.
Für mich persönlich die beste Solo-Klasse
im ganzen Spiel. Deswegen
spiele ich auch in Alp Zork für Gruppen
Zeug und
auf Mid
Skalde für Zerg,
RVR und Solo rumgerenne.
Skalde ist top. Skalde ist
einfach auf der
einen Seite. Du hast ein paar
Nahkampfangriffe, du hast ein paar
Songs und Spells, die du drücken musst.
Bei Skalde kommt's
um das Solo, beziehungsweise
auch Solo im
Grenzgebiet navigieren zu können
und vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen schön
reinzuadden in die Fights, abzustauben und
wieder abzuhauen und was man halt als Skalde so macht.
Auch mal ein bisschen Dark Knowledge.
Man muss wissen, was
die gegnerischen Klassen können.
Man muss Fights gut
einschätzen können. Also, gerade wenn man Solo lebt,
wie der rauskommen will.
Ja, wenn du zum Beispiel jetzt auf irgendeinen Schleicher-Fight addest,
da musst du gut einschätzen können,
wen greifst du jetzt zuerst an, wer ist
am gefährlichsten, wo rennst du lieber weg,
engaged neu und so.
Also Skalde wirklich, wirklich gut
zu spielen Solo ist gar nicht so
einfach, finde ich. Aber
Skalde an sich
ist super einfach und sehr effektiv.
Also auch eine tolle Einstiegsklasse.
Spiritmaster,
der langweiligste Caster im ganzen Spiel.
Hat nen Pet und macht Zeug.
Donnerkrieger, die Noob-Klasse schlechthin
in dem Spiel. Jeder,
der damals Dark angefangen und Midgard
gespielt hat, jeder hat Donnerkrieger gespielt.
Weil Tor
und Blitze und Hammer.
Ne, der Fabian ist nicht dabei. Vielleicht am Wochenende, mal gucken,
ob er Bock hat.
Wer weiß auf jeden Fall Bescheid.
Ich persönlich mag Donnerkrieger
gar nicht so sehr als Einstiegsklasse.
Für Zerg-RVR ist Donnerkrieger
gut. Für alles andere,
ja, PVM tanken
kann er auch.
Ist ne brauchbare Einstiegsklasse.
Ich persönlich würde was anderes empfehlen.
Es ist aber,
Donnerkrieger ist die Dark-Noob-Klasse
schlechthin. Mir fällt jetzt nichts im
Vergleich von anderen Games ein,
was die Noobs, aber Donnerkrieger ist
die Klasse, die jeder Dark-Neuling,
der in Midgard anfängt, instinktiv anlegt.
Ja, genau.
Hammer und sowas. Du kannst dich auch sehr schnell
unbeliebt machen als Donnerkrieger.
So, dann hast du Valkyrie
als letztes oder als eins der letzten
Klassen noch. Valkyrie ist ne
Addon-Klasse. Eigentlich sehr
nice. Weiß ich nicht,
ob ich die als
als
Einstiegsklasse empfehlen würde.
Valkyrie ist
ne Mischung aus Support
und
Nahkampf
Support?
Kann man schwer beschreiben.
Du kannst Damage machen im
Nahkampf, den machst du aber weniger durch
rein Waffendamage, sondern mehr durch
Procs und zusätzliche
zusätzliche
Abilities.
Und du kannst ganz brauchbar heilen.
Die meisten. Und auch ein bisschen tanken.
Also Valkyrie ist
glaub ich kein allzu guter
Einstiegsklasse, aber auf jeden Fall nice, dass es gibt.
Warlock, weiß ich gar nicht, ob es sie
auf Eden überhaupt gibt.
Bin mir nicht sicher.
Ob das, was ich im Kopf habe,
jetzt Eden war
oder Phoenix. Ich glaub Eden.
Doch, doch, ich glaube es gibt Warlock.
Warlock kann ich nicht zusammenfassen. Ist ne
sehr weird, weird Klasse.
Warlocks können casten,
können heilen und
als Warlock hast du so komische Blasen überm Kopf,
wo du instant casten kannst. Ganz
weird. Ist aber auf jeden Fall nichts für Einsteiger.
Warrior.
Gut. Der Main-Tank schlechthin
in Midgard. Wenn jemand
was spielen will. Passt mal auf. Ich zeige
euch mal hier. Also guckt mal Leute.
Das ist Skilltree, Valkyrie.
Guckt euch das an. Kannst du
skillen. Und jetzt kommt Skilltree Warrior.
Fertig.
Ich mein, Warrior
ist glaub ich so ziemlich die einfachste Klasse zu
skillen schlechthin. 50
Schild, 50 Waffe,
Rest Parry. Manch einer,
der besonders auf Solo geht,
spekt vielleicht ein bisschen weniger Waffe, ein bisschen mehr Parry.
Das wars. Easy.
Also Warrior,
kannst du eigentlich nicht verskillen.
Und Warrior ist rein
vom Nahkampf-Damage,
die, also
von den internen Stats im
Game, die
stärkste Nahkampf-Klasse.
Du kriegst den meisten Leben
und du kriegst den meisten
Damage-Modifier als
Warrior.
Was aber die anderen wieder wettmachen. Also
ich würde nicht sagen, der beste
Tank im Spiel.
Ja. So.
Bevor wir jetzt weitermachen, muss ich mir überlegen,
geh ich jetzt mal,
was macht eigentlich hier, was macht denn Danek?
Ah, da ist 23 ins Hit.
Nice, nice.
Vielleicht spielen wir gleich wieder mit Danek ne Runde.
So.
Dann porten wir mal ins BG.
Ach Quatsch.
Ich kack Noob, Alter.
Ich bin in die Housing geportet, um mir Endo-Tränke
zu kaufen. Und was hab ich gemacht?
Mir keine Endo-Tränke gekauft, Mann.
High IQ.
Komm, scheiß drauf. Scheiß drauf.
Wurscht. Ich kauf mir keine Endo-Tränke.
Ich kauf mir ne ordentliche
Rüstung.
Slash. Slash-Hop ist am Start.
Nice.
Ja.
Hi.
So, ich brauch, was brauch ich denn? Ich brauch ne Rüstung.
Kostet
25 Bounty Points. Kann ich mir das überhaupt
leisten? Kann ich mir das leisten?
Wie viele Bounty... Alter, Moment.
Ey, wo... Bounty Points.
3er kann ich mir leisten. Okay.
Ähm.
Chest Piece.
Ich brauch alles, oder? Ah, die Ärmel gehen.
Ärmel gehen. Ähm.
Hose.
Dings. Kopf.
Dings.
Okay. Ready.
Haben wir ordentliche Rüstung am Start.
Voll gebufft. Jawoll.
Auf geht's.
So. Wir sind wieder im PvP-Gebiet.
Schauen wir mal, wie gut das läuft.
Vielleicht levelt Danik ja auch wieder ran.
Wenn's gut bei ihm ist, der Trunkie.
Läuft. Und...
Wir können dann wieder zusammenspielen.
Oh, ich kack nur. Ich hab vergessen,
die Quest anzunehmen.
Ach, guck mal. Da laden Dings Pumps. Bip.
Ist wieder am Start.
Den können wir wieder einladen.
Wenn er will. Wenn er will.
Let's go.
Kann ich noch trainen?
Warten wir mal, bis der da ist.
Hab ich irgendwelche Battlesongs...
So, wir sind alle 25.
Das passt gut. Fehlt doch eigentlich nur noch...
Danik.
Dann brauchen wir noch 2 Level. Dann geht's los.
So. Wir machen jetzt ein bisschen PvP noch.
Bis ich 1L4 bin.
1L4 kauf ich mir Longwind 2.
Und dann wird's weiter...
Okay. Dann...
Dann nicht.
So. Mal gucken, wie viel hier los ist.
Wie heißt denn dieses BG überhaupt?
Hat jemand aufgepasst?
Wo bin ich? In Braema.
Okay. Wer ist denn?
Braema. 15 Leute sind da drinnen.
Okay.
Gucken wir mal. Ne?
Gucken wir mal.
Erstmal Bäume bashen.
Baum Bash.
Ich könnte jetzt eigentlich, wenn der hier am Start ist,
mal den anderen Style verwenden,
der ein bisschen Endo spart.
Easy.
Ich brauch unbedingt meine Makro... Nicht meine Makro.
Meine Shortcut Software.
Dass ich...
Dass ich das mappen kann.
Wartet mal.
Ich leg das mal kurz dahin.
Da kann ich theoretisch wenigstens
hier auf 2 auslösen.
Mit...
Bisschen Hände verbiegen.
Der Bäumesound.
Hören sich bei euch nicht auch Bäume immer so an?
So machen Bäume. Eindeutig.
Also cringe, wenn
eure Bäume so nicht machen.
Aber ich hab euch ja vorhin die Story... Oh fuck.
Den greif ich nicht an.
Ich bin zu low.
Zu low leben.
Aber ich weiß was. Ey, der soll herkommen.
Wir kiten den. Wir kiten den.
Wir kiten den. Pass mal auf.
Wir kiten den.
Six Head. Ich hoffe der kommt.
Alter komm her.
Komm her. Komm her.
Komm her.
Der soll sich nicht hamen.
Jawoll. Jawoll. Geht rauf. Sehr gut.
Excellent.
Ich liebe es, wenn man die Leute
outplayen kann. Oh fuck.
Passt.
Den... Den...
Ja.
Weggenoobt.
Oh shit.
Ja heil mich. Vados. Perfekt. Excellent.
Ehrenmann Vados, Mann.
Siehste?
Und das sind so Dinger.
Also, das ist das,
was ich meinte, warum es schwierig ist
Skalde
Solo
gut zu spielen. Ich will nicht sagen,
dass ich der krasseste Solo-Skalde auf der Welt bin oder so.
Du musst einschätzen können,
was für Fights du nehmen kannst.
wie du die Gegner
auch ohne sie direkt
one on one nehmen zu können
outplayen kannst.
Und der hat sich drauf eingelassen.
Und hat es verkackt.
Oh guck mal.
Also mal zur Erklärung.
Man konnte es glaube ich nicht richtig nachvollziehen,
wenn man nicht
Dark spielt. Also.
Das ist hier ein Bone Dancer bei mir in der Gruppe.
Der wurde angegriffen
von einem Gegner.
Das war ein Schleicher, der kann sich tarmen.
Den hat man nicht gesehen.
Der ist quasi, während wir gegen die Bäume gekämpft haben,
ist der ran geschlichen an den hier
und hat den quasi backstepped.
Und hat ihn fast one-shotted.
Ich habe es ein bisschen zu spät gesehen,
weil ich den betäuben wollte.
Habe ich nicht hinbekommen.
Aber ich habe es geschafft, ihn zu betäuben.
Nachdem mein Caster ein Stelzer war.
Daher kommt übrigens das Wort Stelzer.
Falls sich irgendjemand fragt,
warum sie immer Stelzer gesagt haben früher.
Das kommt aus Dark.
Ja.
Zumindest, ich habe es geschafft, ihn zu betäuben.
Für 18 Sekunden.
Und dann war halt das Ding,
ich warte selbst nur noch 40% Leben
und der Gegner war Orange.
Das heißt, er hat ein höheres Level.
Den hätte ich im Leben nie
im Nahkampf überhaupt
killen können.
Deswegen
habe ich gewartet, bis mein Typ
vom Keep zurückkommt.
Ich wusste ja nicht, dass er nicht losläuft.
Und
die Schleicher können sich nicht tarnen,
wenn sie im Kampf waren.
Bis zu ein paar Sekunden danach.
So, das heißt,
ich bin von ihm weggelaufen,
weil der kann nur Nahkampf-Damage machen.
Wieso basht du Bäume?
Weil es eine Quest gibt, um Bäume zu bashen.
Der kann nur vernünftig Nahkampf-Damage machen.
Wobei das ein Hip-Schleicher war,
der kann auch ein bisschen casten.
Dementsprechend habe ich gewartet,
bis meine Betäubung ausläuft.
Dann habe ich den Typ angeguckt.
Der wollte sich tarnen, konnte aber noch nicht.
Dann habe ich ihn gesnared,
dass er nicht wegrennen kann.
Resettet seinen Stealth-Timer auch.
Ähm...
Ein Nachtschatten, genau, ein Nightshade.
Und...
Danach habe ich gesehen,
dass Leute von mir kommen.
Dann habe ich ihm einen Damage-Shout gegeben,
als er casten wollte.
Albs, Albs, Albs, Albs, Albs, Albs.
Oh, das ist eine Guild-Group, glaube ich.
Vorne ist der Saracene, vorne ist die Zorg.
Vorne ist die Zorg.
Oh, Mads, Mads, Jawoll!
Mads raus. Cleric, Cleric, Cleric.
Okay, ich bin auf dem Heiler drauf.
Perfekt.
Guck mal, das ist ein Bersi, der one-shotted den.
Das ist das, was ich meinte.
Burst-Damage von Bersis.
Oh, ich bin geslammed, shit.
Okay, dead.
Zu weit reingecharged,
aber da können wir nichts machen.
Schön von der Seite geadded haben sie uns.
Ich könnte releasen und da einfach schnell wieder hingehen.
Haben wir doch.
Wir gehen da schnell hin.
Da habe ich ein bisschen
overextended jetzt.
Da bin ich ein bisschen zu weit reingerushed.
Ich habe gedacht, die pushen hinterher.
Wobei, ich muss die Caster interrupten.
Da bleibt mir nichts anderes übrig.
Okay, die sterben. Ich gehe zurück.
Ja, und dann habe ich
den Nightshade, das er nicht casten konnte,
angeschautet, bis meine anderen da waren.
Und er war so gierig
und ist nicht weg und wollte sich tarnen.
Dementsprechend haben wir ihn gekillt.
Danik ist 24,
der kann gleich mitmachen.
Bashen, Alter, bashen, ja.
Wir gehen mal mit denen mit.
Wir zergen die jetzt einfach weg. Easy.
Meine Leute haben keinen Bock,
sich zu bewegen.
Auf Leute, moved!
Okay.
Haben keinen Bock. Ich laufe mit denen.
Da sind sie doch.
Let's go.
Es wäre sinnvoll, wenn wir mit den anderen mitlaufen würden.
Da hinten sind die Deserter.
Ah, gut.
Die sind etwas too slow.
Guck mal, wir haben ein
Einhänderschwert, ist das, ne?
Nehmen wir das trotzdem mal, weil eine Axt kann ich hier nicht nehmen.
Ich brauche unbedingt meine
Shortcuts wieder.
Ich habe die Songs auf den Maustasten jetzt.
Auf Zirkumflex
habe ich mein
Matz. Da bin ich mir noch nicht sicher, welchen
Button ich damit belegt habe.
Ich bräuchte eigentlich noch
den Shortcut für den Snare,
aber den habe ich gerade nicht gemappt.
Deswegen machen wir es mal so.
Den kriege ich auch noch so ausgelöst.
Oh, ich glaube,
da sind Albs irgendwo,
weil die, die hier oben sterben,
das ist immer auch wichtig, muss man mal drauf gucken,
die, die hier oben sterben, ist die Gruppe,
die gerade an uns vorbeigelaufen ist.
Die wurde gerade von den Albs weggezergt.
Wobei, weggezergt, weiß ich nicht. Es waren immer ähnliche Kills.
Aber sie sind auf jeden Fall Albs am Start.
Ah, wir haben eins L4, nice.
Oh, Ink, Ink.
Oh, viel zu viele, Mann. Viel zu viele.
Ist das ein Clary?
Oh, shit. Ah, meine Maus.
Fucking shit. Ah, warum kriege ich den nicht angeklickt?
Alter, Boomer.
Okay, sind
zu viele. Sind zu viele.
Kann man nichts machen.
Der Frasier,
der Frasier hat irgendwie gerade keinen Bock,
aber vielleicht ist er am Wochenende wieder dabei.
Pass auf, Danik
ist gleich herangeliefert. Kann er mit, mit
so.
Finish.
So, jetzt sollten wir alle zusammenlaufen.
Die haben keinen Bock. Alter, Leute.
Wollt ihr jetzt, wollt ihr wieder
mit der Gruppe in die ganzen Albs rennen,
oder was?
Wir sollten jetzt denen einfach mal hinterher.
Was sind Albs? Mit B, das sind
die Spieler aus Albion.
Wir können doch einfach questen.
Nee, egal.
Ja, Huni, auf.
Oh, die sind wieder alle so brain-aff, Kira.
Was ist da los? Let's go, Leute.
Let's go.
Wenn, wenn ich eines hasse in Dark,
ist es sinnloses rumstehen, weil irgendwelche Leute
afk sind.
Da dreh ich durch.
Richtig, NPCs, Dynamates.
Na, beim ersten Fight hat man gesehen, so schlecht sind die gar nicht.
Aber die Crew vorhin war eindeutig besser.
So, Bäume bashen
müssen wir nicht mehr.
Sag mal, was ist mit euch los?
Lauft halt geradeaus, Mann.
Ich bin kein
Dark-Streamer.
Ich mache normalerweise ganz anderes Zeug.
Aber ich bin alter Dark-Spieler.
Und
natürlich, oh, oh, hier war ein Albs,
hier war ein Albs am Start.
Also, ich spiele das
seit 2000, wann kam es in Europa raus?
2002?
East? East?
East, East, East, East, East, East.
Oh, da müssen wir, die müssen wir ass-jammen, Leute.
Die müssen wir richtig hart ass-jammen.
Richtig hart geass-jammt
werden jetzt. Gachi Bass, Leute.
Gachi Bass!
Alter, der ist frei. Warum ist der frei?
Der soll nicht frei sein. Der soll verrecken
jetzt.
Ah, okay. Der hat gefacet, der war
nicht blöd. Jetzt stehe ich 35
Minuten. Nice! Yeah!
35 Minuten, äh,
35 Sekunden rumstehen. Beste!
Weil ich nicht aufgepasst habe.
Jawoll! Pogu!
Okay.
Aber gab ganz gut RPs.
Ach, da ist noch einer. Nee.
Ach, Deserters. Okay.
D-Dessert.
Pipo Fett.
Aufmacht Damage, Jungs.
Damage.
Gibt das nochmal ganz gut. Ex, wie lange bin ich denn eigentlich schon on?
Alter, 4 Stunden
40! Seriously?
Hast du den Trailer von Eden gesehen mit ihrem neuen... Ja, hab ich.
Hab ich.
Ich bin da immer pessimistisch, was sowas angeht.
Ich kann ansatzweise
ahnen, was das für ein Aufwand ist.
Wenn man auch,
sagen wir mal so, moderne
Tools zur Game-Entwicklung
nicht unterschätzen darf.
Also es gibt auf der einen Seite deutlich erhöhte
Komplexität, auf der anderen Seite deutlich
bessere Tools.
Sodass ich sagen würde, unterm Strich
vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher
sogar noch Spiele zu machen.
Aber da gehört schon enorm viel dabei, ja.
Und, also,
ich bin da pessimistisch, weil sowas, ob
da was rauskommt. Ich bin skeptisch.
Es wäre mega,
wobei ich da halt auch wieder die nächste Frage,
die ich mir stelle ist, wie sieht es
Copyright-technisch aus?
Weil sobald da irgendwas...
Irgend...
Wo ist der Bade?
Wo ist der Bade? Weiß, da steht der Bade.
Steht, sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Leute, offer extended tanks killen.
Oder auch nicht.
Ey, der kämpft doch nicht!
Okay, okay, wir sind dead. Wir sind dead. Wir haben verloren.
Dead, können wir uns hinsetzen.
Ähm, wo bin ich grad stehen geblieben?
Ja, also
Unreal-Projekt, wie gesagt, ich bin da skeptisch.
Ich bin da skeptisch.
Ähm,
ob da was rauskommt.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, das sehe ich ganz anders.
Also,
es kann sein, dass es
Copyright-technisch okay ist, einen
Darok-Free-Shard anzubieten.
Weil
die ursprüngliche
Server-Software ja irgendwie mal
von Mystic selbst released
wurde oder sowas, unter irgendeiner Lizenz.
Aber, einen Darok-Client
zu programmieren,
der eventuell sogar
original Darok-Assets verwendet,
das wird nicht funktionieren.
Also, wenn sie vielleicht
keine originalen Darok-Assets
verwenden,
dann wäre es eventuell möglich.
Dann ist halt die Frage, inwieweit das noch wie Darok aussieht.
Ähm,
also ich bin,
ich bin echt skeptisch, was das an
Belangt, ganz ehrlich.
Aber ich lass, ich lass mich gerne eines
Besseren belehren.
Weil ich fände es mega.
Und, also wenn es,
wenn es einen modernen, moderneren
Darok-Client geben würde, als den hier.
Zumal Camelot Unchained
ja mittlerweile,
ich will nicht sagen, zum Scam geworden
ist, weil Scam impliziert, er hatte
von Anfang an vor, die Leute zu verarschen.
Das glaube ich nicht. Aber, ähm,
es wird halt nichts mehr.
Ähm, ist EA
nicht raus? Haben die das nicht verkauft an
Broadsword?
Und Broadsword, das hat mit EA nichts mehr zu tun.
Haben die die Rechte nicht verkauft?
Aber Broadsword könnte sich genauso gut
darüber aufregen.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, selbst wenn sie theoretisch
Recht bekommen würden,
ob sie sich auf ein Rechtstreit
einlassen wollen, ist halt
wieder die Frage, ja.
Ich persönlich würde es hoffen,
und ganz ehrlich, seriously, wisst, wisst
ihr was, wisst ihr was ich machen würde?
Wenn ich, äh, ein paar Millionen hätte,
ich
würde versuchen, die Rechte zu bekommen
und ein offizielles Dark zu machen.
Also, ich habe
aber keine paar Millionen dafür übrig.
Und wenn der Hersteller,
wenn Broadsword schlau wäre,
und das Potential
darin erkennen würde,
dann
würden sie das vielleicht fördern
und nicht direkt unterbinden, aber
Broadsword traue ich halt echt gar nichts zu.
Warum
killen wir eigentlich wieder Bäume?
Wir sind fertig mit Bäumen.
Ich seh nix.
Übrigens, diese Fürze hier,
das ist AE Zeug vom Shami.
Falls sich vorhin jemand gefragt hat,
so, was machen Shamis eigentlich?
Die machen so
AE Fürze.
Die Baum-Sounds
macht mich immer noch fertig.
Ja, für alle, die vorher nicht dabei waren,
ich erzähle euch nochmal kurz die Story. Wisst ihr, woher die Dark-Sounds kommen?
Die haben
damals festgestellt, während der Entwicklung
des Spiels, dass sie keine guten
Sounddesigner sind
und haben.
Und deswegen haben die sich
das Äquivalent von Stock-Footage
gekauft im Jahr 2001,
2000.
Die haben sich eine Stock-Audio-CD gekauft
damals. Und
da sind alle möglichen Sounds drauf gewesen, so
Natursounds, oh fuck.
Jaja, ah shit,
jetzt lassen sie, jetzt haben sie mich abgestellt.
Direkt. Oh, ich muss weg,
ich muss weg, ich muss ganz schnell weg.
Okay. Übrigens, Turks sind
übelst OP in BGs.
Wegen, unter anderem,
dem Kram da.
Das ist nice. Übrigens, Pets,
die auf einen geschickt werden, sollte man nicht killen,
dann ist man nicht CC-bar.
Alter!
Die Lapps, man, hier, was da los?
Ja, Turk ist
richtig krass at low level.
Die Mids könnten sich aber auch mal
zusammenreißen und zusammenlaufen, nicht hier komplett
planlos rumstelzen.
Aber das macht nichts, wir haben gute XP gemacht.
Wir haben
Train,
wir können Longwind 2 erstmal
kaufen, Temporea, das wird nachher
wieder gelöscht. Train,
bisschen Battlesongs, neuer DD.
Erster Resi-Song!
Ja, das könnte man.
Oh ne, noch nicht, noch nicht.
Noch nicht.
Dafür Schwertspeck.
Neuer DD.
Ja, und bisschen mehr Level könnten wir
auch haben. Ja, so.
Alles gut. Oh, Buffs brauch ich.
Buffs brauch ich, cool.
Ja, so sieht das auch in DAG aus. Manchmal
ist man auch...
Wie sagt unser
Brain mit immer? An manchen
Tagen ist man der Baum, an manchen Tagen
ist man der Hund.
Oder in manchen Fights
ist man der Baum, in manchen ist man der Hund.
Also, Strength...
Wir haben jemand
in der Gruppe, ich hab ja den Chat, ich hab ja den Chat
unkenntlich gemacht. Wir haben jemand in der Gruppe, der
komplett neu ist und meint so, sorry Leute,
sorry falls ich nix
auf die Reihe kriege. Ich muss dem grad mal gut
zureden. Also ihr seht, es gibt auch
Neulinge.
Und er spielt Shami!
Als hätte er mal ein Stream geguckt.
Shami ist ne super Einstiegsklasse
in dem Game.
Und man kann übrigens mittlerweile die Lampe anmachen.
Das haben die in Eden gepatcht, dass man nur noch selbst
die Lampe sieht.
Ich muss dem erstmal gut zureden, dass es ja nur
BG ist und es eigentlich hier überhaupt auf nichts
ankommt. So, hätten wir noch ein paar
Level mehr? Und...
hätten wir vielleicht noch einen achten
und einen zweiten Heiler? Wäre schon enorm
prog. Ich weiß gar nicht,
wen ich alles... Also ich muss auf jeden Fall
die Hexe abstellen.
So, und danach
eigentlich muss ich direkt den Turk interrupten,
dass der keine Pets aufstellt, weil die total
prog im BG sind. Das Problem ist
nur, wenn ich nicht auf den Clary gehe und der Clary
von uns nicht abgestellt wird, geht niemand auf den
Clary. Also insofern...
Tja...
Schauen wir mal, wie die
Fights so laufen. Mit
Tanktrains. Lass mich raten, du hast
zu Zeiten gespielt, wo die Leute Triple Savage
gespielt haben.
Das war so ziemlich, aus heutiger Sicht,
glaube ich, mit das nervigste
Meta, was ich je in Dark gesehen hab.
Triple Savage-Meta.
Triple Savage-Meta
ist echt Painz-Champ.
Wir werden eh gleich wieder gebasht
von der Seite.
Wobei, wir sehen
die Alps ja auf der Map. Ich glaub, das waren die, oder?
Also Triple Savage...
Übrigens, aus heutiger Sicht hätte
du wahrscheinlich mit Triple Savage gar nicht mehr so
viel Erfolg.
Heute wissen die Leute, wie man gescheit kitet und gescheit
spielt. Aber
damals war Triple Savage krass.
Wobei ich ja persönlich sagen muss, ich hätte damals schon
Double Savage-Krieger
oder sowas gespielt, aber
Triple Savage war
nervig auf jeden Fall.
Trotzdem haben wir damals
gegen die meisten Triple Savage Gruppen gewonnen.
Außer Ultra HRR.
Das war schon... Alps on Top? Ok.
Ok. Wo? Wo? Wo? Wo? Wo? Wo? Wo? Wo?
Ich seh keine Alps. Wo sind Laps? Wo sind sie?
Wo sind die Laps?
Geht nix.
Oh, hab ich die Deserter-Quest vergessen anzunehmen?
Kann das sein?
Ne. Hab ich nicht. Hab ich nicht vergessen.
Oh shit, ey...
Ey, ey, ey, ey... Die Assjam ja so krass.
Den zu
hitten ist dumm. Wir müssen...
Warum geht denn der auf mich?
Jetzt kommen die Alps noch dabei!
Lull!
Wir sollten nicht den
hitten, ne? Ich sag's nur mal so.
Ja, Tank Troop war...
Generell gab's ne Zeit lang, da war's
übelst meta, ähm, Tanks zu
spielen.
Was aber auch mit daran lag...
Gibt's aber echt auf den Sack.
Was? Wie soll
man Heiler hier protecten? Wir haben doch nix dagegen,
ne? Heiler muss
kreiten und wir müssen die richtigen Targets picken.
Und wer schneller fällt, hat gewonnen.
Das ist in BG nicht so
easy, wie die Leute im Chat da grad schreiben.
Also hier im Ingame-Chat.
Wir brauchen...
Wir brauchen unseren Brain.
Wir brauchen unseren Brain, ähm...
Vendo Caverns macht er.
Sekunde, Sekunde. Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ähm...
Eden, Vicky...
Da mach ich's mit, wenn der Vendo macht.
Eden...
Äh, Vicky...
Midgard...
Vendo...
Immer noch am Kreiten, ja.
Immer noch Kreise, Kreise Kreint.
Ähm, by the way, wir sollen einfach mal die...
Oh, äh, äh, äh, äh, Deserters, Deserters...
Oh, wir haben nicht... Wir haben nicht mal alle Deserters
gekillt. Wie haben wir das denn denn geschafft, äh?
Das ist nett.
So, wir sollten jetzt einfach mal die Quests
abschließen und dann raus hier.
Weil lange gucke ich mir das nicht noch mit an.
Wir sollten jetzt einfach noch zwei, drei
Mobs killen und dann ist gut.
Oder, was ich ja viel
sinnvoller finden würde, wir laufen
ein bisschen außenrum und nicht unbedingt
direkt den Alps und den Hips in die Ärmel.
Alter.
Wie viele von diesen Kackbäumen
wollen wir denn noch killen, Mann?
Wir haben schon 300 Bäume geschnetzelt.
Ich brauch die Bäume nicht mehr.
Kann man eigentlich noch Turkpads
amnesien, dass die dann nix mehr machen?
Weiß ich, ob sie das irgendwie...
Das ging mal nicht. Oder war's
amnesien oder war's Confusion? Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Man konnte Turkpads easy...
easy killen.
Ink Hips? Na geil. Wo?
Okay, der muss sterben.
Wo ist der Heiler frei? Wo ist der Heiler frei? Da hinten.
Fuck, da muss ich hin. Da muss ich hin.
Okay, keine Chance.
Alter, ich fass das nicht, Mann.
Der Typ soll sich mal verpissen, Alter.
Sag mal, ist der Heiler AFK oder was?
Der steht ja einfach nur auf dem Kno...
Der steht ja einfach nur...
Wo ist denn mein Team? Leute?
Wo ist mein Team?
Team? Team?
Geist.
Okay.
Wo ist denn mein Team? Hier, haben wir gewonnen?
Haben wir die gebasht?
Ich glaube, wir haben gewonnen, Leute.
Wir haben das geschafft.
Ja.
Weil ich...
Weil ich Pfeiffer den Heiler interrupted habe, würde ich sagen, ja?
Sonst wäre das nix geworden.
Das ist das, was ich meine.
Man braucht ein bisschen Übersicht und ein bisschen...
Man muss die Gegnerklassen kennen.
Ja.
Das hätte man doch deutlich besser machen können.
Ich hätte mir meine Schauts besser einteilen müssen.
Weil ich kann einen Heiler, der einen...
Oh, come on.
Die Nächsten.
Ich gehe jetzt raus aus dem BG.
Ich habe keinen Bock mehr.
Ist ja abfuck.
Es ist hyper abfuck.
Übrigens, wer sich wundert, warum ich nichts mache.
Ich kann nichts machen.
Ich bin blau hier unten.
Okay, dead.
Okay.
Ich würde sagen, es reicht jetzt mit Battleground.
Wir machen jetzt Frontier-Quests weiter.
Das sind mir ein bisschen zu viele Hips.
Und ein bisschen zu planlose Mids.
Aber gut.
Ich meine, man muss es fairnesshalber sagen.
Ich meine, die sind wieder mitten.
Wir waren noch mitten im Fight.
Leute, tot.
Und wir machen Frontier-Quests.
Einen Run mache ich noch.
Einen Run mache ich hier noch.
Ich meine, wir können einfach die Quests machen.
Wir laufen hier außen rum, machen schnell die Quests und hauen ab.
Aber nope.
Alter, Leute, hört doch mal auf zu fighten.
Ich brauche Buffs.
Also mein Ziel ist heute eigentlich Level 40.
Oder zumindest in die Richtung.
Dazu kann ich mich nicht eigentlich mit BG sterben aufhalten.
Wir leveln zwar, aber wir könnten durchaus...
Was macht denn da Nick?
Wir könnten durchaus...
Wenndo...
Ach, Wenndo ist da.
Wir könnten durchaus schneller sein.
Also hätte ich mir einfach nur hier 1L4 geholt.
Und hätte dann Frontier-Quests durchgecrindet, wären wir wahrscheinlich schon 30.
Okay, einen Run machen wir noch.
Train ich...
Bald könnte ich mir sogar noch SOS kaufen, aber da muss ich...
Longwind wieder wechseln.
Dingsbecken.
Battlesongs.
Erster Resi-Song.
Schwert.
Was brauche ich nicht?
Okay, weißt du.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Resi-Songs.
Body Spirit Energy 8.
Na, das bringt es hier noch nicht so richtig.
Resi-Songs sind eh sehr situationsabhängig, auch später.
Übrigens, so nice ist permanent endo-Sprint.
Also permanent endo-Sprint.
permanent Sprint. Wenn man einen Charmy in der Gruppe
hat, der hat so einen Ausdauer-Buff
und mit Ausdauer-Reduce-Buff, wir können
einfach unendlich lang rennen. Wenn sie halt
rennen würden, rennt halt
Leute, drückt Sprint.
Da vorne ist doch was, ne.
Drückt Sprint, drückt Sprint.
Oh, da vorne sind wieder
Mids, Hips. Ist das der
Bade, ist das der Bade, den ich erwischt hab? Ich hoffe,
ich hoffe, es ist der Bade.
Problem ist, wir verlieren die halbe Gruppe.
Wir verlieren die halbe, die, die
turnen am, am, am Berg.
Die turnen jetzt hier gleich.
Leute, wir sind viel zu sp...
Wir haben die halbe Gruppe,
wir haben die halbe Gruppe verloren.
Alter, the fuck.
Jetzt hab ich den Bade nicht mehr
angeklickt. Das ist so fail. Ich muss vorne
rennen, um den Bade zu interrupten.
Aber, ja, jetzt ist es vorbei.
Leute, ihr müsst halt einfach den
Sprint-Button drücken, man. So schwer ist es doch
nicht.
Okay, komm. Wir hauen jetzt, wir
kloppen jetzt schnell den Charmy weg hier, zack.
Bam.
Passt auf, die enden uns wieder,
während wir fighten. Ich sag's euch, die enden uns.
Direkt. Die enden uns direkt wieder rein.
Die warten schon drauf. Die warten drauf, dass die rein
enden können. Okay, ich verteile mich schon mal.
Ich verteile mich schon mal, weil ich wette mit euch,
die Inkenklei. Die warten nur,
dass wir fighten. Okay.
Nichts zu sehen.
Jetzt machen wir Deserter.
Da oben sind garantiert Hips, oder die Hips warten
am Deserter-Spot. Ich würde auch am Deserter-Spot
warten.
Die warten an der Seite,
warten, bis wir Deserter machen.
Und dann gibt's auf den Sack.
Leute, ihr müsst doch einfach nur den Sprint-Button
drücken, Mensch.
Okay, Leute, ich
bleib jetzt mal ein Stückchen weg.
Die kriegen die auch ohne mich
gekillt.
Und ich will im Zweifelsfall den Typ
interrupten, der
uns gleich das Leben schwer macht.
Weil wir haben dies...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
Kollege. So nicht, du Pisser.
So nicht.
Habt ihr gesehen, wie er unseren Caster
stelzen wollte, der Infi?
Aber nicht, wenn ich daneben stehe,
Kollege. So nicht.
Ink.
Ich bleib auf dem Clary.
Oh, shit.
Nein, Hilfs!
Okay, Alps.
Oh, noch mehr. Okay, wir sind dead.
Wir sind dead.
Wir können die auf die Alps vielleicht
ein bisschen umlenken.
Alter, die Hips sehen alle gleich aus,
dass da Bade.
Auf den müssen wir.
Äh, zu viele.
Zu viele. Keine Chance.
Machste nix.
Da wird er geaddert.
Er ist fucked, man.
Leute, die gehen im Chat gerade
wieder ab, man.
Alter, das ist Battleground.
Du hast hier nix großartig.
Ich sag euch,
es ist in Dark auch so,
du hast so ein paar Leute, die können es über die Flippen
immer aus.
Wenn sie mal sterben.
Und bis dahin geht dieser...
Ja, war nicht so etwas.
Die...
Die rasten immer aus.
Und...
Ich... Also, ich war früher ähnlich
in Dark, ja? Ich hab so oft
übelst Elite 8 vs. 8 und alles ist
Kacke und so. So richtig, so richtig
Dark Elite Kack-Spaß
war ich früher.
Mittlerweile bin ich viel entspannter, was das angeht.
Ich mein, hallo, das ist ein 20 Jahre
altes Game. Ein Game,
wo absolut kein Hahn
mehr danach kräht, ob du da drin
jetzt abgehst oder nicht, außer für
dich selbst. Ein Game, wo
wir froh sein können, wenn
neue Leute reinkommen. Ein Game, wo wir froh
sein können, dass es überhaupt noch Server dafür gibt.
Es... Wir sind doch auch
20 Jahre älter mittlerweile, man.
Wir sind keine 20 mehr, 18 mehr
und irgendwelche Rage-Kiddies
oder so. Ich verstehe die
Leute nicht, man. Die sind... Wisst ihr?
Ich versteh's ja, wenn man irgendwie so
16 ist und so und super... Kommt,
Competitive Multiplayer und so.
Aber, ey, die Leute sind 40.
Die sind so alt wie ich heute. Gut, ich bin noch nicht ganz
40. Die sind so alt wie ich heute.
Die sollen mal ein bisschen... Die sollen sich
mal ein bisschen abriegen.
Ich bin auch übelst abgefuckt von dummen
Mitspielern, ja. Das ist immer so. Okay.
Nice. Hoffentlich kommen die mit
hier. Ich bin auch übelst
abgefuckt von dummen Mitspielern. Aber die
hier sind nicht dumm. Die sind... Die sind
neu. Die sind ein bisschen unkoordiniert,
weil sie noch nicht zusammen vorhergespielt
haben an sich. Die vergessen zu sprinten.
Aber das ist Battleground.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
So nicht, Kollege. So nicht.
So nicht.
So nicht. So nicht.
So, ich muss gucken, wenn der
Bade... Fuck, der Bade kommt raus.
Der Bade ist dumm. Der Bade hat geheilt
anstatt zu metzen. Sehr gut.
Alter, kann mal irgendjemand die
fucking Heiler interrupten? Ich muss auf dem Bade
bleiben. Sonst ist... Rip. Rip
ist sonst, ey.
Und wenn der Caster frei ist,
ist es auch Rip.
Gut. Gut.
Alter, ich kann nicht mehr interrupten. Kannst vergessen.
Kannst du nicht machen.
Was willst du machen? Ja.
Was willst du machen? Es sah aber schon ganz gut aus.
Ich sag euch, die Hips,
das ist keine reine
Random-Gruppe. Ich gehe davon aus, dass da
die einen oder anderen so
drei, vier bestimmt öfters auch
schon zusammenspielen. Was siehst du
denen auch an? Weil die sich
gegenseitig in Targets abruten und sowas?
Alpsink.
Alter, das sind alle tot.
So. Level 28.
Ich mache jetzt noch ein paar
Frontier-Tasks. Ich habe keinen Bock mehr
auf Battle-Crowned.
Ach, guck mal. Ach, das ist wahrscheinlich
der Main-Scharf von Danik.
Okay. Ich...
Ich porte mal.
Ich frag mal. Oder wollen sie noch
einen Run machen?
Ich frag mal, ob sie noch einen Run machen.
Okay, einen Run wollen sie noch machen.
Ah ja, gut. Dann wollen wir mal nicht sein.
Wir haben es ja nicht eilig. Wie gesagt,
wir sind ein 20 Jahre altes Game.
Wir können froh sein, dass es noch läuft.
Ist doch gut.
Ist doch gut. Wir sollten einfach nicht so sehr
auf Elite-krasse
Orgas-Gruppe machen, sondern noch ein paar andere Mids mitnehmen.
Weil...
Dann läuft es auch besser.
Man muss auch sagen,
also die Target-Wahl
der Leute ist nicht
so optimal.
Der BD macht es ganz gut.
Wir haben auch zwei BDs.
Ähm.
Also ich kann nicht mehr machen als
Bade-Truide.
Versuchen einen davon vielleicht zu killen sogar.
Sobald ein Caster frei wird,
musst du eigentlich
dort auch versuchen, weil sonst bist du tot.
Atheno, danke für den Sub.
Ansonsten, mal schauen. Ich hoffe, die anderen Mids kommen mit.
Es wäre sehr nice,
wenn die mitkommen.
Auf, komm mit.
Midis, hopp, hopp, mitkommen.
Komm mit.
Heller.
Die Mids machen immer auf Elite, Mann.
Ist das WoW 2?
Alpha.
Moment, hier vorne sind Alps.
Äh.
Voll in den Quickcast reingerannt.
Aber pass auf, jetzt enden uns die Hips,
während wir hier stehen.
In dem jetzt wäre Poggers.
Nice.
Sag mal, kam jetzt erst, Atheno, kam jetzt erst der Sound,
dass du subscribed hast?
Super lahm, Alter.
So, was müssen wir überhaupt noch killen?
Frogs? Frogs müssen wir killen.
Dann lasst uns doch mal mit den anderen Mids laufen.
Ist doch ganz easy.
Oh, die machen Bäume. Ich mach keine Bäume mehr.
Ich mach keine Bäume mehr, Leute.
Ich hab genug Bäume in diesem BG gekillt.
Ich mach keine Bäume mehr.
Dann mach ich lieber Frontier-Quests.
Wasser-Buff? Wasser-Buff?
Der hat keine Endo mehr?
Ah, der hat nicht die richtigen RRs gespeckt.
Alter.
Was ist hier los?
Der hat nicht die richtigen RRs gespeckt.
Und wie wär's mit Tauchen, Kollege?
Tauchen, tauchen.
Hat keinen Bock, will gesehen werden.
War da oben was?
War da oben ein Gegner? Kann das sein?
Ich hab's nur ganz kurz gesehen.
Ne. Oder?
Ne.
Sind die zwei Mids?
Frogs! Jawoll, mach die Frogs.
Die brauchen wir für Exp.
Ach ja, übrigens, in jedem See kann man tauchen,
aber meistens ist da nix drin.
Man kann super rumklitschen mit Tauchen,
weil die Leute eigentlich richtig hitten können,
wenn man permanent ab- und auftaucht.
Also da kann man schon etwas nerven,
wenn man es drauf anlegt.
Hab ich eigentlich Tokens?
Prima-Token.
Ja, da sollten wir mal ein paar abgeben vielleicht.
Wir können nicht Turn-In, weil wir Albs sind.
Äh, nicht Albs sind.
Wem gehört denn das Keep?
Äh, Moment, wie?
Oh, ich hab vergessen,
wie man das guckt.
Slash Realm?
Kennt man das so?
Ne.
Okay, keine Ahnung mehr,
wie man erkennt...
Ach, M?
Ne, ich weiß nicht mal,
wie man erkennt, welcher Realm.
Hat er das hier nicht?
Battle Crowns?
Ne.
Keine Ahnung mehr,
wie man erkennt, wer Battle Crown Keeps hat.
Irgendwie erkennt man das.
Ich mein, man erkennt's,
wenn man ranläuft und sich die Fahne anguckt.
Was?
Gibt's Slash BG?
Oder sowas?
Ne.
Keine Ahnung.
Low IQ, richtig.
Kreisel-Criant.
Braindead Kreisel-Criant.
Du-du-du-du.
Übrigens, ich find die Fantasy-Musik übelst entspannend im Hintergrund.
So, wo sind die Frogs?
Da unten ist ein Frog, dann haben wir die Quest fertig.
Qu-Quest.
Quest is done.
Ausge-Quested.
Da vorne!
Hips.
Ein Solo-Hip.
Die Leute checken's wieder.
Wieder nicht.
Nope.
Weckt.
Ah, der Lurikin-Schrei, wenn sie sterben, ist der Beste.
Uuuuuh.
Erzähl etwas über das Ziel, noch nie davon gehört.
Hat es zur Zeit das Game rausgekommen?
Noch ne Windel an.
Boah, ich hab viereinhalb Sto-
fünf Stunden über das Game geredet jetzt.
Ähm.
Also,
es ist aus meiner Sicht,
ja, wir, wir turnen jetzt die Tokens in.
Ähm.
Also, es ist aus meiner Sicht das beste PvP-Game, was es gibt.
Sicherlich kommen jetzt die Leute um die Ecke.
Oh, aber Guild Wars, aber Elder Scrolls Online, was auch immer.
Ist aus meiner Sicht das beste PvP-Game.
Und, ach guck mal, da sind die Lapps wieder.
Die Lapps.
Guck mal, da sind sie.
Da müssen wir nicht hin, Leute.
Wir, wir will- wir wollen doch jetzt nicht,
mit sieben Leuten, das Keep raiden, ohne Ramme.
Okay, wir haben den Siege-Giant.
Der Typ kann wieder nicht sprinten.
Ich mein, ganz ehrlich, ich nehm das.
Das BG geht bis 29.
Sollten wir das schaffen, nehm ich das mit.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass wir's schaffen können.
Die Hexe wird einen guten Aemerts rauskriegen und uns bashen danach.
Aber, ähm, also, es gibt einen Faktor, den Darok zum besten, also, von den Voraussetzungen her,
zum besten PvP- bestem PvP-Game ever macht.
Das ist, weil's drei unterschiedliche Fraktionen gibt.
PvP-Game muss drei Fraktionen haben, dass es nicht unbalanced und nervig wird.
Das hat Darok gezeigt und viel zu wenig Spiele aufgegriffen.
Und man hat's heute schon so oft gesehen,
die Fights wären einfach nicht gut gewesen,
gäbe es nicht drei verschiedene Fraktionen, ja?
Du addest in den Fight rein, wo zwei kämpfen.
Du kämpfst, wirst von der Seite geaddert.
Du ziehst dich raus, du, ähm, machst nochmal ne Runde, gehst nochmal neu drauf, um dann...
Also, es hat, es gibt im Spiel einfach so viele...
Alter, was macht...
Ähm, what the f...
Was macht unser Siege-Giant?
Unser Siege-Giant will sterben, glaub ich.
Leute, das hat keinen Sinn.
Kommt mal weg hier, kommt mal weg.
Das hat keinen Sinn, kommt mal weg.
Kommt mal weg.
Der Siege-Giant, was?
Wie der da rumbackt.
Wir müssen übrigens unbedingt...
Okay, ich geh auch mal hin.
Wir müssen unbedingt die Wachen killen.
Weil der Siege-Giant stirbt schon...
Leute, ihr müsst ran!
Da können die nix machen...
Oh Gott!
Die stellen sich an!
The fuck, Alter!
Ihr müsst ran, da hinten werden...
Okay, ich hau jetzt auch ab.
Ich hau jetzt auch ab.
Wenn ihr euch unten ran stellt, können die von da oben nix machen.
Wenn ihr euch natürlich in Caster-Range stellt, dann seid ihr dead.
Aber ich will mich nicht beschweren.
Wie gesagt, wir haben neue Leute in der Gruppe.
Man muss das alles lernen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Herr Sarra-Zähne.
Fuck, der hat mein Metz resistet.
Der Kack-Noob.
Alle ran, alle ran, dann können die nix machen.
Ich meine, ich rede mit mir selbst hier.
Warum greife ich eigentlich so langsam an?
Beziehungsweise, warum greife ich denn eigentlich gar nicht an?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Lasst euch nicht rausziehen, dann könnt ihr genugt werden von oben.
Sag mal, was ist mit der Vision und den...
Alter!
Was ist mit den Guards los?
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Die backen so krass rum.
Na, kann die nicht hinten?
Guck mal, ich kann die nicht hinten.
Die sind nicht möglich, die zu treffen.
Das ist so krass verbuggt gerade.
Man kann die nicht hinten.
Okay, jetzt.
Jetzt, jetzt.
Wachen geben übrigens auch gut Exp.
Okay.
Jetzt erst mal langsam.
Ich mache mal Speed für die Heiler an, dass die sich besser positionieren können.
Hendo?
Haben wir eine Ramme?
Auf, kommt rein, Leute.
Oh, zu viele Alps, zu viele Alps.
Raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus.
No chance.
Keine Chance.
Keine Chance, Leute.
Nicht reinrennen!
Alter!
Okay.
Komm.
Sterben wir halt da drinnen.
Let's go.
Der Relikt-Dude.
Guckt euch, guckt euch das Elend an, Mann.
Ich, ich...
Man weiß es halt schon.
Man weiß es halt einfach schon, ey.
Du flötest meinen Heiler nicht, ey.
Weiß es halt einfach schon.
Oh, das ist ein Reaver!
Oder ein Heretic? Wahrscheinlich ein Heretic.
Okay.
Weißt du was?
Ich bin raus, Leute. Ich bin raus.
Ich bin raus.
Also ich bin, mach nicht den Stream aus.
Ich hau aus dem WG ab.
Ich mein, noch ein halbes Level
bis Max Level, kein Ding.
Ihr könnt es euch aussuchen.
Ihr könnt es euch aussuchen, Chat.
Wir sind jetzt schon 5 Stunden am Start.
Also, ich bin da entspannt.
Ich bin auch noch eine Weile online.
Ach, die Stelle anzeigen.
Nein, mach ich jetzt.
Mach ich jetzt.
Okay, die hauen alle ab.
Dann hau ich auch ab.
Okay.
Ich guck mir das an, sobald wir in Sicherheit im Keep sind.
So, Leute.
Überrede die jetzt dazu,
mit mir Frontier-Quests zu machen.
Brauch ich ein neues Schwert?
Abgeben. Quest.
Okay, wir machen ein F-Quest.
Wir machen ein F-Quest.
Ich muss jetzt mal
gleich afk
mir was zu trinken holen und was zu essen.
Aber erstmal,
dass die nicht abhauen.
Die NF-Quests holen.
Okay, das können wir.
Ich sell das mal schnell.
Sell.
Sell, sell, sell.
Oh, wir haben 100 Trinkets noch.
Krass.
Hätte ich das mal ingeturnt, ey.
Hätte nochmal,
bisschen Level gegeben.
Improved Necklace.
Dex.
Melee.
Parry plus 4.
Na ja.
Haben wir da zum Vergleich so
Magic Spells.
Okay, auf jeden Fall das.
Eins ist besser.
Äh, zwei besser.
Was hat das?
Melee Weapons.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Weg.
Ring.
Äh, Strength 50, okay, das ist nicht schlecht.
Weg, weg.
Okay, mal gucken, für den Fall der Fälle, dass wir da nochmal ins BG gehen, aber ich glaube
eher nicht.
Ähm.
Hmm.
Constitution, Matter, Strength.
Ja.
Nämlich.
Äh.
Okay.
Was haben wir hier?
Body, Melee, Weapons.
Okay, nice.
Next, let's go.
Okay.
Oh, okay, ich bin wieder da.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
No.
No, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Neeen.
Neen, 1930.
Neenen.
1991.
Ja.
Also, ist keine europ气, days to money.
Nö.
Ja.
Ja, okay, ja.
Okay.
Mit da unten da unten ist was moment für die killen tatsächlich
Ausbildung zum fachinformatische systemintegration mwd ok wir gucken ich muss bloß irgendwie afk hinlaufen
ohne dass meine gruppe irgendwie
verloren geht unterwegs
braucht kein port dessen chamois
an jetzt gar kein chamois das ist ein bonbon tänzer hubs
Ja ja ich kann als schlechtes lesen und und rennen dabei das ist das ist es gibt noch offizielles server ja ja
aber
Das ist ein community server zum glück weil die offiziellen server am kommen auch spieler so hier
die müssen gepasht werden jetzt
ok also hast du im rahmen deiner ausbildung beschäftigst du dich mit der gesamten wahl bei technologien 6
die wir für uns ganz okay
so relativ
08 15
kann alles sein
das bedeutet konkret du erhältst einblicke in nahezu alle server fahren mit betriebssystemen wie linux unix und windows haben die wirklich noch
unix am start oder schreiben wir das einfach die rechnung irgendein solaris oder
hpx oder irgendwie sowas in der richtung am start kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen
ich glaube das schreiben die einfach nur mehr
mehr ibm mainframe wahrscheinlich ja das kann das kann schon sein
haben wir noch was aber irgendwo hier ist noch ein gegner
und
und auch mainframe steht ja auch da und auch mainframe
was soll man hier killen eigentlich die da hier den soll man bashen wahrscheinlich guck mal
und martin team
team team
team
Er lasst sie erst mal alles bashen alles was da ist
alles was da ist wird gepasht
und die freie dienstbombs müssen wir noch bashen
ich muss jetzt reggen und wer nicht regge
guck ich bin die rest an
mainframe wird ein bestandteil der ausbildung sein außer mit netzwerk und sicherheitslösung machst du dich unter anderem mit der das auch so 08 15 begriff
datenbank und bank fachlichen applikationen vertraut zudem beschreibt es du mit uns den weg zur digitalen transformation unser kund innen
mwd hier lernst du verschiedene cloud lösungen der fox kennen
ist schon so ist der waage aber ist jetzt nicht irgendwie
schlecht oder so
ließ sich ganz gut von den farmen würde ich fast sagen sparkasse
aber
Es könnte auch die bahn sein
Aber das passt ja mit finanz wiederum nicht kommt mein group geht es halt einfach gleich viel einfacher
Das ist übrigens das was meine
In dark ist halt einfach nice
Wenn man crupt es geht es geht so gut wie alles besser in group
Aber hier noch irgendwie mobs ich sehe nämlich nichts mehr keine mobs mehr
Wo sind wo sind diese komischen snowman
das normal wieder am start
Ich könnte auch mana und ende laufen lassen eigentlich
Klasse mana und ende laufen in richtung sparkasse
aber hinten was gesehen
einfach nur responde mobs in respond
und kurz was trinken lauten
So, also, ich muss euch dran erinnern, wir sind immer noch im Grenzgebiet.
Hier könnte potenziell jederzeit ein Gegner vorbeikommen.
Allerdings, an der Stelle ist es nicht so wahrscheinlich, da hier ein Tor dazwischen ist.
Und da kommt eigentlich keiner durch, es seien dann alle unsere Festungen wurden erobert.
Und das ist ja nicht der Fall.
Deswegen, alles iets.
Oh, ich brauche neue Schwerter.
Und neue Armlinge.
Äh, irgendwo hier ist angeblich auch noch ein Named.
Hier muss noch ein Named sein, der sich Prey oder Frey oder so nennt.
Weil wir da mal schauen müssen, was Irish Sea, wir sind nicht Irish Sea, wir sind Upland sind wir.
Upland, so und als nächstes.
Ah, hier ist der Dude oder was?
Ist ja kacke.
Da müssen wir in die andere Grenzfestung.
Okay, dann gehen wir mal zurück.
Alter, nicht da durchrennen.
Wie ich so Mobs hasse, die einfach random spawnen irgendwo im Weg.
Okay.
Danach sind wir, okay, jetzt sind wir auf jeden Fall 30 gleich.
Und dann können wir nochmal ins andere BG gucken.
Vielleicht.
PvP-technisch.
Und wir machen Frontier-Quests.
Der Typ hat keine Endu, Mann.
Braun.
Ich muss dem sagen, dass er...
Dass er Longwind kaufen soll für mehr Sprint.
Nice.
Next.
Ordentliche Quests.
Okay.
Du-du-du-du-du.
Äh, wo ist...
Wo ist Slashtop?
Äh, Slashtop ist irgendwie AFK.
Nee, Slashtop zählt gerade.
Okay.
Nice.
Ein Greatsword.
Okay.
Let's go.
Neues Schwert, kann nix schaden.
Och Gott.
Lass mich in Ruhe, Schneemann.
So, jetzt müssen wir aufhören.
Aufpassen.
Denn, wenn man durch dieses...
Alter, Schneemann.
Verpiss dich.
Wenn man durch dieses Tor geht,
dann ist man offiziell so richtig im RVR-Gebiet.
Wo müssen wir überhaupt hin?
Nach Osten.
Dann ist man so richtig im RVR-Gebiet.
Und jetzt hab ich das Problem,
jetzt müsste ich eigentlich...
Das ist mein Problem.
Jetzt müsste ich irgendwie meine Position verstecken mit Chico.
Weil es gibt immer ganz tolle Leute,
die Stream snipen.
Auch in DAWG.
Für ein paar Graue.
Pass mal auf.
Chico...
Chico muss größer werden.
Nice.
Perfekt.
Leute.
Chico hidet jetzt die Map.
Riesen-Chico, ja.
Oh Mann.
Man muss halt was sagen, dass er Stickloss hat, man.
Sag mal.
Die sind ja alle wieder richtig planlos, ja.
Beim puren gerade Auslaufen verlieren wir schon die Hälfte der Gruppe.
Sechsen.
Äh, nee.
33 gibt's gelben Speed.
Ja.
Das ist übrigens auch der Grund...
Wisst ihr, was wir machen?
Nee.
Das ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum BDs so gut sind.
Leute, ich hab ne Idee.
Wir machen das anders.
Zack.
Chico?
Du schrumpfst mal wieder.
Und...
Die Map kommt einfach über den Chat.
Ja.
Da seht ihr ja auch nix.
Wobei.
Okay.
Man sieht, man sieht genug.
Man sieht genug, ne?
Man sieht genug.
Man sieht genug, dass man uns findet, wahrscheinlich.
Wenn man sich echt drauf anlegt.
Wenn man sich echt drauf anlegt, findet man was.
Aber ich mein, scheiß drauf.
Komm.
Wenn's einer wirklich snipen will, ein paar Graue.
Was brauchen wir eigentlich?
Ja.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was wir alles brauchen als...
Als Mobs.
Okay.
Anschein...
Anscheinend alles.
Alles, was es hier gibt, brauchen wir als Mobs.
Okay.
Die...
Die Scrags brauchen wir nicht.
Äh.
Skeletons brauchen wir.
Skeletons.
Okay.
Oh.
Nice.
Ein Named.
Bogu.
Ja, Riesen-Chico ist wieder weg.
Ich glaube, Leute, das ist heute echt der längste Stream, den ich in ganz langer Zeit gemacht hab.
Bäume sind etwas im Weg.
Oh, nice.
Wir haben ne Welt dabei.
Das heißt, wir haben sogar einen Heiler, der ein bisschen, bisschen heilen kann.